THE
SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY
A TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY
ALL MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
. WE'LL BE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
ALSO PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR
OUR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS.
THIS WILL GREATLY AID IN
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT
YOU USE THAT RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
A POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON
MUTE. PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING OUR I.
T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK
ON MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING
ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. I
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. HE WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. THE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 THE ACCESS CODE IS
THREE FIVE THREE ONE TWO EIGHT
THREE. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
AND OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY BECAUSE AN OPERATOR
WILL THEN ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME HE
WILL BE ON MUTE IT AND YOU ARE
NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. ALL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEDIAN SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
LASTLY FOR EVERYONE PHYSICALLY
PRESENT HERE TODAY PLEASE KEEP
YOUR MASKS ON COVERING YOUR NOSE
AND MOUTH AT ALL TIMES. BANDA
NOW WE'RE- READY TO MOVE ON- I
JUST WANT TO SAY A FEW WORDS AS
WE BEFORE WE GO ON TO THE ISSUES
BEFORE US- BUT YOU KNOW LAST
YEAR WE STRENGTHENED ACCESS TO
WORKERS RIGHTS AND PROTECTIONS.
AND WE STRIVE TO MAKE HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS IN OUR WORKFORCE
WITH A FOCUS ON HIGH ROAD JOBS
AND TRAINING. THIS YEAR THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
HIGHER LEVELS OF SPENDING IN
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT ACROSS
MANY DIFFERENT SECTORS SO WE'RE
WE WILL COVER A NUMBER OF
PROPOSALS TODAY. AND ADDITIONAL
OVERSIGHT ITEMS ON LAST YEAR'S
AGREEMENTS AND SO FIVE HEARINGS
LATER IN THE SPRING. I WANT TO
COMMEND THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
THE PARTNERSHIP I'M PROUD THAT
OUR STATE IS IN A POSITION TO
PUT FORTH SUCH INVESTMENTS. WE
KNOW NOW THAT THIS PANDEMIC HAS
PERMANENTLY CHANGED OUR WAY OF
LIFE OUR ECONOMY AND OUR
INSTITUTIONS MUST AND WILL
CHANGE WE MUST MAKE OUR
INVESTMENTS MORE WORKER CENTRIC.
THESE HEARINGS THEREFORE ARE
VERY IMPORTANT AND UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITIES TO GIVE THE KIND
OF DIRECTION AND STRUCTURE TO
THOSE INVESTMENTS INVESTMENTS
THAT WE'RE MAKING IN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE ROBUST PIPELINES TO GOOD
JOBS HIGHER WAGES AND PROVIDE
QUALITY TRAINING. UP FROM
EVERYWHERE FROM THE KAREN
ECONOMY TO LOGISTICS AND CLIMATE
FRIENDLY NEW JOBS AND SECTORS-
OVERALL ARE FUNDING DECISIONS
MUST ALSO INCLUDE ENFORCEABLE
JOB COMMITMENTS AW AND THE SHIFT
TOWARD MODERN AND RESILIENT
CLEAN- FEATURES. AW THERE FOR
OUR AGAIN OUR QUESTIONS TODAY IN
THE INFORMATION TODAY ARE
INTENDED TO HELP OF DIRECT THE
FUNDING DECISIONS. LIFT UP
LETTERS UP THOSE WORKER
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE PAID LOW
WAGES AND LIVE IN POVERTY AND
LETTERS ASSERTIVELY CRAFT AND
LET'S DESIGN AN ECONOMY. THAT
CREATES NEW CAREERS AND JOBS
THAT DON'T ANA WHERE PEOPLE
DON'T FEAR THEY WILL BE
REPLACED. WE PLACE TO A YOU KNOW
WITH- LOW WAGE JOBS IF THEY'RE
GETTING PAID- GOOD SALARIES
RIGHT NOW SO WITH THAT. GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
SENATORS- IF YOU WOULD LIKE
ANYTHING TO SAY WE CAN MOVE ON
TO OUR FIRST FIRST ISSUE. OKAY
OF THE FIRST WE WANT TO WELCOME
OUR NEW SECRETARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY. US SECRETARY
NATALIE BLUE GI I HOPE I SAID
THAT RIGHT THE SECRETARY WELCOME
AND- LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
COMMENTS TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD MORNING. CHAIR DRAWS
ON MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY AND
TO SPEND A FEW MINUTES FRAMING
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY. IT
IS AN HONOR OF A LIFETIME TO BE
HERE SERVING AS CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST LATINO LABOR SECRETARY
PARTICULARLY AT THIS CRUCIAL
MOMENT IN WHICH THE STATE'S
PANDEMIC RECOVERY IS TAKING
PLACE ALONGSIDE OTHER
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC SHIFTS.
RELATED TO CLIMATE AND HEALTH
CARE. THE BUDGET THAT WILL BE
DISCUSSED HERE TODAY IS VERY
INTENTIONALLY FOCUSED ON
ENSURING THAT THE LABOR AGENCY
REMAINS WELL POSITIONED TO HELP
EMPLOYERS AND WORKERS MEETING
NEW DEMANDS CREATED BY THE
INTERSECTION OF THESE ECONOMIC
SHIFTS. BEFORE I START I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE MY COLLEAGUES WHO ARE
HERE WITH ME TODAY THEY ARE THE
AGENCY LEADERS WHO REPRESENT
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
SERVE AND SUPPORT THE
ENFORCEMENT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND BENEFITS
ADMINISTRATION ECOSYSTEM. THAT
SUPPORTS OUR WORKERS AND THEIR
EMPLOYERS. THEIR WORK AND THEIR
DEDICATION CANNOT BE OVERSTATED
AND I'M SO GRATEFUL FOR THEIR
CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO THEIR
GREAT AND THEIR TIRELESS WORK
BOTH THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC. AS
WELL AS WE ENTER THIS NEW STAGE
OF ECONOMIC GROWTH. SO THE
CHANGES THAT WE'VE ALL
EXPERIENCED THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC HAVE HAD SPECIFIC
IMPACTS ON THE LABOR AGENCIES
WORK AND OUR MISSION AND I'D
LIKE TO MENTION A FEW OF THESE
IMPACTS. FIRST WE'RE WORKING TO
ADDRESS. NEW WORKFORCE DEMANDS
IN SECTORS SUCH AS HEALTH CARE
AND ENERGY WHILE ALSO FACING
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGES RELATED
TO HIRING AND RETENTION. SECOND
WHILE WE WORK TO SUPPORT SHARED
VALUES AROUND CARBON NEUTRALITY
AND CLIMATE JUSTICE FOR
COMMUNITIES WE FACE A
SIGNIFICANT RESPONSIBILITY TO
SUPPORT WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS IN
THIS TRANSITION IN INDUSTRIES
AND TO DO SO IN A MANNER THAT
PRESUMES LESS AND LISTENS MORE.
THIRD AS WHICH AND WE FEEL
GRATEFUL FOR ECONOMIC RECOVERY
AND PROMISING FUTURE WE MUST DO
SO WHILE FOCUSING ON SOME
DIFFICULT TRUTHS THAT THE
PANDEMIC ON COVERED. IT IS FACT
THAT PERVASIVE ECONOMIC AND
SOCIAL INJUSTICES CONTINUE TO
EXIST AND HAVE GROWN OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL DECADES. IT IS FACT
THAT THESE INEQUITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY ADVERSELY AND
DIRECTLY IMPACT OUR COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR WOMEN INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES VETERANS RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND HEARTBREAKINGLY
BUT OFTEN FORGOTTEN OR USE. IT
IS ALSO A FACT THAT THE
DISCONNECTION AND POVERTY THAT
INEQUITY PERPETUATES RESULTING
GROWING SOCIAL COSTS FOR
EVERYONE AND LIMITS AND PLACES
LIMITS ON HOW QUICKLY WE CAN
RESPOND TO AND ADAPT TO THE
DEMANDS OF OUR SHIFTING ECONOMY
. THIS BUDGET RECOGNIZES THESE
TRUTHS AND OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
RESHAPE AND REIMAGINE OUR STATE
PROGRAMS TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
OUR EVOLVING ECONOMY WILL ALSO
LIBERATING OURSELVES FROM THE
STUBBORN AND PERVASIVE
INEQUITIES. AND SPEAKING OF
INEQUITY WE HEAR THIS TERM IS SO
MUCH THESE DAYS IN THE MEDIA AND
POLITICS AND ACADEMIA EVEN IN
OUR OWN POLICY AND OPERATIONAL
DISCUSSIONS. BUT THE GROSS
INJUSTICES ON THE COSTS THAT
INEQUITY CREATES WON'T DISAPPEAR
SIMPLY BECAUSE WE WILL HAVE TO
DISAPPEAR OR BECAUSE WE PAT
OURSELVES ON THE BACK FOR A
KNOWLEDGE IN THAT THEY EXIST. AT
THE LABOR AGENCY WE INTO COMBAT
IN EQUITY BY REMOVING SYSTEMIC
BARRIERS FOR POPULATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED
FROM OUR WORKFORCE AND TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES. BY DISRUPTING THE
STATUS QUO AND BEING READY TO
REIMAGINE AND TAX STRATEGIES
THAT CREATE BROADER SYSTEMS
CHANGE AND BY PUSHING FOR
SYSTEMS CHANGE WHICH RECOGNIZES
THAT MEETING THE NEEDS OF THOSE
HARDEST TO SERVE BOTH IN OUR
WORKER AND EMPLOYER SPACE IS THE
KEY TO SUSTAINABLE A DOCTOR. AND
MEANINGFUL ECONOMIC TRANSITION
TRANSFORMATION. GROWTH AND
PROSPERITY FOR EVERYONE. INVEST
IN THIS BUDGET AND OUR
COMMITMENT TO EXECUTING THEM
WITH A FOCUS ON COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS. EMPOWERMENT AND
INNOVATION AIMED TO DO JUST THAT
MEET THE DEMANDS OF THE FUTURE
ECONOMY WHILE ASO LIFTING UP
THOSE DISCONNECTED FROM THE
CURRENT ECONOMY. THE BUDGET ALSO
RECOGNIZES THAT WE CAN'T MAKE
THIS CHANGE ALONE OUR BUSINESSES
ARE ENTREPRENEURS ARE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE THE PIONEERS
OF ECONOMIC TRANSITIONS THE
MARRIAGE AND REQUIRE SUPPORT TO
SUCCESSFULLY MEET THE DEMANDS OF
PIONEERING INTO OUR FUTURE. SO
HOW DO WE GET THERE HOW DO WE
SUPPORT WORKERS BUSINESS AND
COMMUNITIES DURING THIS
TRANSITION WELL MEETING NEW
ECONOMIC DEMANDS BREAKING DOWN
BARRIERS AND MODERNIZING THE WAY
WE SERVE CALIFORNIANS. FOR THE
LABOR AGENCY IT'S ABOUT
INTENTIONAL INVESTMENTS AND
FOCUS ON THE MOST PRESSING
NEEDS. THE BUDGET THAT YOU WILL
DISCUSS IN MORE DETAIL WITH MY
COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY IS DRIVEN
BY A FEW DISTINCT PRIORITIES.
FIRST THE UNDENIABLE AND
PRESSING DEMANDS FOR NEW BETTER
AND MOREINCLUSIVE HEALTH CARE
JOBS AND PATHWAYS THAT WILL LEAD
TO IMPROVED AN EQUITABLE HEALTH
OUTCOMES ACROSS THE STATE.
SECOND WORKFORCE STRATEGIES AND
INNOVATION THAT MEETS OUR
CLIMATE GOALS IN A MANNER THAT
RECOGNIZES THE CHALLENGES FACED
BY TRANSITIONING WORKFORCES AND
OUR COMMUNITIES. THIRD A RENEWED
FOCUS ON THE IMMENSE VALUE OF
CALIFORNIA'S IMMIGRANT WORK
FORCE AND THE RECOGNITION THAT
CONNECTING THEM TO THE EVOLVING
ECONOMY REQUIRES INCREASING
ACCESS TO LANGUAGE AND
VOCATIONAL TRAINING THAT MEETS
BOTH THEIR PERSONAL CAREER
TRAJECTORIES AND THEIR EMPLOYERS
NEEDS. POOREST CONTINUE TO
MONITOR MODERNIZATION OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE SYSTEM TO
IMPROVE CLAIM ACCESS AND
EXPERIENCE BOTH WHILE ENSURING
LONG TERM RESILIENCE AND KEEPING
OUR DOORS SHOT TO FRAUD. AND
LASTLY FIFTH IT GOES WITHOUT
SAYING AS A FORMER FEDERAL
WORKPLACE INVESTIGATOR BUT A
CONTINUED FOCUS ON PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA'S IN CALIFORNIANS IN
THEIR WORKPLACES IS THE BASIC
REQUIREMENT TO ASSURING THE
INCREASE VOICE SAFETY AND
DIGNITY. ALL WORKERS NEED IN
ORDER TO SHAPE THEIR PERSONAL
GROWTH AND MEANINGFULLY
PARTICIPATE IN THE BROADER
ECONOMY. IN CLOSING I WANT TO
REITERATE HOW INNOVATIVE AND
UNPRECEDENTED THIS BUDGET IS. IT
INCLUDES ELEMENTS THAT ALLOW
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE THE HARD
WORK OF RESPONDING TO COLD IT
WILL ALSO SEND YOU A MESSAGE OF
HOPE ABOUT HOW WE CAN RECOVER
DIFFERENTLY AND BETTER THAN
WE'VE DONE IN THE PAST WITH
INVESTMENTS THAT FOCUS O
EXPANDING OPPORTUNITY. CREATING
BALK BROADER ENTRY INTO THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES AND STRENGTHENING
THE FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
WORK FOR SYSTEM AS IT LEADS THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY TOWARD A
SUSTAINABLE FUTURE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND ALL OF THE SUB
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND ALSO YOUR
STAFF FOR THE TIME THAT YOU
SPEND TODAY ALL OF THE WORK YOU
DO OUTSIDE OF HEARINGS LIKE
TODAY'S TO SHAPE POLICY. THAT
SUSTAINS CHANGE AND IMPROVEMENTS
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. MY
LEADERSHIP TEAM IS PRESENT AND
READY TO ADDRESS YOUR QUESTIONS
ABOUT THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THIS CRUCIAL AND
MUCH NEEDED INVESTMENTS IN OUR
WORK FORCE. OUR WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS WHO CARRIED CALIFORNIA
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC DESERVE
NOTHING LESS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WITH THAT I. HANDED
OVER BACK TO YOU FOR ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. AND MY
COLLEAGUES ARE HERE. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MADAM SECRETARY OF WE
WELCOME YOU TO CALIFORNIA TO AND
- WE'RE VERY GLAD TO HAVE YOU-
AS A LEADER AS OUR LEADER ON
THESE ISSUES- WE COULD MOVE ON
TO SEE IF THE L. A- WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS. ACCORDING
TO THE ALAMO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- FOR THIS
INTRODUCTORY ITEM- OUR OFFICE
HAS HAS NO PARTICULAR COMMENTS
BUT WILL BE AVAILABLE- AND HAVE
SOME COMMENTS ON SOME OF THE-
STUFF FOR OTHER ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA THANK YOU. THANK YOU- AND
THE FINANCE DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
I BETTER TOP AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- NO FURTHER COMMENT SAID
THANK YOU. OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL-
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. WE
HAVE A LONG AGENDA YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS RIGHT NOW TO START OFF
. OKAY HEIDI RIGHT QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS I'M SORRY- SENATOR THE
COULD. MISTER FRANCIS TO REDO
THE QUORUM. OKAY I THOUGHT WE
HAD TO WE HAD TO DO THAT OKAY
THANK YOU SKEWS ME. SIR GROWTH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS PERU GI
IDEA I SIT ON THE RULES AND IT
WAS MY HONOR TO CONFIRM YOU AND
THEN ALSO THIS BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE. AND I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS IF YOU'RE
OKAY WITH THAT. IN YOUR
STATEMENT THAT YOU- THAT YOU
OPENED WITH YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
URGENT LABOR SOURCE SHORTAGES
AND ALL ASPECTS OF HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY. YOU TALKED ABOUT- NEW
AND CHANGING- WORK FORCES IN THE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM AND-
SOME OTHER THINGS- I HAVE A
QUESTION ON. THE TO IT HE'S-
WHEN YOU SAID THAT IT MADE ME
THINK OF OUR FRONTLINE WORKERS
IN THE HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY THAT
WERE THERE DURING THE PANDEMIC
IN THE IN AT TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT WERE
SERVING EVERY DAY ON THE FRONT
LINE SAVING LIVES OF
INDIVIDUALS- WHO CAME TO THE
HOSPITAL WITH COATED. AND THEN
THIS YEAR AND THEY HAVE BEEN
TARGETED FOR VACCINE FREEDOM
ISSUES- THERE'S APPROXIMATELY
STILL ALMOST TWELVE THOUSAND
WORKERS THAT HAVE BEEN
TERMINATED TWO THOUSAND FROM
JUST LOS ANGELES AREA KAISER
SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED FROM THE
NORTHERN PART OF CALIFORNIA AND
THEN DONE THE LIST GOES ON-
WE'RE TERMINATING NURSES THAT
HAVE WORKED FOR OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME
YEARS AS A MATTER OF FACT THAT
WERE FRONTLINE HEROES. I'M JUST
TWO YEARS AGO AND NOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT INVESTING IN
TAXPAYER DOLLARS. AND TO RECRUIT
AND BRING IN THE SAME SKILLED
INDIVIDUALS THAT PROVIDE HEALTH
CARE. CAN YOU GIVEME AN
EXPLANATION ON WHY THAT
SOMETHING THAT'S- THAT'S TAKING
PLACE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
PERCENT ARE THANK YOU AND IT'S
GREAT TO SEE YOU AGAIN AS WELL-
I FEEL LIKE WE'VE HAD SEVERAL
MEETINGS IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS-
I EAT I I'D LIKE TO SEE A FEW
THINGS- THE SHORTAGES THAT WE-
ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS IN THIS
BUDGET GOAL WAY BEYOND- THESE
IMMEDIATE SHORTAGES THAT YOU ARE
NOTING DO DETERMINATIONS THAT OF
COURSE THE LABOR AGENCY- DOES
NOT OVERSEE-YOU KNOW THAT WHAT
EMPLOYERS HAVE POLICIES- AND IF
THEY ARE LAYING OFF BECAUSE
EMPLOYEES DON'T NEED TO THOSE
STANDARDS. THAT IS THAT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW WE PLAY
INTO HOWEVER I DO WANT TO MAKE
CLEAR THAT THE SHORTAGES WERE
TALKING ABOUT GO WAY BEYOND WHAT
IS HAPPENING CURRENTLY WHAT YOU
DESCRIBED THE EXISTED PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC IN FACT OUR
FRONTLINE WORKERS HERE AND
ACROSS MANY STATES IN THE
COUNTRY WERE SO STRETCHED THEN.
WERE SO STRESSED OUT OUR BY THE
LEVELS OF INDIVIDUALS COMING IN
WITH COLD AND DYING- AND
OFTENTIMES THEY WERE COMING TO
WORK SICK AS WELL. AND SO ALL OF
THAT TO ME AND THAT YOU KNOW THE
THERE'S ALSO BEEN A LOT OF-
BRINGING WORKERS FROM OUT OF
STATE TO FILL SOME OF THESE
CRITICAL ROLES AND THIS WAS
DURING AN EMERGENCY. THIS
DOESN'T EVEN COVER ALL OF THE
GAPS AND SHORTAGES THAT WE HAVE
HEALTH. IN COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS THE TECHNICIANS THAT THE
GAPS ARE PERVASIVE THE SHORTAGES
ARE PERVASIVE AND I THINK WHAT
YOU DESCRIBE IS A SYMPTOM. OF
WHAT HAS BEEN OCCURRING FOR
SEVERAL DECADES NOW AND SO THIS
THIS BUDGET IS VERY
INTENTIONALLY ATTEMPTING TO
ADDRESS. AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
ECONOMIC DRIVER FOR THE STATE'S
WHICH IS THE HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY
AND IF WE DO NOT INVEST PROPERLY
IN GETTING PEOPLE TRAINED AND
EMPLOYED IN THESE JOBS- WE PUT
THE ENTIRE. SYSTEM AT RISK NOT
ONLY IN TERMS OF HEALTH OUTCOMES
BUT EVEN THE ECONOMIC DRIVER
PIECE OF THIS. I AGREE AND I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR RESPONSE YOU
KNOW THE ASKS FOR ONE POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS INVESTMENT FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT TO CREATE
INNOVATIVE AND ACCESSIBLE
OPPORTUNITIES TO CREATE RECRUIT
TRAIN AND ADVANCE. INCLUSIVE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
WORKFORCE- I UNDERSTAND THAT-
BUT I JUST SAID I UNDERSTAND
THAT WE HAD IT A GAP AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE
THE CALL YOU KNOW THE- THE
AMOUNT OF PERSONAL THAT WE NEED
TO WIN THE PANDEMIC KIT THAT WAS
ALL EVIDENT TO ALL OF US IN OUR
DISTRICTS- I DO UNDERSTAND ALSO
THAT WE BROUGHT IN OUTSIDE-
NURSES FROM DIFFERENT. STATES
AND WE ACTUALLY RAN THEM THROUGH
A I DON'T AS A TEMPORARY
STAFFING BUT WHATEVER THEY CALL
IT FOR THE NURSING INDUSTRY FOR
STAFFING AGENCIES. OR THE
AGENCIES WERE PAID FOR FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS AN HOUR CHARGE
THAT TO THE HOSPITAL'S FIFTY. AM
NURSES THEMSELVES GOT EIGHTY
DOLLARS AN HOUR SO CREATED A
LARGE REVENUE SOURCE. FOR
SOMEBODY WHO WAS JUST HAPPENED
TO BE IN AN INDUSTRY THAT. THAT
CATER TO THAT SPECIFIC THAT
TALENT I GUESS- I STILL DON'T
UNDERSTAND I AGREE THAT WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
FUNDING FOR ADEQUATE HEALTH
CARE. BUT I DON'T UNDERSTAND HIM
AND- THE ISSUE THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO FOCUS ON. IS YOU KNOW THE
ROUGHLY SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
WORKERS THAT ARE LAID OFF THAT
WERE CONSIDERED. IN THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC GOING
TO WORK IN TAKING CARE OF SICK
PATIENTS EVERY SINGLE DAY AND
NOW THEY HAD TO CHOOSE. TO
EITHER KEEP THEIR JOB AS A NURSE
FOR TWO I HAD JUST TEXTED NURSE
IN THAT ORKS FOR KAISER SHE
WORKED THERE FOR THIRTEEN YEARS.
AND BECAUSE SHE REFUSED TO BE
VACCINATED AFTER SHE WORKED IN
THE- THE- RESPIRATORY AREA FOR
COVERT FOR A YEAR AND A HALF-
SHE WAS TERMINATED- SO THAT'S AN
ASSET SOMEBODY'S ALREADY TRAIN
SHE'S LATINA SHE'S GOT FIVE KIDS
SHE'S. JUST AN INCREDIBLE PERSON
AND WE HAVE A WOMAN WHOSE FAMILY
IMMIGRATED HERE FROM MEXICO WHEN
SHE HE'S TERMINATED. SHE REFUSED
TO GET VACCINATED AND SHE'S A
INCREDIBLE ASSET TO OUR HEALTH
CARE INDUSTRY. OKAY ANYMORE
QUESTIONS CENTER NO THANK YOU
OKAY- THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
. AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE AND FOR ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS- WE WILL MOVE ON NOW
TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO- ACTUALLY
ISSUES TO THE FORE UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
ISSUE TWO WHICH IS HIERO
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS FOR HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES- I. WOULD
LIKE TO THE- HIS DEVELOPMENT
BOARD WHO WILL BE SPEAKING ON
THAT I'M PRESENTING. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THIS IS TIM RAINY
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR- I'M
I'M NOT SURE BUT I THINK
POSSIBLY AT LEAST NAY WITH LABOR
AGENCY WAS GOING TO PROVIDE A
SLIGHT OPENING FOR CONTEXT OR-
OR MAYBE I SHOULD BE HAPPY TO DO
THAT. GREAT THANK SEVENTY AND IS
PART OF ISSUE ONE. SO I AM AT
LEAST NAY DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
THE FUTURE OF WORK AT THE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
WHEN I WANT TO THANK YOU SENATOR
DRAW SO AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. FOR BY CHANCE TO
TALK TO YOU FOR A FEW MINUTES
TODAY AS SECRETARY PALU GI-
MENTIONED ACROSS THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
WORKFORCE DEPARTMENTS WE HAVE
THREE MAJOR CROSS CUTTING
INITIATIVES. PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- THAT HAVE
SPECIFIC PROGRAM INVESTMENTS IN
EATING IS WORK FOR SERVICES
BRANCH THE STATE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD AND THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL WHICH
YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT IN GREATER
DETAIL IN THIS MORNING'S
HEARING. AS A VERY BROAD
OVERVIEW THESE THREE INITIATIVES
INVEST IN HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICE AGENCY.
CLIMATE AND GREEN ENERGY
WORKFORCE IN COLLABORATION WITH
CAL START WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION WITH NATURAL
RESOURCES AND OTHER STATE
AGENCIES. AND IMMIGRANT ECONOMIC
MOBILITY INITIATIVE IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE GOVERNOR
SENIOR ADVISER ON IMMIGRATION.
WITH DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. AND THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
JUST A FEW MINUTES ON THE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE INITIATIVE
AND AS OUR SECRETARY MENTIONED
THIS BUDGET INCLUDES A ONE TIME
ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT. OVER THREE YEARS AND
HEALTH CARE ECONOMY AND
HEALTHCARE ECONOMIES WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT TO CREATE MORE
INNOVATIVE AND ACCESSIBLE
OPPORTUNITIES TO RECRUIT TRAIN
HIGHER AND ADVANCED AN
ETHNICALLY AND CULTURALLY
INCLUSIVE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES WORKFORCE WITH IMPROVE
DIVERSITY. BETTER WAGES AND
BETTER HEALTH EQUITY OUTCOMES
FOR CALIFORNIANS. THESE
INVESTMENTS WILL BE JOINTLY
COORDINATED. BY THE LABOR AGENCY
AND HELPING SERVICES AND
INITIATIVE INCLUDES TWELVE
PROGRAMS THREE DIRECTLY
ADMINISTERED BY THE WORK FORCE
DEVELOPED BY THE LABOR AGENCY.
THE H. R. T. P. WHICH TENANT
WILL DESCRIBE HEALTH CARE WORKER
ENHANCEMENT- THROUGH EIGHTEEN P.
AND EM TREAT ANSWER EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TECHNICIAN TRAINING AT
THE WORK FORCE SERVICES BRANCH.
AND AS OUR SECRETARY ALLUDED TO
THE PANDEMIC SERVED AS A GREAT
ON MASTER IN EQUITY'S ACROSS OUR
STATE INCLUDING THOSE IN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
WORKFORCE. AND WHILE PROBLEMATIC
AREAS IN HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE
HAD BEEN GROWING AND SHORTAGES
IDENTIFIED EVEN BEFORE THE
CRISIS BUT PANDEMIC EXACERBATED
THESE WHAT WE SEE NOW ARE MANY
HEALTH CARE ENTITY STRUGGLING
HOSPITALS ARE SHORT STAFFED AND
DESPERATE AND PAYING VERY HIGH
REGISTRY RATES FOR TEMPORARY
WORK FORCE. HOMELESS SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND OTHER HUMAN
SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE DESPERATE
FOR CASE MANAGERS AND OUTREACH
TEAM MEMBERS WITH IMPACTS ON
SERVICES TO CHILDREN PLACEMENT
OF CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE AND
OTHER. SOCIAL SERVE. AND OVER
ARCHING PROBLEM EVEN WHEN
STAFFING CHALLENGES MIGHT BE
SOMEWHAT LESS SIGNIFICANT IS THE
LACK OF REPRESENTATION AND
DIVERSITY IN THE CURRENT
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE. IN RACE
ETHNICITY LANGUAGE IS SPOKEN L.
G. B. T. Q. STATUS AS WELL AS
PEOPLE WITH A VARIETY OF LIVED
EXPERIENCE. WE ALSO SEE THAT
CURRENT TRAINING PROGRAMS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ADULT SCHOOLS
THE CSU AND UC PROGRAMS ARE
ALREADY IMPACTED AND CANNOT
PRODUCE THE VOLUME OF HEALTH
CARE WORKERS. NEEDED TO REPLACE
THE CURRENT HEALTHCARE WORKERS
PROJECTED TO RETIRE OR WHO ARE
LEAVING THE WORKFORCE BECAUSE OF
CARBON AND DISTRESSED. OR TO
MEET THE GROWING HEALTHCARE
NEEDS OF A RAPIDLY AGING
POPULATION. AS INVESTMENT WILL
CREATE AN INNOVATIVE AND
ACCESSIBLE OPPORTUNITIES TO
TRAIN AND RECRUIT HIRE IN
ADVANCE AND ETHNICALLY AND
CULTURALLY INCLUSIVE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES WORKFORCE. AND
WILL ALSO BUILD LADDERS OF
OPPORTUNITY AND ECONOMIC
MOBILITY ACROSS THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES SECTORS FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY FOR YOUNG PEOPLE OF
COLOR ACROSS CALIFORNIA. EDIE'S
LABOR MARKET INFORMATION
DIVISION PROJECTS JUST UNDER ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION HEALTHCARE
AND HUMAN SERVICE JOB OPENINGS
FROM. TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TO
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY EIGHT WITH
WAGES AVERAGING JUST UNDER
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR.
WE'VE IDENTIFIED TWENTY THREE
OCCUPATIONS AND OCCUPATIONAL
CLUSTERS IN THESE PROJECTIONS
THAT WILL DO NOT REQUIRE FOUR
YEAR DEGREES AND OFFER MORE
ACCESSIBLE PATHWAYS INTO FAMILY
SUSTAINING JOBS AND HOSPITAL.
PRIMARY CARE AND COMMUNITY
SETTINGS. THESE INCLUDE HEALTH
TECH ROLE SUCH AS EKG.
ULTRASOUND TECHS RESPIRATORY
THERAPISTS FOR BOTTOM MISSED AND
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS WHO
SERVICES WILL SOON BE COVERED BY
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENTS. HELLO
CALIFORNIA LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY IS REQUESTING
FOR OUR OWN USE TWO POSITIONS
AND FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND IN
ANNUAL GENERAL FUND- FINDING
OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS TO
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT THIS WORK
FORCE FOR A HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
INITIATIVE. IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY FOR THIS NEW LEVER LEVEL
OF COORDINATION THE LABOR AGENCY
REQUIRES AN ASSISTANT SECRETARY
OUR RESEARCH DATA SPECIALIST AND
FUNDING FOR TEMPORARY STAFFING
AND CONSULTATION TO PLAN AND
EXECUTE THIS INITIATIVE AND TO
BUILD A SUCCESSFUL AND
SUSTAINABLE COLLABORATION WITH
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES. AND
THEN BRIEFLY SECRETARY POLLUTE
CHEN MENTIONED ANOTHER OVER
ARCHING AN INITIATIVE ACROSS THE
LABOR AGENCIES DEPARTMENTS. WILL
HELP THE STATE TACKLE THE
CLIMATE CRISIS AND CREATE
ECONOMIC AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES IN THE
CLEAN ENERGY ECONOMY IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE THE
BUDGET DIRECTS INVESTMENTS TO
EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES AND CREATE
HIGH QUALITY JOBS BUT ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGES THE CHAP CHALLENGES
FACING WORKERS IN INDUSTRIES
MOST AFFECTED BY THE STATE'S
RESPONSE TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN THE FOSSIL
FUEL INDUSTRY. AND THEN LASTLY
THE IMMIGRANT WORK FORCE
INITIATIVE ENVISIONS A TRUE
CALIFORNIA THAT TAPS THE SKILLS
AND EXPERTISE NEW IMMIGRANTS AND
CREATES PATHWAYS OUT OF POVERTY
FOR IMMIGRANTS TRAPPED IN LOW
WAGE JOBS AND PRECARIOUS
EMPLOYMENT. AND ENVISIONS A
COORDINATED STATE EFFORT ACROSS
MULTIPLE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS OF SKILLS TRAINING
AND SUPPORTS THAT CREATE ACCESS
TO THE U. S. LABOR MARKET FOR
IMMIGRANT WORKERS AT ALL
EDUCATIONAL LEVELS FROM
INTERNATIONALLY TRAINED
PROFESSIONALS TO PEOPLE WITH
MORE LIMITED EDUCATION WHO NEED
CAREER PATHWAYS INTO LIVING WAGE
JOBS. WE ALSO ENVISION A SYSTEMS
CHANGE APPROACH THAT REMOVES
BARRIERS TO LICENSURE AND
CERTIFICATION SUBSTANTIALLY
BROADENS ACCESS TO SKILLS
TRAINING EXPANDS EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES THAT ACCELERATE
LEARNING FOR ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS AND ENGAGES EMPLOYERS
IN BUILDING THE SKILLS OF THEIR
WORKERS TO BUILD THEIR
COMPETITIVENESS INCLUDING
DIGITAL SKILLS. THANK YOU I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS FOR TO
PASS THE BATON BACK ON TO MY
COLLEAGUE. TIM RAINY AT THE
STATE WORKFORCE BOARD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MY NAY- I KNOW YOU
WERE GIVING THE BROAD OVER VIEW
OF ALL OF THESE ISSUES- BUT BASS
THE REASON WE HE ALSO MENTIONED
IS A VERY SPECIFIC ITEM OF THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS
REQUESTING. OF FOR THE ROLE OF
THE LABOR AGENCY AN ARM. IN THE
VARIOUS THINGS THAT YOU KNOW IN
WITH REGARDS TO THE HEALTHY OF
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD HAVE SO
THAT'S THE SPECIFIC ITEM. IN
ISSUE ONE- AND THEY WERE GONNA
BREAK IT DOWN EVEN MORE- WITH
REGARDS TO THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. AGENCY AND BOARD-
WITH REGARDS TO THE OVERALL
OVERVIEW ANY. ISSUES HERE WE'RE
GOING TO BREAK DOWN AGAIN INTO
MORE SPECIFICS. OKAY ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU HAVE A QUESTION- ON
THE OVERVIEW ORDER WE GONNA
BREAK IT DOWN LIKE I HAVE
QUESTIONS ON THE HIGH ROAD
TRAINING PROGRAM AND THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
SPENT LAST YEAR. IN THE DATA
THAT SAYS THAT SUPPORTIVE OF-
YOU KNOW HOW MANY JOBS ARE
CREATED OUT OF THAT WHAT WITH
THE WAGES OF THOSE JOBS THOSE
THINGS AND- ALSO HAVE QUESTIONS
ON THE OIL INDUSTRY OBVIOUSLY
REPRESENTING 70% OF THE STATE'S
OIL SO DO YOU WANT ME TO DO THAT
NOW. OR DO YOU WANT ME TO DO
THAT LATER AND AS WELL IF
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO COMPETITOR-
SENATOR I- WE HAVE SPECIFIC
ISSUES THE ONLY ISSUE IN. THE
ISSUE AN ITEM- ISSUE ONE IS
SPECIFICALLY THE REQUEST FOR TWO
POSITIONS- THE OFF FROM THE
GENERAL FUND- SO WE ARE MOVING
WE CAN MOVE ON NOW SPECIFICALLY
THE ISSUE TO WHICH HIGH ROAD THE
HIGHROAD PARTNERSHIPS- CLIMATE
AND CLEAN ENERGY ECONOMY TO
ISSUED TWO THROUGH FOUR ARE ARE
MORE SPECIFIC. OKAY YOU CAN I
JUST WANT THE OPPORTUNITY ASK
THIS QUESTION SURE THANK YOU
OKAY ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER.
CLARIFICATIONS NEEDED ALL RIGHT
THEN WE WILL MOVE ON- MISTER
RANEY WOULD YOU LIKE TO- DIVE
INTO A TO. S. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OUT TOO MANY
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD. THE FISH THE FIVE
PROPOSED INITIATIVES INSIDE
ISSUES TWO THREE AND FOUR ALL
WALK THROUGH THOSE ALL OF THESE
BUILD INTO THE HIGH ROAD WORK OF
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD- THE
HEALTHCARE HIGH ROAD- THE THREE
INITIATIVES WITHIN THE CLIMATE
AND CLEAN ENERGY ECONOMY- BUCKET
AND THEN THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
LEADERSHIP PROGRAM THE LANGUAGE
JUSTICE PATHWAY- SO QUICKLY THE
HYBRID VISION IS TO MOVE BEYOND.
A WORKFORCE APPROACH OF JUST
MAKING MORE PEOPLE COMPETITIVE
FOR TOO FEW GOOD JOBS- AND IT
PRIORITIZES EQUITY JOB QUALITY
AND CLIMATE RESILIENCE- IN THE
PREMISE IS THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE
EQUITY WITHOUT PAYING CLOSE
ATTENTION TO JO QUALITY OF
THOSE THINGS ARE INEXTRICABLY
CERTAINLY ONCE WE TALK ABOUT
ECONOMIC EQUITY I IN THAT
CONTEXT. RAIN GAME IS TO
INCREASE ECONOMIC EQUITY BY
TRANSFORMING THE WAY THE WHOLE
SECTORS RECRUIT HIRE PROMOTE
RETAIN ALEX THIS IS VERY
INDUSTRY BASED WORKER CENTERED
WORK- THE END GAME IS TO END UP
WITH A CALIFORNIA CAN BE DEFINED
BY QUALITY JOBS EQUITY IN
CLIMATE RESILIENCE IN THE GOAL
THIS OUR GOAL IS TO BUILD HIRING
TRAINING PARTNERSHIP. OR HIGH
ROAD CONSTRUCTION CREWS PROGRAM
BOTH ACTUALLY IN EACH MAJOR
SECTOR IN EVERY CORNER OF
CALIFORNIA SO IT'S VERY LONG
GAME STUFF- SO JUMP RIGHT INTO
THE ISSUES- MANAGER IF THAT'S
OKAY YES PLEASE SO THE ISSUE TO
HIRING TRAINING PARTNERSHIP FOR
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES-
DEPUTY SECRETARY STATE SPACE AT. THE CONTEXT FOR THIS. ARTIST
LARGER INITIATIVE FOR CARE WE'RE
- THREE FORTY MILLION OVER THREE
YEARS FOR THE HEALTH CARE HIGH
ROAD. AGAIN THIS IS INDUSTRY
FOCUSED WORK TARGETING
OCCUPATIONS THAT DON'T REQUIRE
FOUR YEAR DEGREES BUT LARGELY IN
THE ALLIED HEALTH- EVERYTHING BY
DOCTORS AND NURSES ESSENTIALLY-
MEDICAL ASSISTANTS RESPIRATORY
TECHNICIANS SURGICAL
TECHNICIANS. AND OTHER
OCCUPATIONS- WE'RE GONNA TRAIN
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE- THE DATA SHOW
AS A DEPUTY SECRETARY STATE
POINTED OUT. TWO MILLION- AT
ALLIED HEALTH OPENINGS. BETWEEN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT AND A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND OPENINGS FOR JUST
MEDICAL ASSISTANCE ALONE- SO
HUGE DEMANDS- WE'RE GONNA DO OUR
BEST TO FEEL THAT THE GAPS- BUT
THERE'S A GREAT DEAL OF WORK TO
DO- ISSUE THREE CLIMATE. AND
CLEAN ENERGY ECONOMY THOSE THREE
ITEMS THE FIRST IS A WELL
CAPPING- WORKFORCE PILOT WERE
REQUESTING FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING.
AGAIN INDUSTRY BASED PARTNERSHIP
WORK- WITH ORGANIZED LABOR-
INDUSTRY. EMPLOYERS SCHOOLS
COLLEGES. WE'RE GOING TO TRAIN
ACROSS FIFTY HUNDRED WORKERS IN
KERN KERN COUNTY- WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION WHICH IS. ALSO
REQUESTING IN THEIR IN THEIR-
THERE IN THIS BUDGET TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO PLUG ORPHANED
OIL AND GAS WELLS- THAT'S A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OVER
OVER TWO YEARS. EACH OF TWO
YEARS THE OIL CAPPING WORK
REQUIRES SKILLS THAT ARE COMMON
ALREADY IN SEVERAL OF THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES- AND IS
ESPECIALLY ALIGNED WITH OIL AND
GAS DRILLING. SO OUR INTENTION
IS TO TRANSITION. CURRENT AS
WELL AS DISLOCATED WORKERS TO
OIL WELL CAPPING MORE BY
BUILDING NEW SKILLS TRAINING IN
EXISTING STATE APPROVED JOINT
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT SIR
KERN COUNTY- ARE HYDRO
CONSTRUCTION CREWS INITIATIVE IN
KERN COUNTY WHICH TARGETS.
WORKERS FROM DISADVANTAGED
GROUPS FOR PATHWAYS TO CAREERS
IN CONSTRUCTION- WILL BE ALLIED
WITH THIS IS A PATHWAY AND IS A
PIPELINE AND- WE'RE ALSO GOING
TO WORK WITH- EDT SORT FOR
SERVICES BRANCH- BUT YOU'LL HEAR
ABOUT LATER- IN IN THIS HEARING.
BOB FOR BY TO WORK OR TO
IDENTIFY DISPLACING OIL AND GAS
WORKERS INTERESTED IN DOING WELL
CAPPING WORK. A MOVE ONTO THE
NEXT ITEM- UNDER UNDER CLIMATE
THE LOW CARBON ECONOMY PROGRAM
WE'RE REQUESTING SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE YEARS. BUILDING
ON A HIRING TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS AND HIRING
CONSTRUCTION CREWS THAT WERE
PLANNING TO. TRAIN APPROXIMATELY
FOUR THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
WORKERS- THE THIRD ITEM- IN THIS
BUCKET THE PORT TRAINING CAMPUS.
WERE REQUESTING- HUNDRED TEN
MILLION DOLLARS OVER THREE
YEARS. THE TOTAL COST OF THAT
TRAINING CAMPUS AT THE PORT OF
LA AND LONG BEACH IS A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THE
DIFFERENCE THERE IS CAN BE
PICKED UP BY THE PORTS OF LA AND
LONG BEACH. THE SAN PEDRO BAY
PORT COMPLEX AS AS YOU WELL
KNOW- MADAM CHAIR- HANDLES MORE
CONTAINERS PER SHIP CALL THAN
ANY OTHER PORT COMPLEX IN THE
WORLD- YET IT DOESN'T HAVE A
CENTRALIZED LOCATION FOR
WORKFORCE TRAINING. THERE IS
LIMITED TRAINING AVAILABLE. ON
PORT PROPERTY FOR LONG CHAU
WORKERS AND NONE FOR TRUCK
DRIVE. AWAY TRAINING THAT IS
HAPPENING. FOR I'LL DOUBLE L.
SHORT SPEECH. ALL ACROSS.
DIFFERENT PARCELS OF LAND-
BECAUSE THERE ISN'T A
SPECIALIZED TRAINING FACILITY SO
THAT. IN DUE TO THE CURRENT
LIMITED CAPACITY LONG FOR
TRAINING IS SUFFER DELAYS. AND
BOTTLENECKS AND- AS WE ALL KNOW
WELL- THE CHALLENGES OF PORT
REQUIRED. TRAINING AND ALSO
REQUIRES TO BE MORE EFFICIENT
AND EFFECTIVE IN HOW WE DO THAT
TRAINING. AT THAT AT THE PORT
COMPLEX. THE LA AND LONG BEACH
PORTS HAVE SET ASIDE A FIFTEEN
ACRE SITE FOR THE TRAINING
CENTER- THE CENTER IS GOING TO
FOCUS ON EXPANDING OF BASHING
TRAINING THAT WE STARTED WITH-
WITHOUT THE LA PORT A COUPLE
YEARS AGO IT'S HIRING TRAINING
PARTNERSHIP WITH I'LL W. CIVIC
MARITIME ASSOCIATION AN EMPLOYER
SUPPORT. LASHING TRAINING WILL
MOVED THIS PORT AT THIS- THIS
TRAINING SITE- THIS THIS
TRAINING FACILITY- SHIP TO SHORE
TRAINED AT CRANE OPERATOR
TRAINING- WHICH CURRENTLY CAN
HAVE- CAN ONLY HAPPEN. ON CRANES
THAT ARE SITTING IN BUSY
TERMINALS- SO WHEN THEY'RE
TRAINED CRANES ARE BEING USED WE
CAN DO TRAINING ON ON THOSE
CRANES FOR A LONG FOR WORKERS
WHO WANT TO BECOME A CRANE
OPERATORS HUGE. WHICH IS IN HUGE
DEMAND- AND DO THAT NOW BECAUSE
OF ALL THE STRANGER BEING
OBVIOUSLY UTILIZED YEAH AND EVEN
IN THE PAST. THOSE TERMINALS ARE
QUITE BUSY IN THERE IF THEY'RE
NOT SAFE PLACES TO DO TRAINING-
ZERO EMISSION CARGO HANDLING
EQUIPMENT TRAINING FOR WORKERS
TO LEARN HOW TO OPERATE.
MAINTAIN AND REPAIR EQUIPMENT
THAT DIRECTLY SUPPORTS THE
INDUSTRY'S LOW EMISSIONS
TRANSITION IN GOALS FOR REDUCING
CARBON AT THE PARK- AND THEN
MAINTENANCE REPAIR OF THAT THAT
ZERO EMISSION EQUITY THAT'S ALL
GOING TO BE HANDLED. AT THIS NEW
TRAINING SITE RATHER THAN
SCATTERED ACROSS THE PORT
COMPLEX BOB OUR INTENT. BIGGER
PICTURE IS THE IMPACT THE REGION
IN THE ENTIRE SUPPLY CHAIN- BY
PROVIDING SPACE FOR OTHER HIGH
ROAD EMPLOYER SEEKING TO TRAIN
THEIR WORK. ENTREE TO QUITMAN
INCLUDING TRUCKS AND FORKLIFTS-
AND FINALLY. THE ISSUE FOR
CALIFORNIA YOUTH. PROGRAM
LANGUAGE JUSTICE- THE- WORK FOR
SOME REPORTERS WERE. TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDS. TO
RECRUIT AND TRAIN AT RISK YOUTH
WHO WISH TO GO INTO NONPROFIT
WORK. IN DRIVEN TOO MANY
ORGANIZATIONS AND THEY'RE DOING
SUCH SOCIAL JUSTICE WORK. YOUTH
PARTICIPANTS WILL RECEIVE
TRAINING THROUGH SEVERAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- AND YOU EARN
AND LEARN WITH NONPROFIT SOCIAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS ESPECIALLY
THOSE PROVIDING LEGAL SERVICES-
BACK AND IMMIGRANTS RIGHTS-
SERVICES SO. THIS IS A VERY NEW
PROGRAM WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL HERE IT'S IT IT'S
ALREADY- BEEN INVESTED IN IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN GOING ON
FOR A LITTLE WHILE IT'S A
NATIONAL. EFFORT THE LABOR MORE
FOR SOME AGENCIES HAS BEEN
SUPPORTING THIS AND SO THIS
WOULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY EXPAND THIS WORK ACROSS
CALIFORNIA- STUDENTS- WELL IT I
SHOULD GO BACK A SECOND SAY THAT
. IT'S KIND OF A TWO FOR TWO FOR
AND THAT'S WHY IT IS VERY
EXCITING WE NEED MORE ADVOCATES
AND LEGAL AND LANGUAGE SERVICES
FOR IMMIGRANTS- BUT THE SAME
TIME THIS CREATES GREAT PATHWAYS
FOR CAREERS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
REALLY HAVE A PASSION FOR THIS
KIND OF WORK- SO IT BRINGS US
TO- REALLY IMPORTANT- THINGS
TOGETHER THE STUDENTS ARE GONNA
RECEIVED INCOME AND OTHER
SUPPORT AND MENTORING WEILAND
AND ROLLED THE OUTCOMES WILL BE
PAID INTERNSHIPS WITH THESE TO
ME BASED ORGANIZATIONS AT LEAST
A MINIMUM FIFTEEN DOLLARS PER
HOUR. AND A POST SECONDARY
CREDENTIAL AT THE END OF THE OF
THE PROGRAM WORK WE HAVE SEVERAL
PARTNERING COMMITTEE COLLEGES
AROUND CALIFORNIA MISSION
COLLEGE IN LA FRESNO CITY
COLLEGE DE ANZA COLLEGE IN SAN
JOSE LA TRADE TECH RECYCLAGE-
COMMITTEE COLLEGE- AND THIS THIS
WORK WILL EXPAND AGAIN TO OTHER. COLLEGE PROSTATE. SORRY FOR
GOING SO. THROUGH THIS AND WE'RE
LIMON ON TIME I'M I'M- READY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS. AND I'M SURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
RANEY APPRECIATE YOU GOING
THROUGH ALL OF THE ISSUES- WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS- FOR PURPOSES
OF OUR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS.
TAKE THEM AT ISSUE AT A TIME-
RATHER THAN YOU KNOW COMBINING
ALL- THREE. OF THE ISSUES SO WE
WILL TAKE ISSUE TO WHICH HAS TO
DO WITH THE HIGH ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS FOR HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. AND THIS IS
MISTER RANEY HAS- PRESENTED ON
BEHALF OF THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. BOARD I'D LIKE TO
ASK THE L. A. O. YOUR COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS. COMMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF JAZZ
ALMOST THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
ITEM TO THE HIGH ROADS TRAINING
PARTNERSHIP. COMPONENT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S-  ADER
ECONOMY PACKAGE- I PUT OUT OUR
OFFICE IS WORKING ON AN
ASSESSMENT OF THE ENTIRE
PACKAGE- WHICH WOULD INCLUDE AN
ASSESSMENT OF THIS COMPONENT.
WE'VE YET TO RELEASE THAT WILL
BE DOING SO SHORTLY WILL
OBVIOUSLY GET THAT TO THEM
MEMBERS AND STAFF OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE I JUST AS SOON AS
WE HAVE IT OUT- HIGH LEVEL
REMARKS AROUND THE CARE ECONOMY
PACKAGE. IT DOESN'T- IT'S IN A
VERY CONCEPTUAL STAGE AT THIS
POINT AND AS A RESULT WE THINK
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE MORE BROADLY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO- DIVAN AND SHE-
THAT- THAT THE CARE KIND OF.
CONSISTENT ITS PRIOR AND
PRIORITIES OF THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
- BEYOND THAT WHAT I WE DON'T
ANY USED. COMMON ON THE H. R. T.
P. PROPOSAL OTHER THAN TO NOTE
THAT IT- BECOMING. THIS FLAG
WORKFORCE OF PROGRAM- WITH WITH
MORE THAN SEVERAL YEARS OF
TENURE NOW SO IT'S A- A
COMPONENT OF THE KERATOTOMY
PACKAGE THAT WE WERE NOT
SURPRISED TO SEE- IN THAT REGARD
IT DOES MAKE SENSE TO BE A-
PIECE OF THE PACKAGE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR ALAMO- FINANCE. WHO
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT. I BETTER
TOP AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
MANAGER WE HAVE NO NOTHING TO
ADD TO- TIM'S COMMENTS THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU BYE I JUST
WANT OPEN UP- TO QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. ON I'D
ISSUE TOO. YES SIR GROWTH
QUESTION HERE AND I'M NOT SURE I
APOLOGIZE I DON'T KNOW WHO WILL
ANSWER THIS QUESTION- BUT LAST
YEAR WE ALLOCATED- ON THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE HYBRID
TRAINING PROGRAM IS THAT CORRECT. THAT IS CORRECT. OKAY AND THIS
YEAR THEY'RE ASKING FOR AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE MILLION
OR SKIS ME TWENTY MILLION- PER
YEARS- ON THAT TWENTY FIVE
MILLION THAT WAS ALLOCATED LAST
YEAR CAN YOU TELL ME HOW IT WAS
MEASURED AND HOW MANY NEW HIGH
ROAD TRAINING JOBS THAT CREATED
. I'M SORRY STATE SENATOR OF I
MISSPOKE- IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET- THERE WAS A
HUNDRED MILLION TOTAL ALLOCATED
FOR HIRING TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS. EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO DEVELOP THAT
NEW AND EXPAND EXISTING HIRING
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS IN THIS
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS. IN A
PARTNERSHIP WITH JIMMY COLLEGES
I TO THE DEVELOP HIRING TRAINING
PARTNERSHIP SO TOTAL A HUNDRED A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. AND
THOSE DOLLARS HAVEN'T GONE OUT
YET THEY'RE IN THE PROCESS OF.
OF WE'RE DEVELOPING A REQUEST
FOR PROPOSALS NAY WILL BE OUT
NEXT MONTH. SO I HAD IS I AM NOT
TWENTY FIVE MILLION IT'S A
HUNDRED MILLION THAT MONEY
HASN'T GONE OUT YET WE DON'T
EVEN KNOW IF THIS PROGRAM WORKS
AND WE'RE GONNA ALLOCATE ANOTHER
TWENTY MILLION IS THAT THAT. IS
THAT WHAT I UNDERSTAND- MINE
MISSING SOMETHING. WE DO WE
ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN INVESTING AS
MR ALAM OF A POINTED OUT IN
HIRING TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS FOR
SOMETIME- BEGINNING IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN- WE USE- FEDERAL
WORKFORCE INNOVATION OPPORTUNITY
ACT FUNDS. WE'VE INVESTED- PROP
BATH THAT- THIRTY NINE FUNDING
ALSO IN HIGH REGISTRATION
CAREERS- SO WE DO HAVE. AN
EVALUATION DEVELOP BY THAT UCLA-
THAT THAT- AND I CAN SHARE THAT
EVALUATION TO WORK WITH YOU SO
IT IS VERY EFFECTIVE WORK. A LOT
OF THE FOCUS IS ON BUILDING
INDUSTRY BASED PARTNERSHIPS- AND
THEN WE ALSO TRACK PARTICIPANTS-
AND OUTCOMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
SOME OF THOSE ARE YEAH INCOME
WORKERS ALREADY EMPLOYED PEOPLE.
WHO GET RETRAINED AND MOVE UP-
AND A LOT OF THAT WORK IS ALSO
BRINGING. IN NEW HIRES. THWAITES
FOR NEW HIRES. INTO SO AT WORK
ON SO IT'S KIND OF A SKILLING
BACKFILL- PAST. I'M BUT AS I
SAID SHE VERY INTO BASED THAT A
LOT. EMPLOY ORGANIZED LABOR WHEN
THEY REPRESENT THE WORKERS BUT
ALSO THE TRADITIONAL WORKFORCE
SYSTEM KIND OF CONNECTING THAT
TO PATHWAYS TO GOOD QUALITY JOBS
SO WE HAVE A VALUATION- WORK. UP
ON OUR WEBSITE AND I AS I SAID I
CAN ASSURE THAT YOU WE ALSO HAVE
AN EVALUATION FRAMEWORK FOR THE
ON GOING INVESTMENTS BECAUSE THE
INVESTMENTS HAVE HAVE REALLY.
SCALED UP OVER THE LAST SINCE
THE LAST BUDGET. THE FRAMEWORK
IS IN DEVELOPMENT WITH UCLA- AS
WELL. YOU THE GENERAL NUMBER
JUST A GENERAL ESTIMATE TO YOUR
BEST GUESS OF HOW MANY JOBS NEW
JOBS THAT THAT PROGRAM FOR A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS HAS
CREATED FOR INDIVIDUALS. THAT
NEED THAT PEOPLE OF COLOR PEOPLE
WHEN LOW DE SOCIO ECONOMIC AND
COMMUNITIES. AND PEOPLE THAT
DON'T HAVE A SUCH A GREAT WORK
HISTORY SECOND CANCERS- DO YOU
HAVE. YOUR BEST GUESS THAT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS HOW MANY
OF THOSE PEOPLE GOT THAT JOB OR
GOT THOSE JOBS JUST TO ESTIMATE
. SURE YOU NEED A HUNDRED
pAS I SAID- AND- WE CAN I CAN
COME BACK WITH YOU TO YOU WITH
WITH A MORE DETAIL ON KIND OF
HOW THE EVALUATION FRAMEWORK
WORKS. BUT IN THE PAST
INVESTMENTS- WELL I SHOULD I
SHOULD BACK UP AND SAY- WELL IN
THE PAST INVESTMENTS WE TRAINED
ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND. WORKERS AND
THAT WAS A COMBINATION OF UP
SCALING BACK FEELING ON OUR
HIGHER CONSTRUCTION CAREERS
ABOUT- INITIATIVES. OUT WITH
THAT PROP THIRTY NINE FUNDING
THAT WAS THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IT WAS INVESTED STARTING
pFEW YEARS IT'S OVER THREE YEARS-
THANK THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN
ENERGY JOBS ACT WAS A PARK
THIRTY NINE THAT- PULLED SOME
MONEY FOR. THE STATE WORKFORCE
BOARD. TO START THAT THAT HIGH
RECONSTRUCTION CHRIS PROGRAMS WE
TRAINED TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
WORKERS- SEVENTY EIGHT PERCENT-
FINISHED WHAT WE CALL AN MC
THREE CERTIFICATE WHICH IS
INTRIGUED BY YOUR CERTIFICATE IN
THE CONSTRUCTION TRADES. ABOUT
78% OF THOSE WERE PLACED IN. A
STATE APPROVED APPRENTICESHIP-
BUT 41% CONSTRUCTION ENERGY
EFFICIENCY RELATED EMPLOYMENT
ABOUT TWENTY THREE PERCENT- A
LOT WERE PUT THAT PLACE IN POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION ABOUT 10% OF
THAT THAT THAT GROUP OF
TRAINEES- SO THAT. THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF PEOPLE SERVED I
WISH I HAD THOSE NUMBERS IN
FRONT OF ME SENATOR ALL RIGHT
I'D BE- I'D BE. GOING TO THAT
LIST OF PRIMARILY- PEOPLE OF
COLOR IT'S ALL FOCUS ON LOW
INCOME WORKERS FROM
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES- SO
PEOPLE OF COLOR- THE PERCENTAGES
OF PEOPLE OF. OF PEOPLE OF COLOR
IN THE CONSTRUCTION TRADES NEEDS
TO COME UP IT'S QUITE GOOD IN
SOME OF THE CRAFTS WE GENERALLY
NEED TO COME UP SO THE COHORTS
FOR THAT HIGH RISK INSTRUCTION
CAREERS. ARE LARGELY ABOUT
PEOPLE OF COLOR WOMEN- WHO ARE
ALSO. UNDERREPRESENTED IN THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES- THEY
REPRESENT BETWEEN TEN AND 15% OF
MOST OF OUR COURTS IN SOME CASES
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. SO THE
DEMOGRAPHICS THAT WE SEE IN OUR
COHORTS THAT ARE GETTING PLACED
IN IN. STATE APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS TO- THAT
INITIATIVES- LOW EXACTLY WE WALK
. THE CONSTRUCTION A LOOK-
OVERTIME SO THAT THAT'S THE-
PUSHER. THANK YOU I CAN GET YOU
MORE DETAIL ON SATURDAY DON'T
THAT. IN FRONT OF ME I
APPRECIATE IF YOU GIVE THAT DEEP
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL. RESPONSE
WAS- ADEQUATE VERY ADEQUATE SITE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M FOR
THAT. I JUST WANT TO CONFIRM
THAT I HEARD CORRECTLY YOU SAID
THAT. IN THE CONSTRUCTION TRADES
INDUSTRY CONSTRUCTION TRADES
WHERE WE'RE INVESTING SOME OF
THESE RESOURCES IN ORDER TO. ADD
A MAKING MORE DIVERSE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES INDUSTRY.
YOU'RE SAYING THAT IN THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES IT'S AS LOW
AS 10% FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR
SOMETIMES FIFTEEN. AND IN VERY
RARE CASES 25% IS THAT WHAT YOU
TOLD ME JUST NOW. OR NOT. I
THINK I SAID THAT FIRST FOR
WOMEN IN THE- TRADES I'M NOT
SURE THAT IF I GIVE YOU A
PERCENTAGE FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS EXACTLY IN
THE TRADE BUT WHAT I DID SAY. IS
IN GENERAL- PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
UNDER REPRESENTED IN THE TRADES
AND AROUND BUT IN SOME CRACKS IN
THE CONSTRUCTION TRADES THEY'RE
OVER REPRESENTED. IN TERMS OF
THE SHARE THE POP OF THE
POPULATION. OKAY THANK YOU SIR
VERY MUCH. BUT I CAN GET YOU-
SPECIFIC STATISTICS ON THAT
SENATOR NO I APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. COLLEAGUES
MANY. QUESTIONS ON ISSUE NUMBER
TWO- I JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF
THEM. MISTER RANEY HOW WORK-
WHAT DO YOU EXPECTATIONS FOR THE
KINDS OF JOBS AND BENEFITS THAT
BOB PARTICIPANTS ARE OF THE HIGH
ROAD OUR TRAINING BOB
PARTNERSHIPS WOULD RECEIVE AFTER
COMPLETION WHAT WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION. LOOKING FOR- AND
YOU KNOW HOW DO YOU MEASURE THE
SUCCESS FOR THE FOR THOSE
INVESTMENTS. THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION- THE- IT FOCUSES ON- ON
EQUITY AND JOB QUALITY- SO THE
OUTCOMES OF THE INTENTION IS TO
PLACE PEOPLE IN FAMILY
SUSTAINING WAGES ARE FAMILY
SUSTAINING JOBS WITH GOOD WAGES-
THAT OFTEN WELL THE SHOULD OFFER
FAMILY BENEFITS- WE ALSO LOOK AT
JOB QUALITY STANDARDS AROUND-
SCHEDULING SCHEDULING- WORKER
VOICE ON THE JOB- WORKER AB-
AGENCY ON THE JOB THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR JOB TRAINING
TO MOVE UP- INCOME ABILITY SO WE
LOOK AT ALL THESE. METRICS IN
DETERMINING JOB QUALITY AB SO
JOHN QUALITIES TO FOCUS THAN
EQUITIES THE OTHER I'M SO MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE FOCUSING ON ALL
OF OUR PROGRAMS ACTUALLY TARGET
POPULATIONS- THAT ARE THAT
WORKERS FROM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES SO THE IDEA IS TO
BUILD THE PIPELINE INTO WHERE
THE BEST. ALL OF THE JOB ARE
SIDE MAYBE SHOULD TALK. VERY
BRIEFLY ABOUT HOW STRATEGY IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE WAY WE
TRADITIONALLY DO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT THE HIGHROAD
PARTNERSHIPS START WITH INDUSTRY
A BILL- DEEP RELATIONSHIPS WITH-
MULTIPLE COMPANIES WITHIN AN
INDUSTRY SECTOR- AND WE FOCUS A
LOT ON TRAINING AND UPSKILLING
THE CURRENT WORK FORCE. AS A WAY
OF BUILDING PIPELINES INTO GOOD
QUALITY JOBS FOR PEOPLE WHO MOST
NEED GOOD QUALITY JOBS THE
TRADITIONAL WORKFORCE APPROACH-
WHILE THEY STILL NEEDED IN A LOT
OF WAYS- DOESN'T DO THAT KIND OF
INDUSTRY BASS WORK. WE PROVIDE.
TRAINING AND WHERE WITH OFFER
PEOPLE. CAN PUSH HIM OUT AND
LABOR MARKETS TO HELP THE
ATTACHED TO A JOB- SO THIS IS
REALLY KIND OF CONNECTING THAT
SUPPLY AND DEMAND THE SUPPLY OF
WORKERS. AND THE DEMAND FOR
WORKERS ON THE ON THE SIDE OF A
GOOD QUALITY JOBS- WE DO HAVE A
FOR A FRAMEWORK. THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON. M. FOR ALL OF THE
INVESTMENTS FOR HIGH RIGHT
ACROSS ALL THE PROGRAMS ITS
STATE WORKFORCE BOARD- THAT
LOOKS AT THAT THE- WE CAN
MEASURE AGAINST THE GOALS OF
HIGHROAD ECONOMIC EQUITY WORK
INVOICING OR POWER QUALITY JOBS.
WAGES FAMILY BENEFITS
SCHEDULING- INCOME SECURITY
THOSE THINGS. BUT ALSO
PARTNERSHIP. INDUSTRY. SHARES
AND WE WERE WORKING WITH YOU SEE
I AS I SAID BEFORE THE LABOR
CENTERS OF A THIRD PARTY
EVALUATOR- I'M SORRY CENTER I
MIGHT BE GOING TO TOO DEEP INTO
THIS- THE DATA WE'RE COLLECTING
IS. IS BOTH A QUALITATIVE AND
QUANTITATIVE THE QUANTITATIVE
SIDE IS USING OUR OUR CURRENT
SYSTEMS CAL JOBS FOR EXAMPLE TO
COLLECT- PARTICIPANT LEVEL DATA
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION- THE
KINDS OF SERVICES PEOPLE READ
RECEIVING. THAT TYPE THING- THE
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA IS RACE RACE
ETHNICITY GENDER. AGE LOW INCOME
STATUS FORMERLY INCARCERATED
JUSTICE INVOLVED STATUS. VETERAN
STATUS IN MOVING THESE
POPULATIONS AND INTO GOOD
QUALITY JOBS. THANK YOU MYSTERY
OF. IT I AM JUST TO WORK A
QUESTION- HOW DOES THIS FIT HOW
DOES THIS HIERO TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS- FIT INTO THE ARM
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES-
PROPOSAL THAT'S BEING MADE- THE
CARE ECONOMY WORKFORCE PACKAGE.
IF YOU COULD GIVE A SHORTER
ANSWER BUT YOU KNOW- YEAH I
ENJOY LISTENING TO ALL OF YOU
BUT WE'VE WE'VE GOT A TIME ISSUE
HERE BUT HOW DOES THAT FIT INTO
THIS I WROTE BECAUSE IT I COULD
SEE FROM THE CHART. THAT IT'S IN
THE IN THERE BUT I'M NOT QUITE
SURE HOW IT. EXACTLY CONNECTS OF
YOU CAN GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE OF
HOW YOU EXPECT THAT THIS WOULD.
BE INTEGRATED. SURE YEAH IT'S IT
IS UNIQUE IT'S- IT'S
COMPLIMENTARY TO THE BROADER
PACKAGE- BUT IT IS UNIQUE IN
THAT IT'S- LIKE ALL THE HIGHROAD
OF PROGRAMMING THAT WE DO IT'S
VERY INDUSTRY SECTOR BASED SO
IT'S WORKING WITH EMPLOYERS
DIRECTLY- AND THEN BUILDING
PATHWAYS IN INTO INTO JOBS AND
HEALTH CARE SO. THE PUSH IS
GOING TO BE REAL STRONG
PARTNERSHIPS WITH- PROVIDERS
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS COMMITTEE
CLINICS HOSPITALS- PARTNERSHIPS
WITH THEM AND THE PATHWAYS INTO
IT TO THOSE JOBS THAT ARE OPEN
THIS ALLIED HEALTH. JOB SO
THAT'S THE UNIQUE PART OF IT IS
THEINDUSTRY BASED NATURE OF THE
HIGH ROAD. THANK YOU AND THE
LAST QUESTION IS. AND MAYBE
YOU'LL ANSWER IT OR SOMEONE ELSE
IS. EVERYTHING THAT YOU JUST
DESCRIBED IS THAT GOING TO BE
FORMALIZED IN TRAILER OR BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE. WE DON'T
ANTICIPATE THAT INITIATE SENATOR
WE ACTUALLY HAVE- THE HIRING
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS BUILT INTO
THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE CODE-
AS WELL AS- DEFINITIONS FOR HIGH
AT THREE THIRTY P. AND HIRING
CONSTRUCTION. WORKERS AND ALSO-
BUILT INTO THE CODE ARE THOSE
KINDS OF OUTCOMES THAT I THAT I
DISCUSSED- SO THEN THE METRICS
FOR MEASURING THE HIRING
TRAINING PROGRAMS IS ALREADY
BUILT INTO THE INTO THE COAT.
THANK THANK WE DON'T ANTICIPATE
ANY FOR TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
HISTORY WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
HERE QUESTION JUST TO CONFIRM
MAN ON THAT QUICKLY THE HEALTH
ON THE HEALTH AND MISTER RAINY
YOU SAID THOSE JOBS ARE GOING TO
PAY MINIMUM FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR CORRECT. YES FOUR THAT WITH
THE ONE. NOT FOR ALL THE
HEALTHCARE JOBS THAT GEN. HEALTH
CARE OCCUPY. THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
TARGETING PRETTY MUCH MUCH
HIGHER WAGES AND PROVIDE HEALTH
CARE BENEFITS. WELL BUT FOR THE
LIGHT FOR THE LANGUAGE PROJECT
YET MINIMUM OF FIFTEEN DOLLARS
NOW THAT'S IT. THAT'S IT OR IN
LEARN- PAID INTERNSHIP
INITIATIVES. THANK YOU SIR FOR
CLARIFYING. THAT WE'LL MOVE ON
NOW TO- ISSUE THREE WHICH IS
CLIMATE AND CLEAN ENERGY
ECONOMY- YOU ALREADY MADE A
PRESENTATION. ON THAT MISTER
RANEY RIGHT. I DID I THINK THERE
ARE OTHER ASPECTS- THAT OTHERS
MIGHT- COLLEAGUES IN OTHER
DEPARTMENTS- ARE HANDLING-
THERE'S MORE ON THE. I'M SORRY
YES I KNOW LA BUT NOBODY ELSE
FROM THE WORKFORCE BOARD. THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY YES NOW- IF VALLEY
OR WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON
ISSUE THREE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR CHAO'S ALTHOUGH WITH THAT
AWAY- THERE ARE STOPPED THREE
COMPONENTS HERE IN IN THIS ITEM.
I HAVE. A BRIEF COMMENTS ABOUT
THAT THE SECOND COMPONENT WHICH
IS THE CAMPUS AT THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES AND LONG BEACH- OUR
OFFICE WHAT ABOUT A QUICK
ANALYSIS OF THIS PROPOSAL. AS A
PIECE OF THE BROADER SUPPLY
CHAIN PROPOSAL THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION. HAS PUT FORTH-
HELLO BRIEF COMMENTS I- PERSON
FOR IT'S A CLEAR FROM FROM. MR
RAINEY'S COMMENTS THAT- THE KEY
BOTTLENECK AS IDENTIFIED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ALL A LACK OF.
PHYSICAL SPACE FOR TRAINING- WE
POINT OUT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WANT TO DIRECT ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS THE ADMINISTRATION
ABOUT WHAT OTHER POTENTIAL
BOTTLENECKS TERE ARE- IF IT THE
CASE THAT THIS IS THE EXCLUSIVE.
CONCERN REGARDING. ADEQUATE
WORKFORCE SUPPLY AT AT THE PORTS
OR OTHER OTHER ISSUES THAT ARE
GOING ON THAT THAT MIGHT MERIT
STATE ATTENTION AS WELL- THAT
WOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT A WITH
OTHER PROGRAMS LIKE. H. R. T. P.
FOR INSTANCE THAT WE JUST
DISCUSSED- THE STATE SETS SOME
STANDARDS FOR A- WHO WILL BE.
ELIGIBLE TO ENROLL IN TRAINING
PROGRAMS AND- IT MIGHT BE
WORTHWHILE FOR THE SUB COMMITTEE
TO CLARIFY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT SIMILAR
STANDARDS- WOULD BE APPLIED FOR
TRAINING THAT TAKES PLACE THE
CAMPUS. AND MAYBE TO MEMORIALIZE
THOSE STANDARDS IN TRAILER BILL
OR OR. BUDGET BELT- THIS. BECAME
IS A IS A FOR. STRUCKAND SO IN
MY- ON. SORT OF A NEW IN. FOR
THE WERE ABOUT BOARD I'M
TYPICALLY BEEN RESPONSE FOR A
STRING GRANDSON SETTINGS. REWARD
DEVELOPMENT- AND SO SORT OF
MOVING INTO THIS THIS REALM OF A
BUILDING PHYSICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
THERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS SO SHE
TO WITH THAT- PRINCIPALLY. ABOUT
WHETHER THE STATE IS SORT OF
IMPLICITLY MAKING A COMMITMENT
TO PROVIDING ONGOING FUNDING
SOURCE FOR. ONGOING TRAINING
COST FACILITY MAINTENANCE AND
THE LIKE I'M SORT OF LOOKING
INTO THE FUTURE AFTER THIS ASSET
IS DEVELOPED AND GETTING A
BETTER SENSE OF WHAT THE
STATE'S. FISCAL OBLIGATIONS ARE-
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- WE DON'T
HAVE SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS-
THESE THESE ARE JUST THE ISSUES
THAT WE RAISED. FOR A FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR ALAMO.
DEPARTMENT FOR. PLEASE I THANK
YOU PATRICK TOPPING DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- NOTHING FOR THE ADD
ON TIM'S COMMENTS HE WOULD JUST
LIKE TO CLARIFY THAT THIS WOULD
NOT BE THE BOARD BUILDING THIS
IS TO BE PROVIDING FUNDS TO THE
PORT OF LOS ANGELES AND LONG
BEACH TO BUILD THESE. RESOURCES
IN THE WATER PROVIDE FISCAL
OVERSIGHT TO MAKE SURE THE FUNDS
ARE USED FOR THEIR INTENDED
PURPOSES- AS WELL AS TO NOTE
THAT THERE IS NO PROPOSAL FOR ON
GOING FUNDING FOR TRAINING AT
THE PORT. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- ARAMBULA BONTA QUESTIONS
HERE FROM OUR COMMITTEE. I JUST
LIKE TO START WITH ONE- HOW DOES
THE ADMINISTRATION VIEW. OF
THESE PROPOSALS ON CLIMATE AND
CLEAN ENERGY ECONOMY. IN
RELATION TO THE TRANSPORTATION
PACKAGES. ARE BECAUSE IN THE
TRANSPORTATION PACKAGES WE- ALSO
INCLUDE A- ZERO. EMISSION
VEHICLE- EFFORTS PORT
INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPLY CHAIN. OUR
RESILIENCE- AND JUST OVERALL OF.
ENORMOUS INVESTMENT THE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM HOW HOW DO
YOU- HOW DO THEY WORK TOGETHER
OR DO THEY WORK TOGETHER. THANK
YOU SENATOR THEY DO THEY DO WORK
TOGETHER- THE BIG THAT PASSED
HIRING TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS IN
CURRENT HIRING TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS TO FOCUS A GREAT
DEAL ON THAT THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR- WE HAVE A NUMBER OF-
WE'VE ELECTRIC BUS MANUFACTURING
LOS ANGELES FOR INSTANCE ARE
TERRA- IN B. Y. D- PUBLIC
TRANSIT. WE'RE EXPANDING FROM.
EIGHT UP PUBLIC TRANSIT AGENCIES
- YET TO THIRTEEN OR MORE OVER
THE COURSE OF COURSE OF THESE
INVESTMENTS- FOR. THE ADOPTION
OF NEW TECHNOLOGIES YOUR
EMISSION BUSES- FOR THE
MAINTENANCE AND THE OPERATIONS
OF THOSE BUSES- WE ARE WORKING
ENERGY STORAGE STORAGE AND
MICROGRID AS A HIRING TRAINING
PARTNERSHIP WITH IDW INDICA-
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION. WITH
HIRING TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS IN
SACRAMENTO WHAT'S WITH THE
SACRAMENT IN MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISTRICT THE CALIFORNIA MOBILITY
CENTER- SO THEY ARE DURING
NUMBER OF PROJECTS ALREADY IN
TRANSPORTATION- AND WILL BE
EXPANDING THAT. THAT WORK IN
ADDING NEW. AS RE IT THIS FUND
IF IT'S- BY THE LATE- SO. YEAH
WE'RE WRITING THERE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION WORK
CLOSE WITH THE AGENT WERE VERY
CLOSE WITH CALTRANS- TO ALIGN
OUR WORK AND BE SURE THAT THEIR
INVESTMENTS AS THEY CREATE JOBS
WE'RE CREATING ACCESSING AND
PATHWAYS TO THOSE GOOD QUALITY
JOBS. THANK YOU MISTER RAINY-
MEMBERS. CENTER GROVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER RANEY I
APPRECIATE- THE INFORMATION THAT
YOU PROVIDE- I HAVE QUESTIONS
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT- OBVIOUSLY
THE OIL INDUSTRY WERE KERN
COUNTY PRODUCES 70% OF THE
STATE'S REDO AN OIL 53% THE
STATE'S RENEWABLE ENERGY OUT OF
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY SO WE ARE THE
ENERGY HAVE OF THIS STATE- IN ON
THE BACKLOG. OR THE SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES- LET'S I GUESS I HAVE
THOSE QUESTIONS AS WELL. DO YOU
THINK- WHAT'S YOUR SOLUTION TO
THE TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY IN
THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY WERE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT IN NUMBERS OF
TRUCKERS LOST THEIR JOBS DUE TO
AB FIVE IN DON'T TRANSPORT IN
CALIFORNIA ANYMORE- DO YOU THINK
THAT HAD ANY EFFECT ON THE
SUPPLY CHAIN- PROBLEM THAT WE
HAVE. YEAH I THINK WE'RE
ACTUALLY DOING A STUDY ON ON.
TRUCK DRIVING IN IN CALIFORNIA-
WITH YOU THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY AND USED
UNIVERSITY OF PENNSYLVANIA TO.
UNPACK WHAT'S HAPPENING A
TRUCKING IN CALIFORNIA I DO
THINK THAT- ACCORDING TO THE
RESEARCHERS THE BOTH THE IMPACT
OF DEREGULATION AND POSSIBLY
EIGHTY FIVE. I HAVE TO BE LOOKED
AT BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF-
CHURNING AT INDUSTRY NOW TRUCK
DRIVERS DON'T SEEM. TO BE
STICKING AS TRUCK DRIVERS VERY
LONG- AND THERE A LOT OF PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA DRIVER'S LICENSES-
DAHLE WHO TOOK CHOSEN NOT TO
DRIVE TRUCKS. I'M SORRY THERE'S
A THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH THE
PIPELINE INTO TRACKING- THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THERE'S A
PROBLEM WITH THE JOB QUALITY AND
OUT FOR TRUCK DRIVERS. OUT TO
TRY TO EXPLAIN AND SOLVE FOR-
THE FACT THAT PEOPLE ARE TURNING
TO A NOT STICKING TO TRUCK
DRIVING SO WORK. WORK THAT
REPORT STUDIES CAN BE DONE IN
DECEMBER. AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS ON THAT.
INVOLVED WORKFORCE- THAT WILL.
HELP INFORM HOW WE HOW WE
UNDERSTAND. HOW WE ADDRESS THE
STATE SECTOR. THANK YOU THAT'S
GOOD NEW TO HEAR YOU VERY FOR
THAT INFORMATION I PREACH I
APPRECIATE THAT- SO JUST A FEW
FACTS AND DATA AND YOU CAN
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG.
CALIFORNIA PRODUCES ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED NINETY ONE THOUSAND
BARRELS OF OIL TODAY 1100% OF
THOSE GIRLS PRODUCED ARE. AT IN
CALIFORNIA ARE CONSUMED BY
CALIFORNIANS. BUT WE HAVE
ACTUALLY CONSUME AS CALIFORNIANS
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION BARRELS
A DAY ACROSS THE STATE- WE HAVE
PEOPLE IN THE OIL INDUSTRY ARE
55% PEOPLE OF COLOR THEY ARE 38%
SECOND CHANCELLOR'S MEANING
THEY'VE BEEN FORMER- FORMER
INCARCERATED FELONS SERVE TIME
IN PRISON GOT OUT IN THE MADE A
WAY FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND STATE
OUT OF PRISON AND REDUCED
RECIDIVISM. THE AVERAGE WAGE IN
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN THE OIL
INDUSTRY IS A HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
WITH BENEFITS- I WORK I HAVE
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN THIS
INDUSTRY- BUT THE MINIMUM WAGE
WHEN YOU GO OUT TO THE OIL
INDUSTRY IS TWENTY DOLLARS AN
HOUR TWENTY ONE DOLLARS AN HOUR
REALLY I THINK IS WHAT THE IT'S
GOING TO WIN THE NEW REPORT
COMES OUT. AS IT'S HARD FOR ME
TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE WOULD
TRANSITION OFF OF THIS EVEN
THOUGH THERE'S RESOURCES IN THE
BUDGET TO TAKE THESE- FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND WORKERS OUT OF THIS
INDUSTRY AND PUT THEM IN A
DIFFERENT INDUSTRY THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO TRAIN THEM FOR CAN YOU
TELL ME WHAT INDUSTRIES THAT
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT RETRAINING
THESE WORKERS TO GO IN AND WHEN
THEY MAKE. THOSE WAGES AND THE
INFORMATION THAT I JUST PROVIDED
TO YOU WHAT WHAT INDUSTRY IS
GOING TO BE EQUAL TO OR EXCEED
THE WAGES OF THE BENEFITS AND-
BUT THAT WE WOULD HAVE IN THIS
INDUSTRY FOR THESE FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND WORKERS SPECIFICALLY
THE ONES THAT MOSTLY WORK IN MY
DISTRICT. THANK YOU CENTER GROVE
THAT'S THERE'S A ROOF REALLY
IMPORTANT STATISTICS. I THINK
THE OPPORTUNITY HERE- WITH THE
CAPPING OF THE ORPHAN OIL WELLS
IS TREMENDOUS- BUT I THINK WE
NEED TO DO MORE IN CONSTRUCTION.
AND FORTUNATELY WE'VE GOT
INVESTMENTS FROM THE STATE BUT
ALSO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
DRIVE OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE
TO MOVE INTO THE CONSTRUCTION
TRADES FOR OTHER GOOD. PAYING
JOBS- AS WE BUILD STUFF THAT
CREATES DEMAND FOR WORKERS THAT
WE HAVE OUR PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS I RECONSTRUCTION CHRIS
GRADING PIPELINES IN THE STATE
APPROVED APPRENTICESHIP. SO AS
NEW APPRENTICES. ARE IN DEMAND
WE CAN WE CAN FILL THOSE SLOTS-
IN EVERY CORNER OF THE STATE'S
MATTER FACT HIRING CONSTRUCTION
CREWS PROGRAM IN KERN COUNTY BUT
WE HAVEN'T EVERY. EVERY COUNTY
OF CALIFORNIA. THE INTERESTING
AND I THINK HUGE OPPORTUNITY
HERE IS IN KERN COUNTY ALONE
THERE FIFTEEN HUNDRED TO TWO
THOUSAND. OIL AND GAS EXTRACTION
WORKERS- THIS ACCORDING TO LABOR
MARKET INFORMATION DIVISION ET.
KERN HAS A HIGH CONTENT YOU KNOW
A HIGH CONCENTRATION OF THOSE
WORKERS WITH EXPERIENCE AND
SKILLS. SO ACCORDING TO THE
CONSERVATION DEPARTMENT
CONSERVATION SPEECH BC PETER
FIVE THOUSAND- ORPHAN. DESERTED
POTENTIALLY DESERTED WELLS- IN
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE INVESTING.
PROPOSED. TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WILL. GO TO IT
CAPPING THOSE WELLS- BUT THIS
HOUSING LEVERAGE FOR FUN AUTHOR
BY THE- INVEST AND JOBS ACT. SO
IT'S GOING TO BE SEVERAL HUNDRED
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS INVESTED IN
THIS WHILE CAPPING WORK- IT'LL
CREATE ABOUT EIGHT THOUSAND.
JOBS TOTAL DIRECT INDIRECT AND
INDUCED AND AS YOU POINT OUT
THESE ARE HIGHLY SKILLED AND
WELL COMPENSATED WORKERS WITH-
GREAT WAGES SO OUR INTENTION IS
TO. MAKE SURE THAT THOSE JOBS
ARE AVAILABLE TO THE WORKERS WHO
ARE CURRENTLY IN THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY BECAUSE THEIR SKILL
SETS ARE ARE VERY WELL ALIGNED-
WITH THOSE SKILLS REQUIRED FOR
THE OIL WELL CAPPING- SO AS WE
DO THAT MORE MORE THAT WORKS
MORE THOSE WILL. MORE THOSE
WORKERS ARE GONNA GET ARE GOING
TO BE. EMPLOYED BUT IT'S ALSO A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR NEW
APPRENTICES THAT WILL THAT WILL
BE ABLE TO. MOVE PEOPLE WHO
EITHER DISLOCATED OR AT RISK OF
TO SECURE FROM THEIR JOBS.
MOVING TO THE SHOPS BUT YOU YOU
LOOK AT THAT PLUS. THE OFFSHORE-
WIND INVESTMENTS- THE LIFTING
INVALID INVESTMENTS THE
EXPANSION OF HIGH SPEED RAIL-
THE BUILDING AND BUILDINGS THE
RETROFITTING OF BUILDINGS ALL OF
THAT WORK IS CREATING DEMAND.
FOR MORE AND MORE PEOPLE TO GO
INTO CONSTRUCTION BUT THERE'S
ALSO A MULTIPLIER EFFECTS IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
THAT ARE JUST IN THE IN THE
METROPOLITAN DENSELY POPULATED
AREAS BUT ALSO IN THE RURAL
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA. SO BUILDING
STUFF IS CREATING JOBS AND WE'RE
CREATING ACCESS TO THOSE JOBS
AND THOSE ARE. THOSE ARE GOOD
PAYING FAMILY SUSTAINING. JOBS
BUT I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS SENATOR. THANK YOU- ON
THE SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUE. A
CALIFORNIA IMPORTS. ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION BARRELS OF OIL A
DAY- CALIFORNIA IS THE NUMBER
ONE. NUMBER ONE STATE. AT THE
PURCHASES ECUADORIAN OIL F. WE
ACTUALLY CALIFORNIA PURCHASE
FIFTY ONE PERCENT. OF ALL OIL
PRODUCED IN ECUADOR- THERE WAS A
RECENT FORCE MAJEURE IN THE
STATE OR THE COUNTRY OF ECUADOR
BECAUSE INDIGENOUS INDIANS. THAT
WON A LAWSUIT REGARDING- AS THE
DEMOLISH OF THE RAIN FOREST THE
AMAZON RAINFOREST FOR OIL
TRIANGLES THAT ARE THERE. IF
THAT LAWSUIT GOES THROUGH IN
THOSE INDIGENOUS INDIANS WHERE
WE'RE TEARING DOWN THEIR
RAINFORESTS TO GET OIL TO COME
TO CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS BECAUSE OUR
CONSUMPTION HASN'T GONE DOWN.
WHAT'S THE BACKUP PLAN- FOR THE
SUPPLY CHAIN FOR THAT 51% OF THE
OIL THAT WE GET FROM ECUADOR. IS
THERE A DIZZY ADMINISTRATION
HAVE A BACKUP PLAN BECAUSE OF
THAT WILL CEASE TO EXIST.
BECAUSE OF THE LAWSUIT THESE
INDIGENOUS INDIANS HAVE AGAINST
THE STATE THE COUNTRY ECUADOR IF
THAT LAWSUIT- GOES THROUGH AND
THEY WENT ON THE SECOND LEVEL. A
CALIFORNIA WILL NOT BE RECEIVING
THAT OIL AND WE PURCHASED 1% OF
<c.blue>CUADOR'S OIL. TO MEET THE</c>
DEMAND OF THE ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION IMPORTED BARRELS OF OIL
EVERY DAY ON THE SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUE WHAT'S TE
ADMINISTRATION'S BACKUP PLAN FOR
THAT IF THAT TAKES PLACE. THE U.
S. CENTER GROVE HOW IS THAT
SPECIFIC AND WE REALLY NEED
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS TO THESE
ISSUES I THINK IT'S REGARDING IS
ABOUT NINETEEN ISSUE I THOUGHT
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT SUPPLY
CHAIN. PRODUCTS ARE HIRING
PEOPLE SO IF YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT AN INTERNATIONAL HOW DO WE
HOW DOES THAT. HAVE TO DO WITH
THE SUPPLY CHAIN HERE AS FAR AS
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT POLITIC
COUNTY WILL BE WANT TO TAKE A
STAB AT A BILITY. LET ME PLEASE
. A MISTER RANEY IF YOU WANT TO
GIVE A SHORT ANSWER TO THAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR I I'M NOT SURE
THAT I HAVE AN ANSWER TO IT BUT
I I'D LOVE TO- TO VISIT SENATOR
GROSS VEGGIE CENTER TALK TO YOUR
STAFF AND CUT KIND OF THING TO
THE WORKFORCE- ANGLES ON THAT
QUESTION. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. THANK YOU I'D I'D LIKE
THAT WE COULD SET UP A MEETING
I'D REALLY LIKE THAT. I'M ON THE
WORK FORCE PIECE AS WELL. AND
YOU MENTIONED THAT- THERE'S FIVE
THOUSAND WELLS. OUT ROUGHLY FIVE
THOUSAND ORPHANED AND ABANDONED
WELLS THAT NEED TO BE CAPPED.
AND WE'RE GOING TO TRANSITION
PEOPLE THAT. MAKE M. HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR. BENEFITS MOST OF THEM HAVE
COMPANY VEHICLES- ALL OF THE
STUFF WE'RE GONNA TRANSITION
THEM. OFF AS AT AN INCIDENT JOB
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE FOR CAREER
SOME OF THE WORK IN THE WHEN YOU
SEE THIRTY THIRTY FIVE. FORTY
YEARS- HOW MANY WELLS ARE CAPPED
EVERY YEAR JUST A. CURIOSITY
DOES ANYBODY HAVE THAT ANSWER.
I'LL SEE IF I CAN GET IT AS WELL
. YEAH I THINK CENTER I DON'T
HAVE AN ANSWER BUT I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT CONSERVATION-
PROBABLY DOES HAVE AN ANSWER. SO
LET'S JUST SAY IT'S A THOUSAND
WELLS A YEAR WHICH I DON'T THINK
IT IS I THINK IT'S MORE LIKE
HUNDREDS- ONCE THOSE WHEELS ARE
CAPPED WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO THOSE
WORKERS. BECAUSE THEY'RE
ACTUALLY WORKING THEMSELVES OUT
OF A JOB. IF WE PRODUCE OIL HERE
THEY KEEP THEIR JOB AND THEIR
BENEFITS. AND PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES AGAIN 55% PEOPLE OF
COLOR. 38% SECOND CHANCE SERVICE
14% WOMEN. 18% UNITED STATES
MILITARY VETERAN. OF THE IF THEY
CAP THESE WELLS WHERE THEY GO
AFTER THAT. THIS IS A GREAT
QUESTION I IT THE BEAUTY OF THAT
OF THE CONSTRUCTION TRADES- IS
THE DISPATCH MODEL- AND AS
WORKERS I MEAN IT'S A VERY
VOLATILE INDUSTRY- WHERE
WORKERS. GO TO WORK ON A
PROJECT- THE PROJECTS OVER THEY
GO BACK TO THE HIRING ON THEIR
DISPATCH OF THE WORK SO- THE
INTENTION HERE WITH WELL WELL
CAPPING IS TO BUILD IT INTO
EXISTING. APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS THAT SERVES KERN COUNTY
IN OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE
WHERE WE'LL BE DOING THIS WHILE
CAPPING. SO I THINK THAT
INTERESTINGLY THAT THAT THE
OLDEST MODEL FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT- PROBABLY IN HISTORY
IS THE MOST RELEVANT ONE FOR
TODAY AND THE CAN THE KINDS OF-
CHANGE THAT WORD THAT WE'RE
FACING. SO DO THOSE JOBS COMING
OUT OF CONTRACTS FROM CAL JIM.
WOOD WAS DAVID OVERSEE DOT. THE
KALENJIN CORRECT I BELIEVE
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY IN THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES HAVE THIS
SKILL SET I MEAN I MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE'S ONLY
TWO COMPANIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT CAN PROVIDE THIS
SERVICE- OF OIL WELL CAPPING A
WE RECENTLY WORKED WITH. CAL JAM
IN ONE OF THESE COMPANIES. THE
END OF FIVE MINUTES AGO WE'RE-
THE IT WAS THE OIL WELL THERE
ARE THAT WAS CAP. SO LONG AGO.
ANY REGULATE PROCESSES WERE IN
PLACE. IT ENDED UP BEING LIKE
THREE TIMES THE AMOUNT OF THE
COST AND I MEAN THEY FOUND LAWN
CHAIRS. LIKE METAL LAWN CHAIRS
AND ALL KINDS OF JUST CRAZY
THINGS AT THE BOTTOM OF THIS
WELL. IS THERE- IS VERY-
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING PROGRAM.
THAT YOU'RE AWARE OF THAT IS
THERE THAT IS ACTUALLY. TRAINING
THESE INDIVIDUALS TO DO THIS
JOB- BECAUSE LIKE I SAID I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S ONLY TWO IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT DO
THIS AND IF AND IF THAT'S TRUE.
AS WHO DEVELOP THE CURRICULUM
AND IS THAT HOW LONG DOES IT
TAKE FOR SOMEBODY TO GET THAT.
TRAINING IS IT SIX MONTHS IS IT
TWO YEARS WHAT'S THE PROCESS.
YEAH THERE ARE THERE ARE.
CONSTRUCTION CRAFTS THAT DO VERY
SIMILAR WORK WITH OIL DRILLING-
THAT WOULD BE. A VERY THAT. I'M
VERY CLOSE TO THE WELL CAPPING
WORK- THAT'S BEING CALLED FOR
HERE SO IT WOULD BE A MATTER OF
BUILDING A DIGITAL SKILLS INTO
THE EXISTING APPRENTICESHIP
TRAINING PROGRAM SO YOU USE UP
SKILLED THREE LEVEL WORKERS BUT
YOU'RE ALSO. BUILT INTO THAT
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
ADDITIONAL SKILLS FOR NEW
APPRENTICES COMING THROUGH-
THERE THERE ARE. AS YOU SEE I
THINK THAT THIS IS NOT MY OF
EXPERTISE- THAT INDUSTRY
WORKFORCE PERSON- BUT I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE.
COMPANIES THAT DO THIS WORK BUT
ALSO A LOT OF SUBCONTRACTORS
THERE A LOT OF THERE'S A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO GO TO
WORK- AT THAT POINT. ON WELL
WELL CAPPING. OKAY CAN I OPEN UP
. THANK YOU IN A OPEN INVESTORS
- ISSUE. THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
LEADERSHIP PROGRAM. LANGUAGES
JUSTICE PATHWAY- YOU ALREADY
PRESENTED RIGHT MISTER RAINY SO
WILL LAST ALEJO TO COMMENT ON
ISSUE FOR PLEASE. HELLO THE ONLY
A WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH
ISSUES FOR OKAY- FINANCE ANY
COMMENTS. AT THE TOP AND BOTTOM
TO FINANCE A NO FURTHER COMMENTS
ON THIS PROPOSAL. OKAY. A MISTER
MISTER RANEY ON THIS ON THIS
ISSUE. OF WHAT TYPES OF JOBS AND
BENEFITS ARE DUE THE
ADMINISTRATION EXPECT FOR
PARTICIPANTS TO GO THROUGH THIS
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THESE
ARE THESE ARE- ARE TO LEARN
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS TO GO
TO WORK FOR MISSION DRIVEN CAN
BE BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT
DON'T HAVE HUGE BUDGETS BUT WORK
IN THIS AREA OF- THAT IT
LANGUAGE AN IMMIGRANT RIGHTS- SO
WITH THE INTENTION HERE IS
FIFTEEN DOLLARS HOUR MINIMUM FOR
THOSE THAT. OUT A TOTAL OF TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE
STUDENTS TO DO THIS THIS- THIS
ART AND LEARN OPPORTUNITY A LOT
OF THE STUDENTS THAT ARE GOING
IN TO THIS WORK- WE EXPECT WILL
STAY WITH THOSE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS OF THE WORKING
WITH FOR LONGER TERM CAREERS- IT
ENDS OR WILL BE PART OF A
NETWORK OF JIMMY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE STATE
SO IT OPENS UP OTHER ACTORS FOR
CAREERS. WE ALSO ANTICIPATE THAT
THOSE STUDENTS WILL WILL
CONTINUE IN THEIR EDUCATION
PATHWAYS AND GO INTO TO LEGAL
SERVICES BECOME LAWYERS- THAT
KIND OF THING SO- THERE THERE
ARE LOTS OF OPPORTUNITIES I
THINK FOR CONNECTING THE
STUDENTS THAT ARE SO PASSIONATE
FOR THIS WORK- TO THIS
INITIATIVE. IT HAS HUGE
POTENTIAL. ABBY STEAK JUMP ANY
TIME BECAUSE SHE- SHE'S ALSO
KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT THIS THIS
PROJECT- AND JUST ONE MORE WHAT
IS THE ROLE OF EACH OF THE
PARTNERS- YOU'VE LISTED THEM
HERE. OF WHAT THE TO THE
PARTNERS BRING TO THE TABLE FOR
THIS. FOR THIS PROGRAM. ACTUALLY
COULD BE A GREAT PLACE FOR IT
FOR ABBY DEPUTY SECRETARY SLATED
TO JUMP IN OKAYTHERE THERE
THERE ARE THREE THREE DIFFERENT
LEVELS- MEMBERS OF THIS%
PARTNERSHIP- AND YOU'LL GO AHEAD
I DON'T TO TAKE SIR I'M HAPPY TO
DO IT AS TO MENTION THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH LEADERSHIP
CORPS IS ACTUALLY PART OF A-
NATIONAL. NETWORK OF LEADERSHIP
CORE PROGRAMS THAT EXIST IN
OTHER STATES AROUND THE COUNTRY
AND THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
LEADERSHIP CORPS ITSELF WAS SET
UP TO- DESIGN AND DELIVER THIS
PROGRAM IN IN CALIFORNIA. AND IT
REALLY IS A UNIQUE COLLABORATION
THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
INVOLVED CHEN MENTIONED THE
SELECTED COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
THEIR ROLE IN THE COLLABORATION
IS CHIU ONLINE CLASSES AND-
CAREER PATHWAYS WITHOUT WORK
THAT THE STUDENTS WILL BE DOING
AN IMMIGRANT LEGAL SERVICES
ANOTHER SOCIAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS. AS WELL AS TO
PROVIDE IN THIS IS SO IMPORTANT
WRAPAROUND SUPPORT SERVICES AS
PART OF THAT BEAUTY OF THIS
PROGRAM IS ITS ABILITY TO CALL
AND YOUNG PEOPLE WHO AREN'T YET
IN COLLEGE WHO ARE PASSIONATE
ABOUT SOCIAL JUSTICE LANGUAGE
JUSTICE. AND GET THEM INVOLVED
IN HIGHER EDUCATION AND SO THERE
ARE NONE REALLY ROBUST
WRAPAROUND SUPPORT SERVICES FROM
ACADEMIC SUPPORT ON REFERRALS
FOR HOUSING AND FOOD ASSISTANCE
AND OTHER SOCIAL SERVICES. YOUNG
PEOPLE NEED SO THAT THEY CAN
STAY IN SCHOOL AND BE SUCCESSFUL
AND THEN THE ROLES OF DARK
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ARE TO PROVIDE MEANINGFUL JOBS
HIGH QUALITY SUPERVISION
MENTORING SO THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
CAN SEEING THEIR FUTURES- REALLY
PROVIDING SERVICES TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND THE YOUTH
LEADERSHIP CORPS- THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH LEADERSHIP CORPS PROGRAMS-
DOES THE PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT IT
DOES- AT A COACHING SUPPORT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE-
COMMUNITIES OF PRACTICE SOMEONE
BUT THAT- PROJECTS AND
COMMUNITIES AND- AS YOU CAN SEE
THE SPONSOR THE AND CITY CALLED
WHICH WILL BE THE MAIN THAT
ASPECTS OF THE PROGRAM PLEASE
LET ME KNOW IF THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION ADEQUATELY OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I DON'T HAVE ANY
MORE QUESTIONS ON ISSUE FOR
ANYONE. YES CENTER COURT BECAUSE
HE- THANK MINIATURE. ON THE ON
THE WORD AND EARNED A PROGRAM
INTO ONE OF THE BILL I THINK
ACTUALLY THE LARGEST ONE IN MY
DISTRICT IS ACTUALLY RUN BY THE
COUNTY SANTA CORE IT'S A PROGRAMTHAT WE STOOD UP A FEW YEARS
AGO- IN SIMILARLY THEY ARE
DISTRIBUTING STUDENTS OUT-
COMMITTEE BC DISEASE OR HAVE
THEM WORK WITHIN COUNTY AGENCIES
- I AM PLEASED TO SEE. BUT THE
ANSWER THE ANSWER COLLEGE
LISTED- IN MY NOTES HERE AS- ONE
OF THE- ONE OF THE CURRENT
PATHWAYS FOR CALIFORNIA WITH
YOUTH LEADERSHIP BUT I GUESS A
QUALIFIED FOR THE PROGRAM. JUST
ADD IT TO THE TECHNICAL QUESTION
AND I CAN TAKE THE ANSWER OFF
LINE BECAUSE THIS VERY MUCH
BECAUSE OF MY COUNTY EXPERIENCE.
BUT WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE-
PROGRAM IN THIS CASE. BE ALLOWED
TO WORK WITH THE COUNTY- FOR THE
PLACEMENT OF THOSE- COLUMN
INTERNEN LEARN BUT I GUESS
YOU'RE CALLING TO EARN AND LEARN. I'M REALLY ASKING IF THE
COUNTIES IF IN THE CASE WHERE
YOU HAVE A COUNTY PROGRAM- THAT
ALIGNS- THEY QUALIFIED. TO
ASSIST WITH THE PLACEMENT. ARE
ARE YOU ASKING SENATOR CORTESE
OF STAFF COUNTY OFFICES WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE INTERNSHIP SITES. I
SUPPOSE I JUST I'M JUST LOOKING
PROGRAMS BECAUSE IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT THAT WAY IN MY COUNTY
I'VE GOT THIS HUGE ROLE TO BE
HUGE PROGRAM OF. AB TWO
THOUSAND. IN TURN SEVENTY IN
PLACE ALMOST IDENTICAL TO WHAT
YOU'RE CALLING FOR HERE AND THEN
THIS PROGRAM IS DIRECTED AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN A I DON'T
KNOW HOW. IT'S BUT IT'S ONE OF
MY TYPICAL IMPLEMENTATION
QUESTIONS WHEN WE GET IN THESE
DISCUSSIONS- YOU KNOW WHAT-
THOSE TWO ENTITIES- EXPECTED TO
COOPERATE OR FOR WORK TOGETHER
OR THE- IS THERE ANY OBSTACLE TO
THE- WITH THE PROGRAM ITSELF
YEAH I WOULDN'T SEE ANY OBSTACLE
AND I'M SURE YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH BRIAN MURPHY THAT FAIRLY
RECENTLY RETIRED PRESIDENT OF
DAN'S AT. WHO HAS BEEN A
CHAMPION AND- REALLY CREATING
THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH LEADERSHIP
CORPS AND I WOULD IMAGINE THAT
THESE TWO WOULD BE A LINE BUT
HAPPY TO GET MORE INFORMATION
AND FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ONLINE
YEAH I COULD DO IT PERHAPS IT
APPEALS- A LITTLE BIT OF A MATCH
MAKING BY MY OFFICE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE TWO ORGANIZATIONS KNOW
THAT THEY'RE WORKING IN PARALLEL
OR IN UNISON. BUT THAT SOUNDS
GREAT THANK YOU FOR RESPONDING
HAPPY TO DO THAT. THANK YOU FOR
SENATOR. CENTER GROVE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR JUST HAVE A QUESTION
HAVE A HANNAH I DO I DON'T KNOW
DIRECT TO- I'M SURE SOMEBODY AND
IT WHOSE MENTORING OR TRAINING
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE- THAT WE'RE
INVESTING TAXPAYER RESOURCES AND
TO DEVELOP THEIR MINDS- LOOKS
LIKE COMMUNITY ORGANIZING TO ME.
OF WHO'S WHO ARE THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE MENTORING OR TRAINING HIS
PEOPLE AND GETTING PAID TO DO
SO. WITH THESE RESOURCES. CAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE THIS OR
WOULD YOU PREFER FOR ME TO-
FOCUSED AT BEEN IN- MAYBE CAN
JUMP IN. THE COMMUNITIES
ORGANISE ARE GONNA BE UP THAT
MENTOR- AND THESE ARE. IT'S NOT
COMMITTEE ORDER I THESE ARE. AS
ORGANIZATION ARE SERVING THE
IMMIGRANT POPULATION- LANGUAGE
SERVICES IT IS A BIG DEAL- LEGAL
- SO IT IS THOSE THOSE. AND
WORKING WITH STUDENTS TO REALLY
HAVE A PASSION AGAINST FOR GOING
INTO A INTO NONPROFIT WORK INTO
GOING GOING INTO IS THAT WHAT WE
SEE BASED ORGANIZATIONS- SO YEAH
MAYBE THAT. COVERED OR NOT IT
ABBY CAN CHIME IN YEAH THE ONLY
THING I WOULD ADD IS THAT THEY
WILL ALSO BE GETTING MENTORING
THROUGH THE COLLEGES.AND CAREER
ADVISING AND ACADEMIC SUPPORT
TO- AS I MENTIONED SO IT REALLY
IS A- VERY UN WELL COORDINATED-
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM. SO FOR
INSTANCE THE OIL TECH ACADEMY
AND IN TAFT CALIFORNIA WHICH IS-
IN ITS AT TAFT COLLEGE. AS DAVID
TAKE YOUNG PEOPLE AND TEACH THEM
THE BENEFITS OF- YOU KNOW THE
OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY- PETROLEUM
BY PRODUCTS EVERY PLASTIC
HOSPITAL OF VALVES ANYTHING THAT
WORKS IN A HOSPITAL SO THEY
TEACH THEM ABOUT. A AND ABOUT
THE BENEFITS OF THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY UNDER A NON PROFIT AND
THEY ALSO ARE PART OF A COLLEGE
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE TOUGH
COLLEGE. IS THAT SOMETHING THAT
THEY CAN APPLY FOR SOME OF THESE
RESOURCES OR IS THIS JUST FOR-
I'D I'D I DON'T HAVE ANOTHER
WORD THAT DEMOCRAT CAUSES I'M
JUST. I DON'T HAVE ANOTHER WORD
AND I DON'T MEAN TO BE PARTISAN
ABOUT IT I REALLY DON'T I JUST I
JUST. I LOOKED UP RIGHT NOW THE
EMERALD CITY ORGANIZATION. AND-
IS IT AVAILABLE TO OTHER
INDUSTRIES OR OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS BESIDES THAT
ORGANIZATION. ON THIS PARTICULAR
INITIATIVE WAS DESIGNED AS PART
OF THE OVERALL IMMIGRANT.
INTEGRATION AND ECONOMIC
MOBILITY. PACKAGE AND- WITH THE
GOAL OF TRAINING STUDENTS
EXPLICITLY IN LEGAL SERVICES TO
IMMIGRANTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
ON AND SO THAT IS THE FOCUS OF
THIS- SPECIFIC PROPOSAL HONEST
TEN MENTIONED. OFFERING ACADEMIC
WORK AND PATHWAYS INTO- ALL
KINDS OF LEGAL CAREERS-
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE THE
FOCUS OF THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL. THAT I HADN'T LEARNED
HEARD ABOUT THE OTHER PROGRAM
YOU MENTIONED WOULD BE REALLY
INTERESTED IN LEARNING MORE.
THANK YOU MA'AM. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF WHICH FOR THE WE'RE
NOW GOING TO MOVE THANK YOU
MISTER RAINY MIST NAY AND OTHERS
TRUE- PRESENTED TODAY APPRECIATE
ALL YOUR HARD WORK AND
ESPECIALLY MOVINGUS TOWARDS
THOSE- CURRENT AND FUTURE A GOOD
PAYING JOB SPREE **** ALL OF
YOUR WORK WE WILL NOW MOVE ON.
TO ISSUES FIVE TO SEVEN. AND
THIS IS WITH REGARDS TO THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT- I WANT TO WELCOME
THE EDT DIRECTOR NANCY FARI AS-
TO PROVIDE THE ARE COMMITTEE
WITH SOME COMMENTS AND UPDATES-
AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE
SPECIFIC. ISSUES DIRECTOR. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE GOOD MORNING THANKS
FOR INVITING US HERE TODAY TO
UPDATE YOU ON THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSALS AS WELL AS SOME
OF THE PROGRESS MADE OVER THE
LAST FEW MONTHS AND EDIE DATE
FOR THE RECORD MY NAME IS NANCY
VARIOUS I AM THE NEW DIRECTOR OF
THE UNEMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT SH AND WITH ME TODAY
IS MY TEAM TO HELP RESPOND TO
ANY QUESTIONS. AND WHILE I AM
EVER SO GRATEFUL TO HAVE THIS
AMAZING TEAM WITH ME TODAY I
WOULD BE REMISS IN NOT
ACKNOWLEDGING AND THANKING THE
STAFF WHO ARE NOT. THOSE WHO ARE
DOING THE WORK THAT DIRECTLY
IMPACT CALLUM CALIFORNIANS THOSE
IN THE CALL CENTER THOSE PULLING
AND ANALYZING DATA SO WE CAN
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS. AND THE
THOUSANDS OF EMPLOYEES ARE
DEDICATED TO HELPING PEOPLE
NAVIGATE THE COMPLEXITY THAT CAN
BE EDT. ESPECIALLY AS WE
CONTINUE THROUGH THESE DIFFICULT
TIMES. I THANK THEM FOR THEIR
COMMITMENT TO CALIFORNIA. I'M
GONNA JUMP RIGHT IN AND TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE IMPROVEMENTS
THAT WE HAVE MADE AT EDT. IN
RESPONSE TO RISING NUMBERS OF
CLAIMANTS WAITING FOR BENEFITS
EARLY LAST YEAR WE LAUNCHED A
NEW PAY NOW PROGRAMS. THAT
EXPEDITED AT THAT TIME
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND PAYMENTS. THESE CLAIMS
WERE PAID IMMEDIATELY AS EDT
CONTINUED ITS WORK TO VERIFY
ELIGIBILITY. WHILE THESE
CLAIMANTS ARE NO LONGER WAITING
FOR PAYMENT THE DEPARTMENTS WORK
TO DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY REMAINS
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND CLAIMANTS STILL
REQUIRE AN INTERVIEW TO
DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY. EVEN IF
THEY ALREADY RECEIVE THEIR
BENEFITS. TO BETTER MANAGE THE
PROCESSING OF THOSE CLAIMS WE
BOOSTED BENDER STAFFING AND NO
SMALL PART THANKS TO THIS
COMMITTEE LED BY CHAIR TORONTO
OF CURSE. LAST YEAR AND CROSS
TRAINED MORE STAFF TO HANDLE
COMMON ISSUES REQUIRING
INTERVIEWS AND CONTINUED TO SHED
STAFF TOWARD CLAIM DETERMINATION
WE ARE WORKING TOWARDS A WRITTEN
QUESTIONNAIRE IN LIEU OF PHONE
CALL INTERVIEWS TO MORE QUICKLY
GATHER ELIGIBILITY INFORMATION
IN ORDR TO MAKE A DETERMINATION
AND MUCH LESS TIME. MEANWHILE AS
I'M SURE YOU HAVE SEEN IN TO FEND OFF
AGGRESSIVE FRAUD ATTEMPTS FROM
THOSE WHO ATTACKED STATE.
UNEMPLOYMENT SYSTEMS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. OUR EXPANDED PROTECTION
MEASURES INCLUDING THE CONTRACTS
THAT ARE VOIGTS BEFORE YOU
TODAY. BLOCKS OVER A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY BILLION AND FRAUD
ATTEMPTS AND TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE FRAUD
PREVENTION CONTRACTS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ASSIST US IN
PAYING CLAIMS TIMELY WHILE
CONTINUING TO PREVENT SCAMMERS
FROM INFILTRATING OUR SYSTEMS ON
THE FRONT END. I ALSO UNDERSTAND
THE MANY CONCERNS OF THIS
COMMITTEE REGARDING THE OVER
PAYMENT PROCESS AND WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE FOR THOSE WHO MAY
HAVE RECEIVED PAYMENTS THROUGH
NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN DURING THE
PANDEMIC. YOUR CONCERNS ARE ALSO
MY CONCERNS AND I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A FEW POINTS.
CURRENTLY WE ARE NOT
ESTABLISHING OVER PAYMENTS FOR
FEDERAL BENEFITS AND ONE OF THE
REASONS IS BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
ALONG WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF STATE WORKFORCE
AGENCIES ARE NOT SLUSH CONTINUES
TO LEAD DISCUSSIONS ON THIS
TOPIC WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR AND CONGRESS. WE SHARE THE
CONCERNS THAT CLAIMANTS WHO ARE
NON FRAUD NON FAULT SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO GET A BLANKET WAIVER
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR AGREED
AND ISSUED NEW GUIDANCE
REGARDING BLANKET WAIVERS AND
YOU CAN BE SURE THAT WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF EVERY
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE CAN'T TO BE
FLEXIBLE. FOR THIS NON
pUPDATE ON OUR FRAUD PREVENTION
MEASURES IS THE PROGRESS OF
FORMER U. S. ATTORNEY MCGREGOR
SCOTT WHO EDT HIRED AS FRAUD
SPECIAL COUNSEL LAST YEAR. I CAN
PERSONALLY SAY THAT GREG IS TEAM
HAVE HAD A VAST IMPACT AND
PARSING TO THE SUSPECTED FRAUD
OF TWENTY TWENTY. ONE OF GREG'S
MOST HELPFUL ACCOMPLISHMENTS HAS
BEEN INTO SUFFOCATING ACCESS TO
EVIDENCE TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THIS WAS ONE OF EDIE'S BIGGEST
CHALLENGES WE JUST DIDN'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES OR THE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH FEDERAL
STATE. AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO HELP GET THE DATA TO THEM
QUICKLY WHEN IT WAS NEEDED. NOW
INSTEAD OF A LENGTHY SUBPOENA
PROCESSING GRANT HAS HELPED TO
FACILITATE AN MO YOU PROCESS
WHICH EDT AUTOMATED AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT NOW HAS IMMEDIATE
ACCESS TO THE DATA FOR THE CASES
THAT THEY ARE INVESTIGATING.
WELL CLEARLY LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
STILL IN THE INVESTIGATION STAGE
FOR MANY OF THESE FRAUD CASES
GREG WORKS WITH ID ME THOMSON
REUTERS AND ACCENTURE TO
LEVERAGE THE FRAUD ANALYTICS
NEEDED TO PROVIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH THE DATA AND
EVIDENCE BUT THE MOST EGREGIOUS
CASES. SO THEY CAN MOVE INTO THE
NEXT COUPLE OF STAGES WHICH IS
OF COURSE PROSECUTION AND
RESTITUTION DDD. THE RECESSION
CAUSED BY KOBE NINETEEN FOLLOWED
NOHISTORICAL PATTERN AS WE HAVE
DISCUSSED EARLIER TODAY.
UNEMPLOYMENT ROSE FROM RECORD
LOWS OF THREE POINT 9% TO
SIXTEEN POINT 4% IN TWO MONTHS
THE FASTEST RISE EVER RECORDED.
EVERY STATE HAS HAD TO RETHINK
WHAT THEY THOUGHT THEY KNEW
ABOUT RECESSION PLANNING. UNDER
SB THREE NINETY BY SENATE
EARLIER IN THE DAY CRAFTED A
VERY FEDERAL PLAN TO BETTER
PREPARE FOR FUTURE EMERGENCIES
AND ECONOMIC ECONOMIC
RECESSIONS. I KNEW PLAN INCLUDES
CAREFUL MONITORING OF MARKET
CONDITIONS AND RIGOROUS WORKLOAD
FORECASTING TIED TO STATE AND
NATIONAL ECONOMIC INDICATORS. WE
ARE ALSO ANALYZING JOB DUTY
CLASSIFICATIONS TO ENSURE STAFF
ARE DEPLOYED AND AS EFFECTIVELY
AS POSSIBLE. FINALLY EDT WILL
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENTS THAT HELP CUSTOMERS
AVOID THE NEED TO SPEAK WITH EDT
STAFF IN THE FIRST PLACE. OUR
RECESSION PLAN IS DUE TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO DAY AND WE ARE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL
BRIEFINGS ON ITS CONTENTS IN THE
COMING WEEKS. MANY OF THE
REFORMS AND BUDGET REQUESTS THAT
ARE BEFORE YOU TODAY COME FROM
THE WELL THOUGHT OUT
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR AND THE
EDT STRIKE TEAM. WE HAVE MET
EVERY DEADLINE SET BY THE STATE
AUDITOR AND SO SEVENTEEN OF THE
TWENTY ONE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
COMPLETE ARE EIGHTY ONE PERCENT.
THE REMAINING RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE WELL UNDER WAY INCLUDE
HIRING AND TRAINING THE STAFF TO
CARRY OUT WORKLOAD PLANNING AND
IDENTIFYING AREAS FOR FUTURE
AUTOMATED AUTOMATIC CLAIM
PROCESSING. THE STRIKE TEAM
RECOMMENDATIONS OF WHICH THERE
WERE ONE HUNDRED. 81% COMPLETE.
INCLUDING 1100% OF THE SHORT
TERM AND NEAR TERM
RECOMMENDATIONS. AS WE HAVE
MENTIONED IN PREVIOUS HEARINGS
AND IN FULL TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WE CREATED A
PUBLIC AUDIT PROGRESS REPORT
WEBPAGE THAT DETAILS THE
DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS TO COMPLETE
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS AND I HOPE
IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT THE
CONTINUED IMPLEMENTATION AND
COMPLETION OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS IS A PRIORITY OF
MINE IN MY NEW ROLE AS DIRECTOR
. MANY OF EIGHTY DAYS
SIGNIFICANT TECHNOLOGY
MODERNIZATION PROJECTS WERE
PLANNED BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
BEGAN. COVERING NINETEEN TESTED
OUR SYSTEMS AND CAPABILITIES TO
THEIR LIMITS AND CAUSE US TO
RETHINK SOME OF OUR APPROACHES.
IN RESPONSE WE REVISE THE
DIRECTION OF OUR TECHNOLOGY
MODERNIZATION WORK TO BRING
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENTS THAT CAN HANDLE
MORE EXTREME SURGES IN CLAIM
ACTIVITY. ADDITIONALLY WE
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN LANGUAGE
AND USABILITY IMPROVEMENTS
CARRYING OUT OUR MISSION TO
PROCLAIM ITS FIRST. DURING THE
PANDEMIC EDT IS INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY BRANCH DELIVERED MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED TECHNOLOGY
PROJECTS TO IMPROVE CUSTOMER
SERVICE AND SPEED PAYMENT THERE
IS MUCH MORE TO COME AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO UPDATING THE
LEGISLATURE AS WE AS WE PROGRESS
OVER THE NEXT YEAR. AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WITH THE TREMENDOUS
HELP OF THIS COMMITTEE EDT.
EXPANDED AND IMPROVED ITS
LANGUAGE ASSISTANCE SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY THIS INCLUDES MORE
TRANSLATION AND INTERPRETER
SERVICES INCLUDING A MULTI
LINGUAL ACCESS PORTAL. AS WE ARE
ALL AWARE ONE IN FIVE
CALIFORNIANS COMMUNICATE AND
LANGUAGES OTHER THAN ENGLISH SO
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME THAT
YOU NEED TO CONTINUE THIS WORK.
RECENTLY EDT EXPANDED ITS
TRANSLATION SERVICES AND TRAIN
FRONT LINE STAFF TO CONNECT
CALLERS WITH TRANSLATORS WHO CAN
NOW ASSIST IN HUNDREDS OF
LANGUAGES. AND YOU MAY HAVE ALSO
SEEN THAT JUST YESTERDAY EDT
REACHED AGREEMENT WITH SEVERAL
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE L. A. P.
COMMUNITY TO ADD MORE DEDICATED
PHONE LINES WITH MULTI LINGUAL
AGENTS AND EXPAND WRITTEN
TRANSLATION OF VITAL
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
INFORMATION AN ONLINE RESOURCES.
WE ALSO CREATED AND OUR STAFFING
A LANGUAGE ACCESS OFFICE TO
FURTHER EXPAND LANGUAGE
TRANSLATION AND- SERVICE DESK
AND WILL BE BUILDING OUT A MULTI
LINGUAL WEBSITE ACCESS PORTAL.
PORTAL WE ARE VERY PROUD OF THE
PROGRESS THAT WE HAVE MADE ON
THIS BUT WE KNOW THERE'S A LOT
MORE WORK TO BE DONE. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO PARTNER WITH
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION AND SUPPORT
IN AS MANY LANGUAGES AS NEEDED
TO INSURE. THIS POPULATION AS
WELL SERVICE. IN CONCLUSION THE
GOVERNOR'S BY PER. FOR EATING
GAME UPON THE PROGRESS MADE IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND LAYS THE
GROUNDWORK FOR ADDITIONAL
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE YEARS AHEAD
. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I
APPRECIATE THE PARTNERSHIP WE
DEVELOPED THE LEGISLATURE DURING
THESE EXTREMELY CHALLENGING
TIMES PAST COUPLE OF YEARS. AND
I ESPECIALLY WANT TO THANK YOUR
STAFF FOR ALL THE INCREDIBLE
WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE TO ASSIST
CLAIMANTS IN YOUR DISTRICT
OFFICES. AND MY TEAM IN HIGH
HERE I'M SORRY MY TEAM AND I ARE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
GREAT THANK YOU DIRECTOR FOR IS
BAH APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR WORK
AND- STEPPING UP TO TAKE CHARGE
HOPEFULLY AND THEN IN THE NEW-
TIME I KNOW YOU WERE ALREADY AT
THE EIGHTY D. BUT NOW AS
DIRECTOR OF WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT THE BIG CHANGES THAT NEED
TO BE MADE- WE WANT TO MOVE ON
NOW TO ISSUE FIVE. WERE ISSUE
FIVE WE'RE GONNA MOVE INTO ISSUE
FIVE ADDRESSING YOU WHY DEBT
FINANCE- I DON'T KNOW WHO WILL
BE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT IS THAT YOU'D
DIRECTOR FOR YES ON ISSUE FIVE
ADDRESSING YOU AYE DEBT FINANCE
. IT WILL BE A FINANCE. THANK
YOU ARE PATRICK TOP AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- REGARDING
THE U. HIGH DEBT PAYMENTS
CONSISTENT WITH EVEN GRAZING
LIABILITIES INSTRUCTOR
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE BUDGET
INCLUDES ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR TOTAL OF THREE
MILLION THE NEXT TWO YEARS TO
PAY DOWN THE U. I TRUST FUND
LOAN THAT WAS TAKEN OUT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. GOING TO PAY
YOU AYE BENEFIT UNDER
INTERRUPTED IT WHEN THE PHONE
WENT INSOLVENT IN TWENTY TWENTY
THIS WILL REDUCE THE STATE'S
LIABILITIES CELEBRATE THE
PAYMENT OF THE DEBT AND REDUCE
FUTURE INTEREST PAYMENTS AT
COULD YOU WHY THAT IS CURRENTLY
NINETEEN POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS HAVE TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
TOPPEN- L. A. L. THANK YOU JUST
DOWNLOAD THE L. A- LATE LAST
MONTH OUR OFFICE RELEASED A
REPORT ON ON THIS ITEM IN
PARTICULAR- AND SO JUST FOR
CONTEXT AGAIN UNDER THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES THREE BILLION DOLLAR
PAYMENT ON THE STATE'S
OUTSTANDING FEDERAL LOAN ON THAT
REPRESENTS ABOUT 15% OF THE
PRINCIPAL AMOUNT OF THE LOAN.
AND AGAIN- EMPLOYERS WILL REPAY
THAT THIS AMOUNT UNDER EXISTING
FEDERAL TAX LAW OVER THE COMING
YEARS AND- HISTORICALLY ARE
CUSTOMARILY THE STATE HAS PAID
THE INTEREST COST EACH YEAR OFF
FROM THE GENERAL FUND- WE- IN
OUR REPORT INCLUDE A COUPLE
SCENARIOS IN WHICH WE MODELED
THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS OF
REPAYMENT TO GET A BETTER SENSE
OF THE PHYSICAL EFFECTS OF THIS
PROPOSAL- WE ESTIMATE THAT THE
PROPOSED THREE BILLION DOLLAR
PAYMENT. WILL REDUCE STATE
GENERAL FUND INTEREST COSTS BY
BETWEEN FIVE AND FIFTY MILLION
AND ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE LIFE OF THE
LOAN- WHICH WE THINK WILL BE
SOMEWHERE IN THE RANGE OF TEN TO
TWELVE YEARS- ADDITIONALLY ARE
WE ESTIMATE THE TOTAL STATE
INTEREST COSTS COULD RANGE FROM
TWO AND A HALF TO SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS AND THAT'S PRINCIPALLY
DEPENDING ON FUTURE INTEREST
RATES- WHICH AS WE'VE SEEN IN
JUST RECENT. MONTHS ARE ARE LESS
CERTAIN THAN THEY WERE- MAYBE.
THIS TIME LAST YEAR- WE ALSO
KNOW THAT PROPOSED BILLION
DOLLAR PAYMENT HAVE THE- OF
REDUCING. EMPLOYER PAYROLL
TAXES- AND THAT WOULD OCCUR IF
THE PAYMENT. IN ESSENCE SHORTENS
THE NUMBER OF YEARS THAT THAT
EMPLOYERS ARE ARE REQUIRED TO
PAY HIGHER FEDERAL. YOU AYE
TAXES TO REPAY THE LOAN I'M WE
DO POINT OUT THAT IT'S NOT.
CERTAIN THAT THE THREE BILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSED PAYMENT WOULD
SHORTEN THE LIFE OF THE LOAN-
AND IF IT WERE NOT TO EMPLOYERS
WOULD CONTINUE TO PAY THE
INCREASED- FEDERAL YOU AYE
PAYROLL TAXES BUT- ANY CARRYOVER
REVENUE THAT WAS GENERATED FROM
THAT. AFTER REPAYING THE LOAN
FOR THE STATE'S YOU I TRUST
FUND- AND THEREFORE HAVE SOME
INDIRECT BENEFITS TO BOTH
BUSINESSES AND THE STATE-
BECAUSE THE PROPOSED PAYMENT
WOULD NOT. DIRECTLY BENEFIT
EMPLOYERS FOR UP TO TEN YEARS
FOR THE END OF THE LONG PERIOD-
WE DO PROPOSE AN ALTERNATIVE IF
THE LEGISLATURE HE'S INTERESTED
IN PROVIDING MORE IMMEDIATE.
RELIEF TO WORKERS AND
BUSINESSES- THE STATE COULD-
CONTEMPLATING ALTERNATIVE
WHEREBY. THE STATE PROVIDED YOU
I PAYROLL TAX CREDITS TO
BUSINESSES IN THE COMING YEARS
TO DIRECTLY OFFSET THE AMOUNT OF
INCREASED FEDERAL TAXES THEY'LL
BE PAYING TO- READ BEGIN
REPAYING THAT THE FED WOULD YOU
AYE WELL- I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS OR WALK THROUGH
MODELING IN MORE DETAIL.
APPRECIATIVE WITH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- AGAIN. HAVE A BASE-QUESTION- ABOUT. OF THE STATE
PUTTING IN A THREE BILLION
DOLLARS. AND MAYBE YOU CAN MAKE
THESE CONNECTIONS FOR ME. IS AS
YOU SAID THIS STATE THE STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITIES TO PAY INTEREST
ON ANY LOAN THAT WE- YOU DON'T
HAVE TO TAKE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- WHY. AND HOW DOES
THE EMPLOYER'S RESPONSIBILITY UP
TO FIT INTO THE PAYMENT OF THE
LOAN. OF THE FEDERAL LOANS AND-
HOW DOES THE- HERE. WHAT IS THE
PART THAT- CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS
YOU IS STATE TAXES IS THE LOWEST
ALLOWED UNDER FEDERAL LAW SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR HOW DOES
THAT FIT INTO THIS NEW
ACCUMULATED A DEBT TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. I DON'T KNOW
WHO WANTS TO ANSWER THAT. BUT I
I'D BE HAPPY TO MADAM CHAIR-
GETTING SAYS ALMOST THAT WITH
THE L. A. O. OUT YOUR FIRST
POINT I'M FEDERAL LAW OUR
LONGSTANDING FEDERAL LAW
DICTATES HOW. FEDERAL YOU AYE
LOANS ARE TO BE REPAID- AND SO
YOU MENTIONED THAT THAT
CUSTOMARILY THE STATE HAS BEEN
RESPONSIBLE FOR PAYING- THAT THE
ANNUAL INTEREST COSTS AND
EMPLOYERS PAY REPAY ABOUT THE
PRINCIPAL AMOUNT OF THE LOAN AND
NEVER PAYMENT PLAN IF YOU WILL
IT- AS FOR IN TRYING TO GET IN
FEDERAL TAX LAW- AND IT INVOLVES
BASICALLY AN INCREMENTAL
INCREASE IN THE FEDERAL PORTION
OF YOU AYE TABLE TAXES. OVER
TIME AS LONG AS THE LOAN REMAINS
OUTSTANDING UNTIL THE LOAN IS.
ON THIS WAS THE SAME PROCESS
THAT THE STATE AND EMPLOYERS
FOLLOWED- FOLLOWING THE GREAT
RECESSION WHEN THE STATE ALSO
BORROWED. FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR YOU I BENEFITS-
IF YOU REMIND ME AGAIN OF THE
SECOND QUESTION I NOW LOST MY
TRAIN OF THOUGHT PRETTY WELL I
AND I SEE IN THE IMPROVE. BACK
HIM FOR. THAT SINCE NINE EIGHTY-
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS YOU Y.
STATE TAXES THE LOWEST ALLOWED
UNDER FEDERAL LAW- HOW DOES THAT
FIT INTO THIS. WE'RE NOW HAVING
TO PAY MORE. OF OBVIOUSLY FOR A
DAD AND A LOAN THAT NOBODY EVER
EXPECTED NOBODY. COULD IMAGINE
THAT SO I'M JUST TRYING TO GET
HERE THE CONNECTION ON THE
CLARITY AS TO THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF EMPLOYERS IN THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE STATE. AND
HOW THIS LOW- TAX RATE- FITS
INTO ALL OF THAT. THE ADDAMS
SHARED- AS YOU MENTIONED
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT THE STATE'S
YOU AYE PAYROLL TAX BASE INSTEAD
OF SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT
IS THE LOWEST ALLOWABLE AMOUNT
UNDER FEDERAL LAW- MANY STATES
HAVE HIGHER TAX BASES- BUT A LOT
OF THOSE STATES TO. TURN LEVY A
LOWER RATES- AGAINST THAT THEIR
HIGHER TAX BASES BUT IN GENERAL-
IF THE STATE WERE TO INCREASE
THE U. I. PAYROLL TAX BASED IT
WOULD HAVE HAD THE EFFECT OF.
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR
THE STATE YOU I TRUST FUND WHICH
HEADING INTO THE PANDEMIC WHAT
ELSE WOULD PUT THE STATE IN A
BETTER POSITION TO CONTINUE
PAYING BENEFITS FOR A LONGER
PERIOD. PRIOR TO TURNING TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR LOANS- I
WILL CAUTION THOUGH THAT. EVEN
HAVE THE STATE TAKEN. STEPS TO
IMPROVE THE FISCAL POSITION OF
THE U. I TRUST FUND. THE
PANDEMIC WAS SO ENORMOUS IN
MAGNITUDE IT'S LIKELY THAT UNDER
EVEN THE BEST OF SCENARIOS- THE
STATE WOULD HAVE HAD TO REACH
OUT TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
CONTINUE PAYING LOANS. ARE TO
CONTINUE PAYING BENEFITS- BUT-
IRRESPECTIVE OF THAT AT THIS
POINT. AS A RESULT THE STATE
WOULD HAVE NOT FEWER OUTSTANDING
LOANS- TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
FOR TECHNICAL WORK. OKAY FOR NOW
WITH THAT SAID- NUMBERS. SENATE
CRITICIZING THE CENTER TO GROW.
THIS IS PROBABLY QUESTIONS MUCH
FOR FINANCES THE ONLY OPEN- BUT
FOR SOME REASON I FEEL LIKE
DIRECTED TO THE OLE OLE I'M A
LITTLE- BUT I GUESS I PROMISE I
HAVE WITH WITH LIABILITIES ON
THE BALANCE SHEET IN IN ANY
ORGANIZATION PUBLIC OR PRIVATE.
IS THERE THE BEST. RESOLVED
OFTENTIMES BY- KEEPING THEM.
KEEPING THE BUSINESS ON THE
BALLOT SHEET METAL WORDS TAKING.
AN ASSET IN THE LIQUIDATING IT
IF THAT'S WHAT YOU NEED TO DO A
TO PAY OFF THE LIABILITY THAT'S
ON THE BALANCE SHEET SO YOU
BASICALLY HAVE. YOU KNOW A NET-
THE NET ZERO RESULTS IN YOUR
COLLEGE. THE IDEA OF SUPPLYING-
A LONG TERM STATE CREDIT AT THE
BUSINESSES TO HELP THEM TO HE
NOTED TO OFFSET THAT THE FEDERAL
COSTS EIGHT AGREES- INNOVATIVE-
BUT IT FEELS LIKE IT SHIFTING- A
BALANCE SHEET. LIABILITY OVER TO
OVER TO THE GENERAL FUND- WHERE
WE HAVE ONGOING COSTS WHO WAS
MOST CERTAINLY HAVE RISING
ONGOING COSTS IN THE FUTURE WE
MOST CERTAINLY WILL HAVE A
PERIOD OF TIME IN THE FUTURE WE
ARE EXPERIENCING SURPLUSES SO.
THAT WITH THAT BACKDROP MY
THINKING- HAVE YOU LOOKED AT. IS
THIS SOME KIND OF- OPPORTUNITY.
HI I'M TO USE FIXED ASSETS THAT
ARE NO LONGER. NEEDED BY THE
STATE ID I THINK OF EXCESS LANDS
WERE TOLD BY- AT LEAST ONE OF
OUR AGENCIES THAT'S MAPPED OUT
THE EXCESS LANDS FOR THE STATE
THAT WE HAVE FORTY FOUR THOUSAND
PARCELS OF EXCESS LAND IN THE
STATE- WOULD IT MAKE ANY SENSE-
IN ORDER TO IN ORDER TO- EITHER
ELIMINATE OR START THE FRAME OR
MITIGATE. THE INTEREST PAYMENTS
WERE PAID ON THIS DEBT TO USE.
EXCESSIVE LAND LIQUIDATION- FOR
THE TIME BEING TO TAKE SOME OF
THOSE PARCELS OFF OF OUR- OF THE
ASSET SALE ON OUR BALANCE SHEET.
AND HANDED TAKE THOSE ONE TIME
DOLLARS TO REDUCE ITS DEBT. IT
SEEMS TO ME YOU COULD STILL. A
BOOK THE LIABILITY- HERE TO THE
BUSINESSES HOWEVER YOU WANTED
GOOD IN IN THAT WAY IT WOULD
ACTUALLY HELP THE GENERAL FUND
BY. DIFFERENT INTEREST COSTS
WITHOUT PASSING ANY NEW COSTS ON
TO THE GENERAL FUND. SENATOR
CORTESE SAYS ALMOST THE L. A. O.
I. PROBABLY WOULD NEED TO DEFER
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS
TO WHETHER THEY'VE LOOKED INTO
IT OR THE POTENTIAL
COMPLICATIONS E'D BE HAPPY TO.
EXPLORE THE IDEA WITH YOU AND
YOUR STAFF- BUT IT'S NOT
SOMETHING WE'VE LOOKED AT
SPECIFICALLY. GREAT THAT'S- BUT
THE YOU KNOW THAT'S WHAT I WANT
TO KNOW WHETHER YOU TO LOOK AT
IT YET WE CAN FOLLOW UP WITH YOU
IN JUST THE SAME QUESTION FOR
FINANCES. IN EXPLORING OPTIONS
SO HAVE YOU LOOKED AT WHAT I
JUST DESCRIBED. ASSEMBLY CORTESE
OF HUNDRED TOPPING DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- I DO NOT BELIEVE IT HAS
BEEN CONSIDERED ALTHOUGH WE JUST
SORT OF UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS
THE EASY THIS WAS THE MOST
DIRECT WAY OF PAYING DOWN. KEEP
A BOOK WILL CIRCLE BACK. IN ALSO
THE MEDIAN TRUCKS FOR THAT'LL
FURTHER APPRECIATED I'M SURE
THANK YOU SENATOR CENTER GROVE
THANK YOU MA'AM SHARON THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR THOSE QUESTIONS IT'S
A GREAT IDEA- ON LEVERAGING
ASSETS I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS- THE CHAIR MENTION
THAT WE HAVE THE LOWEST RATE- I
CAN'T SEEM TO FIND THAT SO
SOMEBODY COULD EXPLAIN IT TO ME
I WOULD. MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT WE PAY ROUGHLY SIX POINT 9%
ON THE FIRST SEVEN THOUSAND. AND
THAT'S INCLUDING FEDERAL AND
STATE WITH THE FOOD A TAX
REDUCTION CREDIT. DEBT IS- THAT
WOULD LOAN REPAYMENT MECHANISM
AND THAT IS BILL TO EMPLOYERS ON
A AND YOU'LL PLEASE BASIS PLUS
WE HAVE A 15% EMERGENCY
SURCHARGE. WHICH IS ROUGHLY
ESTIMATE ON MY BRIEF
CALCULATIONS AGAIN I'M- AT A
FINANCE PERSON BUT- THAT'S- IT'S
LIKE 65% HIGHER THAN ALMOST ANY
OTHER STATE IN THE NATION
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE HIGHEST TAX
INCREASE FOR EMPLOYMENT. SO- IS
THAT TRUE OR IS IT JUST BECAUSE
THE SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS LIKE
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
THAT QUESTION WAS GOING. I'M
SORRY WHO ARE YOU ASKING CENTER
THAT I GUESS THE L. A. OVER THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SENATOR
PATRICK TOPPING DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I'M CAN YOU PLEASE
REPEAT THE QUESTION I WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE ANSWERED HIS DIRECT
WAYS POSSIBLE. SO THE CHAIR
MENTIONED THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
THE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT ARE YOU
I TAX RATE. AND IT HASN'T BEEN
CHANGED SINCE WHATEVER YEAR WAS
MENTIONED. BUT A QUICK REFERENCE
ON NET AND STATE YOU AYE RATES
CALIFORNIA'S AT SIX POINT 9% ON
THE FIRST SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
EARNED FOR EMPLOYERS- SKEWS ME
EMPLOYEES AND AN ADDITIONAL 15%
EMERGENCY SURCHARGE. COMPARED TO
OTHER STATES THAT ARE THREE
POINT ONE TWO POINT FIVE POINT
FIVE ZERO SOME OF THEM HAVE AND
THEN SOME OF THEM ARE EMPLOYEE
AND EMPLOYER SHARED COST WHERE
THE EMPLOYMENT INSURANCE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS 1100%
EMPLOYER FUNDED. SO I'M TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT AND WHAT YOUR
THOUGHTS ARE ON THAT IN IS THAT
NUMBER CORRECT THAT AND
CALIFORNIA HAS THE LOWEST YOU
AYE TAX RATE WITH THE SIX POINT
NINE AND 15% SURCHARGE COMPARED
TO OTHER STATES OR IS THAT NOT
CORRECT. THANK YOU I'M GOING TO
DEFER THAT TO MY COLLEAGUES OVER
EDIE WHO HAVE MORE PROGRAMMATIC
KNOWLEDGE THAN I DO. THANK YOU.
YEAH THANK YOU SARAH GROW FOR
THE QUESTION- CALEB MORAL ON THE
FISCAL OFFICER FOR THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. SO THERE'S ACTUALLY
TWO DIFFERENT COMPONENTS HERE
AND I THINK THE ONE THAT'S
MENTIONED YOU GENDER THAT THE
CHASSIS ALLUDED TO. IS THE
TAXABLE WAGE BASE SO THAT THE
WAGES THAT THE TAX RATES PAID
OFF OF. AND THAT IS CORRECT THAT
CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH A HANDFUL
OF OTHER STATES HAS THE LOWEST
TAXABLE WAGE BASE. THAT'S
PRESCRIBED UNDER FEDERAL LAW
WHICH IS SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
MANY OTHER STATES HAVE A HIGHER
TAXABLE WAGE BASE IN CALIFORNIA.
AS FAR AS THE ACTUAL TAX RATE
GOES THAT'S ALSO PRESCRIBE BY
FEDERAL LAW TO- AND FEDERAL LAW
DICTATES THAT AND THAT STATES
HAVE TO HAVE AT LEAST AT A TAX
RATE OF FIVE POINT FOUR PERCENT-
CALIFORNIA'S TAX RTE AS YOU
MENTIONED. WITH THE EMERGENCY
SURCHARGE CAN BE UP TO SIX POINT
TWO PERCENT- I BELIEVE- AT LEAST
BASED ON DATA FROM TWENTY
NINETEEN. THAT CALIFORNIA IS
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE AS FAR AS
ARE ON AVERAGE- YOU I TAX STREET
IN COMPARISON. TO ALL THE STATES
ACROSS THE NATION. I APPRECIATE
THAT PLEASE THING YOU SO THAT
THAT THE QUESTION THAT YOU'RE
BROUGHT UP WAS BASED ON THE
TAXABLE RATE OF THE SEVEN FOR
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS EARNED IN
. OKAY THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING
THAT I APPRECIATE THAT VERY
MUCH. NGUYEN AND THIS LOAN
REPAYMENT IS DONE AND- OR IT
WHEN THIS LOAN REPAYMENT HAS TO
START TAKING PLACE. EMPLOYERS
WILL IT BE DONE LIKE IT WAS IN
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT WITH THE
FOOD TAX REDUCTION CREDIT- AT
THE END OF THE YEAR OR IS IT
GONNA BE PAID DIFFERENTLY THIS
YEAR. THIS TIME. BECAUSE WE
SHOULD HAVE LEARNED SOME
HORRIFIC LESSONS. ON THAT FITTED
TAX REDUCTION PAYMENT THAT COST.
OF BUSINESSES TO GO OUT OF
BUSINESS- IN THE REASON I SAY
THAT IS BECAUSE THE LAST TIME
THAT WE RAN DEBT. AT THE END OF
THE YEAR OBVIOUSLY PAYER
QUARTERLY TAXES AND IT INCLUDES
YOUR- AND EMPLOYMENT TAXES ON
THE FOR SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS I
THINK IT'S A- D. SIX. THE
EMPLOYER SEND AN- AND- WHICH
INCLUDES A DISABILITY- ALL THE
WAGES THAT YOU PAID OF THE STATE
OR SKEWS ME TAXES THAT YOU PAID
OF THE STATE. SO IS THIS LOAN
REPAYMENT ON THE PRINCIPAL GONNA
BE PAID BACK BY EMPLOYERS AT THE
END OF THE YEAR FOR A LUMP SUM
PAYMENT. WHICH THEY CONSIDERED
OR CALL DEFEATED TAX REDUCTION
CREDIT PAYMENT. LIKE IT WAS
BEFORE OR IS THERE A DIFFERENT
PAYMENT SCHEDULE THAT YOU GUYS
ARE THINKING OF. SENATE
DEMOCRATIC UP AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- THERE'S BEEN NO CHANGES
TO FEDERAL STATE LAW SINCE
TWENTY ELEVEN SO- IN. THE
MECHANISM OF REPAYING IS THE
SAME ALL DIFFERENT TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN EASIER FOR THE
ACTUAL MECHANISM TO PREPAY.
THANK YOU. YEAH THANK YOU SIR
FOR THE QUESTION AGAIN AND- FUND
DEPARTED FINANCES CORRECT- THAT
THAT IS THE MECHANISM THAT
CURRENTLY EXISTS ABSENT CHANGES
TO THE U. I. FINANCING STRUCTURE
ITSELF- AS YOU MENTIONED THAT
THE FOOD A TAX CREDIT. REDUCTION
ACTUALLY STARTS THIS CALENDAR
YEAR THOSE TAXES BECOME DUE AND
PAYABLE THOSE INCREASED FEDERAL
TAX BY EMPLOYERS THE BEGINNING
OF THE FOLLOWING COUNTY OR SO
THAT'LL OCCUR IN AROUND JANUARY
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY THREE ONE
NO START PAYING OUT HIGHER
FEDERAL TAX RATE. BUT THAT IS
THE MECHANISM THAT THE FEDS USE
ABSENT ANYTHING ELSE THAT- FOR
STATES TO KIND OF PAY DOWN THE
PRINCIPAL AS YOU INDICATED. IS
THERE A CONCERN WITH ANY OF YOU
EITHER OF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR THE
EDG- WITH THE REDUCTION- THE
REDUCTION IN PROFITS FOR ON A
RESTAURANT SMALL BUSINESSES.
THAT AND- BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC AND TRYING TO REBUILD
THEIR BUSINESS THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE A PROBLEM COMING UP WITH
THAT ADDITIONAL SIXTY FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR. EVERY
YEAR ON THE PHONE ECAUSE I
THINK ONCE YOU GET THE BILL ON
THE FIRST OR SECOND IN JANUARY
TO DO BY THE FIFTEENTH. SO
THEY'D HAVE TO. COME UP WITH
THOSE RESOURCES- IS THERE WITHIN
TWO WEEKS IS THAT A CONCERN FOR
ANY OF YOU WAS STRUGGLING
BUSINESSES. I KNOW THE GOVERNOR
SAYS THAT WE HAVE AND- WE'RE
LEADING THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY-
AT THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY BUT YOU
KNOW DATA SHOWS THAT. WE'RE NOT
WE'RE ACTUALLY LAGGING BEHIND-
WITH BUSINESS FOR. BUSINESSES
GETTING BACK TO PRE PANDEMIC
DAYS. SO IS THERE A CONCERN ON
ANY OF YOUR PART. ABOUT
BUSINESSES BEING ABLE TO- MAKE
UP THE DIFFERENCE OF THAT FOOD A
TAX REDUCTION CREDIT PAYMENT
THAT WILL BE D<c.cyan> WITH LOWER</c>
REVENUES FROM BUSINESSES.
SENATOR PATRICK TOBIN DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- REGARDING THIS IS
PRECISELY WHY WE ARE PROPOSING A
THREE MILLION DOLLAR PAYMENT- TO
ACCELERATE THE PAYOFF OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT THAT BY UP TO A
YEAR- AND RESTORE THOSE- FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT TAX TAX. TAX
CREDITS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
NO AND I APPRECIATE THAT I
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
OPERATE PRECIADO OF WHAT THEY
CALL THE NEW DEMOCRATS ON THE
ASSEMBLY WITH THEIR SEVEN AND A
QUARTER BILLION DOLLAR. RELATED
REQUESTS TO- AND OPEFULLY
THERE'S NEGOTIATION FOR A HIGHER
NUMBER OF A PAY OUT SO I
APPRECIATE THE THREE BILLION
DOLLARS I DO. AND I UNDERSTAND
HOW IT WORKS- BUT THAT PRIMARILY
GOES TO INTERESTED DOESN'T
ADDRESS THAT I THINK IT'S
NINETEEN POINT SIX- BILLION OR
IS IT TWENTY ONE WHAT'S THE
TOTAL NUMBER AT WITH THE TOTAL.
DEBT NOW. SENATOR IS NINETEEN
POINT SIX SIX NINETEEN POINT SIX
BILLION AND TO BE CLEAR THE
THREE BILLION IS TO LOWER THE
DEBT. THE CURRENT INTEREST
PAYMENT IS ESTIMATED AT FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY POINT ONE
MILLION. FOR THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR OKAY THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFYING THAT IS I APPRECIATE
IT EVEN MORE NOW THAT YOU
CLARIFY THAT. AND OKAY I
APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTIONS LET ME
SEE IF I HAVE I THOUGHT I HAD
ONE MORE. AND. IS THERE ANYTHING
I KNOW THAT THERE IS A
SUBSTANTIAL A DOLLAR NUMBER OF
FRAUD AT AN AMOUNT OF FRAUD THAT
TOOK PLACE AND AGAIN I KNOW THAT
EDT AND I KNOW THAT THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT HAS- NOT COME FULL
CIRCLE BUT TAKEN LEAPS AND
BOUNDS OF WHERE THEY WERE- IN
ADDRESSING. YOU KNOW FRAUD AND
OVER PAYMENTS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT. IS THAT- I THINK THAT THE
NEXT ISSUE. THAT WE WILL BE
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF FRAUD.
OKAY BUT SO ACCORDING TO THE
DEBT IS ANY OF THE NINETEEN
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN
DEBT DOES THAT INCLUDE ANY OF
THE FRAUDULENT PAYMENTS THAT
WENT OUT. ASSEMBLY I WILL ALSO
THE FOR THAT ONE TO MY-
COLLEAGUES AT THE E. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
THE QUESTION AGAIN- KILLED
LAUREL DDD- YEAH SO ANY
FRAUDULENT PAYMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN PAID OUT OUT OF THE STATE'S
YOU I TRUST FUND WOULD BE PART
OF THAT THAT- OUTSTANDING
ADVANCE BALLOTS- AND AS YOU
MENTIONED AND I AND OTHERS HAVE
DISCUSSED AND WE TALKED IN PRIOR
HEARINGS ABOUT- THAT ESTIMATED
FRAUD FIGURES ABOUT TWENTY
BILLION OVERALL. HOWEVER OF THAT
TWENTY BILLION ABOUT A BILLION
OF THAT IS TIED TO REGULAR YOU
AYE PAYMENT SO THE PAYMENTS THAT
COME OUT OF OUR TRUST FUND. AND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT IN
COMPARISON TO THE REGULAR YOU
ARE PAYMENTS THAT THE
DEPARTMENTS PAID OUT OVER THE
COURSE OF THE PANDEMIC IT
ACTUALLY AMOUNTS TO AROUND THREE
TO FOUR PERCENT. OF THE OVERALL-
REGULAR YOU AYE PAYMENT CENTER
CONSIDERED FRAUDULENT- THAT HAVE
COME OUT OF THE TRUST FUND WHICH
IS WITHIN IN ANY NORMAL YEAR
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY FRAUD IN AN
INSURANCE PROGRAM THAT THAT'S
WITHIN THE NORMAL AMOUNT THIS
WITHIN OUR OUR REGULAR YOU AYE
PROGRAM IN A NORMAL YEAR- BUT IT
IS INCLUDED IN THAT OVERALL
FIGURE. THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S- WHEN WE
DEAL WITH BILLIONS AND TRILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ARE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT SIGNIFICANT BUT
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING TO THE
RESTAURANT OWNER WHO'S SPEAKING
COSTS WENT UP. YOU KNOW 75% AND
WHOSE TRANSPORTATION COSTS WENT
UP BY 4100% AND THEN YOU SAY YOU
KNOW BY THE WAY THIS ADDITIONAL
BILLION DOLLARS IN FRAUD THAT
WAS PAID OUT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO PAY BACK AS WELL FOR YOUR PRO
RATA SHARE. IT HAS A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON EVERY SMALL BUSINESS
THAT EACH ONE OF US ON THIS
DYESS REPRESENT SO I APPRECIATE
YOU CLARIFYING THAT AND I WAS
JUST CURIOUS IF THAT NUMBER WAS
INCLUDED IN THIS. PARTICULAR
DEBT NUMBER SO THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
YOUR RESPONSES. YOU MEAN WITH
REGARDS TO. WITHIN THE NEXT
ISSUE. YEAH YES. OKAY. SENATORS
ANYMORE QUESTIONS ON THIS ISSUE
. THIS IS A ADDRESSING YOU AYE
DEBT FINANCE- SEE NOW WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE INTO FIVE ISSUE
SIX ADDRESSING AND PREVENTING
FRAUD- MAYBE SOME OF THE LAST
QUESTIONS COULD BE ADDRESSED AS
WELL IN THE COMMENTS BELOW BY
THE L. A. OWENS AND FINANCED-
OF- I THINK WE'RE GONNA. HAVE A
SHORT SUMMARY OF THE PROPOSALS
OUTLINED IN THE AGENDA SOME
LOOKING TO ADD TO MAKE A
PRESENTATION. YEAH THANK YOU
AGAIN GOOD MORNING I'M I'M SURE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KALHORO
CHIEF OF THE FISCAL PROGRAMS
DIVISION FOR THE DEPARTMENT. I
APPRECIATE YOU INVITING ME HERE
TODAY ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUES
TO TALK ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT'S
BUDGET REQUEST. SIX PROPOSALS
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AROUND ADDRESSING AND
PREVENTING FRAUD AND IMPROVING
OVERALL OPERATIONS INCLUDED
TOTAL ABOUT A HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR MILLION IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN NINE
IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND
SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION IN IN
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. ON THE
FIRST PROPOSAL WHICH IS VENDOR
SERVICES REQUEST NINETY SIX
POINT THREE MILLION- AND FORTY
FIVE POINT ONE MILLION IN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE TO PROVIDE
CONTINUED FUNDING. FOR VENDOR
SERVICES CONTRACTS ENTERED INTO
DURING THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THESE WERE TO REDUCE
FRAUD TO MANAGE THE WORKLOAD
BACKLOG IMPROVE THE CLAIM
EXPERIENCE FOR CALIFORNIANS
FILING FOR BENEFIT PAYMENTS.
MANY OF THESE PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES WERE PROCURED TO
ADDRESS RECOMMENDATIONS BY THE
EDT STRIKE TEAM. AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR. THE
CONTRACT PROVIDE MISSION
CRITICAL SERVICES SUCH AS FRAUD
PREVENTION DETECTION. IDENTITY
MANAGEMENT SECURITY SERVICES
CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR THE
PANDEMIC PROGRAMS THE OVERALL
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE. PERILLO
MODERNIZATION LICENSE
MAINTENANCE FOR LEGISLATIVE
TRACKING WORK SHARE AND ASK EDT
AND DOCUMENT UPLOAD
FUNCTIONALITY. ADDITIONALLY
SEVERAL THE CONTRACTS WILL ALSO
PROVIDE CRITICAL FRAUD
MITIGATION TOOLS FOR THE
DISABILITY INSURANCE PROGRAM AS
WELL. THE SECOND PROPOSAL WHICH
IS THE INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
BRANCH RESOURCE ALIGNMENT
REQUEST TWENTY THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE- TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
AND TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. FOR
CONTINUED FUNDING OF THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY BRANCH IS
A HUNDRED TWENTY TO UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE WORKLOAD POSITIONS IN
ORDER TO MAINTAIN SUPPORT FOR
CURRENT AND FUTURE WORKLOAD. AS
YOU ARE AWARE ET EXPERIENCES
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN WORKLOAD
FOR BENEFIT PAYMENTS DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND AS A RESULT
BUSINESS PROCESS HOW TO CHANGE
QUICKLY AND IMMEDIATELY IF THE
DEPARTMENT. AND WE IMPLEMENTED
MANY TECHNOLOGIES AND SECURITY
MEASURES AS A RESULT OF THAT.
ANPING COSTS WERE ABLE TO BE
FUNDED BASED ON THE NATIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT RECEIVED DURING A
PANDEMIC. HOWEVER ASK FEDERAL
FUNDING STARTS TO DECREASE EDT
CAN NO LONGER SUSTAIN THE
CURRENT I. T. STAFFING LEVELS
THAT PROVIDE THIS CRITICAL
SUPPORT FOR THE U. I. PROGRAM.
WITHIN EDIE'S EXISTING BUDGET.
QUESTED FUNDS WILL SUPPORT AMONG
OTHER THINGS APPLIQUE
APPLICATION DEVELOPMENT AND
SUPPORT FOR VARIOUS YOUR
APPLICATIONS INTERFACES AND
ENVIRONMENTS. TESTING SERVICES
FOR NEW SYSTEMS AND SUBSYSTEMS
SUPPORT FOR THE U. I. VIRTUAL
CONTACT CENTER AND THE
INTERACTIVE VOICE RESPONSE
SYSTEM. DATABASE SERVER
ADMINISTRATION AND DATA
PROCESSING AND ANALYTICS. THE
THIRD PROPOSAL WHICH IS THE
CYBER SECURITY RESILIENCE
INSTRUMENTATION REQUEST TEN
POINT TWO MILLION AND TWENTY
NINE POSITIONS IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND SIX POINT ONE
MILLION AND TWENTY NINE
POSITIONS IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR AND TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. IN ORDER TO ASSIST WITH
FRAUD MITIGATION AND TO IMPROVE
CYBERSECURITY AND SUSPICIOUS OF
THAT MONITORING RESPONSE
RESILIENCY THE DEPARTMENT. THIS
PROPOSAL WILL FIND A CYBER
SECURITY DIVISION AUGMENTING
STAFF FOCUSED ON CYBERSECURITY
SUPPORTING FRAUD RELATED
TECHNOLOGIES RISK MANAGEMENT AND
IMPLEMENTING ADDITIONAL SECURITY
INTERNAL CONTROLS AND TOOLS.
THESE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WILL
ALLOW THE EASY TO ADDRESS ISSUES
AND FINDINGS STEMMING FROM THE
INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICE THE
UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR THE CALIFORNIA
CYBERSECURITY INTEGRATION CENTER
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY. FOR PROPOSAL WHICH
IS THE U. I. COMMAND CENTER
IMPLEMENTATION REQUEST ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR AND TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. IN SUPPORT OF TEN
POSITIONS THAT OPERATE THE U. I.
COMMAND CENTER DIVISION. YOU AYE
COMMAND CENTERS PRIMARY
FUNCTIONS ARE FORECASTING FUTURE
U. I. WORKLOAD VOLUMES QUALITY
ASSURANCE MANAGEMENT ENHANCING
THE OVERALL CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE
AND ENSURING ADEQUATE STAFFING
LEVELS WITHIN THE U. I. BRANCH.
THIS PROPOSAL DOES DIRECTLY
RELATE TO STRIKE TEAM IN
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
RECOMMENDATIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
IMPROVING WORKLOAD MANAGEMENT BY
FORECASTING WORKLOAD VOLUMES AND
IDENTIFYING TRENDS IMPROVING
PERFORMANCE OF THE CONTACT
CENTER AND IMPLEMENTING LONG
TERM SUSTAINABLE SOLUTIONS. THE
THREE AREAS ADDRESSED BY THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDE VIRTUAL CONTACT
CENTER OPERATIONS WORKFORCE
OPERATIONS AND WORKLOAD ANALYSIS
AND FORECASTING. THE FIFTH
PROPOSAL WHICH IS- TIED TO A
LEGISLATIVE BILL ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE TEN FRAUDULENT CLAIMS FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION
BENEFITS INMATES. REQUESTS TWO
POINT TWO MILLION EDT CONTINUED
FUND IN. TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
NINE HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND AND TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR AND 700-220-0018 TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE. TO ADMINISTER
THE PROVISIONS OF AB ONE TEN
THAT WAS CHAPTER IN OCTOBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AB ONE TEN
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION'S
TO WRITE THE NAMES OF KNOWN
ALIASES BIRTHDATES SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS AND THE BOOKING
DATE AND ARE EXPECTED RELEASED
DATE IF KNOWN. OF CURRENT
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS TO THE
EDT FOR PURPOSES OF PREVENTING
PAYMENT ON FRAUDULENT YOU WHITE
PLAINS. AB ONE TEN REQUIRES EDT
TO COMPLETE ANY NECESSARY SYSTEM
PROGRAMMING OR AUTOMATION A
MONITORED THE IN MAY DATA AND
PREVENT PAYMENTS ON FRAGILE YOU
AYE CLAIMS. ON OR BEFORE
SEPTEMBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT
THE DEPARTMENT RT LEVERAGES CDCR
DATA TO IDENTIFY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ATTEMPTING TO FILE
OR CERTIFY FOR YOU I BENEFITS.
HOWEVER THE CURRENT PROCESS IS
AB ONE THAT REQUIRES QUITE A BIT
A MANUAL INTERVENTION BY EDIE
STAFF WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB TEN
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD ESTABLISH
AN AUTOMATED SYSTEM TO IDENTIFY
ANY INDIVIDUALS INCARCERATED
STATUS. TO PREVENT DETER FRAUD.
AND THEN LASTLY SIX PROPOSAL
WHICH IS ALSO TIED TO
LEGISLATIVE BILL ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE NINETY SEVEN. UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFITS
DISQUALIFICATION NOTICE REQUEST
TWO HUNDRED FORTY ONE THOUSAND
HE CONTENDED FUND IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE TO ADMINISTER THE
PROVISIONS. OF AB THREE NINETY
SEVEN WHICH WAS ALSO CHAPTER
BACK IN OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. I'M EXISTING LAW INDICATES
THAT AN INDIVIDUAL MAY BE
DISQUALIFIED FOR RECEIVING YOUR%
BENEFITS IF THEY ARE FOUND TO
HAVE KNOWINGLY PROVIDED FALSE
INFORMATION. OR WITHHELD
INFORMATION PURSUIT OF THOSE
BENEFITS. PRIOR TO
DISQUALIFICATION AB THREE NINETY
SEVEN REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT TO
PROVIDE NOTICE AND ALLOW
CLAIMING TO DISPUTE THE
POTENTIAL DISQUALIFICATION. THE
CLAIMANT HAS THREE TO TEN DAYS
TO RESPOND AND ET HAS UNTIL
SEPTEMBER FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO TO MAKE THE NECESSARY FORM
AND SYSTEM CHANGES. THANK YOU
FOR THE CONSIDERATION OF THESE
REQUESTED MYSELF MY COLLEAGUES
ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WE HAVE THE L. A.
O.'S COMMENTS PLEASE. THANK YOU
JUDGE ALL OF THE L. A. AGAIN- WE
HAVE COMMENTS. IN REGARD TO THE
FIRST PROPOSAL AND EVEN MORE
SPECIFICALLY. TO THE FIVE VENDOR
CONTRACTS THAT ARE RELATED TO
EATING IS ANTI FRAUD EFFORTS I'M
REALLY SUPPORT- TWO WEEKS AGO ON
THIS TOPIC BUT TO BE ABLE TO
OBVIOUSLY TO TOLD YOU AND STAFF-
IN SHORT. WE RECOMMEND FOR THESE
FIVE CONTRACTS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ONLY APPROVED ONE OF
THE CONTRACTS. WOULD BE TO
CONTRACT TO PREVENT BOT ATTACKS
THAT COULD DISRUPT OR OR SHUT
DOWN ENTIRELY EDIE'S WEBSITE-
AND WE RECOMMEND WITHHOLDING
ACTION. FOR REJECTING THE OTHER
ANTI FRAUD CONTRACTS AND THIS IS
FOR THREE MAIN REASONS THAT WE
MAKE HIS RECOMMENDATIONS- FIRST
IN THE REPORT WE POINT OUT- AS
MR AFOREMENTIONED- JUST MOMENTS
AGO THAT THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF FRAUD THAT OCCURRED-
IN THE U. I. PROGRAM DURING
THAT. THE PANDEMIC TARGETED
TEMPORARY FEDERAL BENEFITS FOR
SELF EMPLOYED WORKERS THAT WERE
FEDERALLY FUNDED AND SUBJECT TO
DIFFERENT- ELIGIBILITY RULES
THEN THE STATES YOU AYE PROGRAM.
AND THIS PROGRAM- ENDED IN THE
FALL OF LAST YEAR SO THE ONGOING
FRAUD RISK- THAT WAS SO HEAVILY
CONCENTRATED AND THIS FEDERAL
PROGRAM HAS NOW ENDED UP MAKING
THAT THE NEED FOR STATE ANTI
FRAUD EFFORTS GOING FORWARD.
MUCH LESS CRITICAL SECONDLY-
TURNING TO THE STATE YOU LIVE
FRAUD THAT OCCURRED DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND CENTER GROVE I
THINK THIS GOES BACK TO TERM THE
QUESTION YOU HAD DURING THE LAST
ITEM ON THE MINISTRATION HAS
NOTED TAT ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS. IN STATE YOU LIVE
BENEFITS ARE SUSPECTED AS AS
HAVING BEEN FRAUDULENT AND SO
THIS IS FOR THE REGULAR STATE
YOU AYE PROGRAM NOT THE FEDERAL
PROGRAM- BUT FOR A FEW REASONS
WEEK WE THINK THOSE THAT LEVEL
OF SUSPECTED. FRAUDULENT CLAIMS
MIGHT BE- OVERSTATED SOMEWHAT
AND THAT IN ALL LIKELIHOOD THAT
THE AMOUNT OF FRAUDULENT
ACTIVITY IN THE STATE'S REGULAR
PROGRAM IS MUCH. LOWER THAN THAT
POTENTIALLY A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR HOURS OR SO- THIS IS THE
STATE. YOU AYE PROGRAM SEVERAL
BILL IN STATE. THAT PREVENT OR
WILL. ARM BANDS OF FROM BUT
FEDERAL PROGRAM- DOES NOT HAVE.
AN WOMEN HIS RECOMMENDATION
BECAUSE MOST FOR WITH THESE ANTI
FRAUD CONTRACTS. RUNS COUNTER TO
THE STRIKE TEAMS OWN
RECOMMENDATIONS AND SPECIFICALLY
A RECOMMENDATION THAT WE POINT
TO IS THAT THE ADMINISTRATION.
MUST SORT OF MOVING AWAY FROM A-
EIGHT. EIGHT INSTITUTIONAL FOCUS
ON FRAUD ELIMINATION AND MUST
REVIEW AND ASSESS THE
EFFECTIVENESS. BUT ALSO THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF FOR
LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS OF ITS ANTI
FRAUD EFFORTS- WE UNDERSTAND THE
DEPARTMENT HAS LEARNED LESSONS.
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF THE
PANDEMIC- BUT GIVEN THAT THE
RISK IS NOW SUBSIDING- AND GIVEN
THE DEPARTMENT'S SORT OF.
HISTORY WITH WITH A FOCUS ON
FRIDAY ELIMINATION POTENTIALLY
AFTER THE- TO THE DATA APPROACH
ACTS OR TIME PAIN. WE ENCOURAGE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE THESE OP
RECOMMENDED PROJECTIONS AND PENN
. AND FINALLY- THE ONE ITEM I DO
WANT TO SORT OF HIGHLIGHT HERE
IS THAT THE CONTRACT WITH WHICH
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
WITHHOLD ACTION ON AND IT IS A
CONTRACT WITH A COMPANY CALLED
ID MEAN FOR IDENTITY
VERIFICATION. UNDERSTAND HIGHER
ID NEED TO PERFORM ONE TO ONE
FACIAL RECOGNITION MATCHES BOB
THIS WAS IN THE LATE SUMMER OF
TWENTY TWENTY AND IS IN ESSENCE
YOU TAKE A SHORT VIDEO ON YOUR
WEBCAM AND COME. A COMPUTER
COMPARES IT TO THE DRIVER'S
LICENSE OR PASSPORT THAT YOU
UPLOAD TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
THE SAME PERSON SO YOU ARE WHO
YOU SAY YOU ARE- WE THINK. THAT
THIS WRITING RECOMMENDATION THAT
HE BE DOCUMENTED IN IN THE LATE
SUMMER TWENTY TWENTY WAS
WARRANTED AT THE TIME GIVEN THE
CRISIS WITH WITH THE BACKLOG AND
WITH FRAUDULENT PAYMENTS BUT NOW
THAT THAT PERIOD HAS PASSED ON
THE STATE MAY WANT TO RECONSIDER
ITS USE OF FACIAL RECOGNITION
SOFTWARE. ARE PROVIDED BY THIRD
PARTY CONTRACTOR I'M GOING
FORWARD IN THE STATE'S PROGRAM
AND THIS A RECOMMENDATION TO
WITHHOLD ACTION ON IT ME
CONTRACTED COMES IT'S DIFFICULT
THE FOLLOWING- SOME RECENT
SCRUTINY THAT THE COMPANY HAS
COME UNDER FOR POTENTIALLY.
MISLEADING CLIENTS- THE- THEY
COME. HAS HAD NOTED NOT ONLY WAS
IT PERFORM THESE ONE TWO ONE
MATCH AS THE STATE UNDERSTOOD
IT'S CONTRACT TO BE FOR IT WAS
ALSO PERFORMING. WHAT'S KNOWN AS
A ONE TIME MANY MATCH AND SO IN
ESSENCE THE SHORT WEBCAM VIDEO
THAT THAT IS TAKEN- IS NOT ONLY
COMPARED MY DRIVER'S LICENSE IN
THIS EXAMPLE BUT- IS COMPARED TO
A DATA BANK OUT OF. OF MILLIONS
OF OTHER PHOTOS THAT I DO ME-
HOLDS HOUR PRIVACY EXPERTS AND-
AND OTHERS HAVE EXPRESSED
CONCERN THAT THERE ARE.
POTENTIAL FOR MISUSE- THERE'S A
POTENTIAL FOR A SUBSTANTIAL. OF
SYSTEMIC RACISM AND OTHER KEY
ISSUES OF EQUITY- TYING TO THE
NOTION OF USING ONE TO MANY- OF
FACIAL RECOGNITION STEPS AND FOR
THIS REASON THIS IS ALL SORT OF
HAPPENING IN REAL TIME THIS IS.
A RECENT DEVELOPMENT WE
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
HOLD ACTION. AND CAREFULLY
CONSIDER THE USE OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY. FOR THE STATE YOU
LIVE PROGRAM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- THE FINANCE LIKE
TO WOOD FINDS LIKE TO COMMENT.
BETTER TOP AND THE BOTTOM THE
FINANCE NO INITIAL COMMENTS I
HAVE AN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY I'D LIKE TO HEAR BACK FROM
THE- EDT- UM RESPONSE TO THE L.
ALES RECOMMENDATIONS. SHORT NAME
THE VARIOUS WITH EDT I'LL TAKE
THE OVER ARCHING- THE RESPONSE
FIRST SO WE FIRST OF ALL I JUST
WANNA SAY THAT WE APPRECIATE THE
L. A. O.'S RECOMMENDATIONS IN
THE KNOWLEDGE MEANS THAT YOU
KNOW THE STRIDES THAT WE'VE MADE
AND YOU KNOW THAT WE CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD- AS THEY HAVE AN
IMPORTANT ROLE OF COURSE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. NOW THAT BEING SAID
SOME OF THE REFERENCES- THAT
ALEJO MAKES OUR YOU KNOW NEARLY
A YEAR AND A HALF OLD DURING THE
HEIGHT OF THE PANDEMIC- AS
EVIDENCE OF A FRAUD CULTURE AT
EDT I YOU KNOW I WILL SAY THAT
WE HAVE VERY SMART EMPLOYEES AT
EDT AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT WE
DO LOOK AT DATA FOR ANY DECISION
THAT'S MADE IT EASY DAY. YOU
KNOW I DON'T WANT TO SAY THAT WE
DON'T ALSO WAY COMMONSENSE BUT
WE DEFINITELY LOOK AT THAT AT
THE DATA- WHEN I RE READ THE
STRAIGHT TEAM RECOMMENDATIONS
WHICH WAS ACTUALLY RELEASED
BEFORE I CAME TO EDT ABOUT FOUR
DAYS BEFORE I CAME TO DANCE A
TIME OF TWENTY TWENTY- YOU KNOW
AND THE L. A. POINTS OUT THAT WE
ARE RUNNING COUNTER TO THE
STRIKE TEAM- I THINK THAT THE
STRIKE TEAM WAS TALKING ABOUT.
PEOPLE'S YOU KNOW THE FRAUD
CULTURE IS TALKING ABOUT THE
WORKERS THAT EDT WHEN THERE WAS
A MANUAL PROCESS- I CAN IMAGINE
THAT THAT'S AT LEAST ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY THE STRIKE TEAM
SUGGESTED THAT WE USE A VENDOR
THAT MEETS YOU KNOW FEDERAL.
IDENTITY STANDARD ID ME OF
COURSE- BECAUSE IT TAKES A
MANUAL PROCESS OUT OF- OUT OF IT
AND IT ELIMINATES ANY FRAUD
CULTURE- I WOULD I WOULD THINK-
AND I JUST JUST A REMINDER THAT
YOU KNOW THESE TOOLS WORK HE
STRIKE TEAM AN AUDITOR
RECOMMENDATIONS. AT NIGHT I
UNDERSTAND THE NARRATIVE AROUND
THAT WE ARE PRIORITIZING FRAUD
ELIMINATION AT THE EXPENSE
EXPENSE OF PROMPT AND STRAIGHT
FORWARD PAYMENTS BUT I WILL SAY
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE I YOU KNOW
I THINK IT'S THE OPPOSITE I MEAN
THE LAST THE LAST FRAUD AND
IDENTITY THEFT THAT. WE DEAL
WITH ON THE FRONT END. I THINK
THE QUICKER WE CAN GET PEOPLE TO
AND WE- THAT YOU KNOW. THE IN
AND BEYOND AND I'M- YOU KNOW
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC WE HAVE HAD TO RETHINK.
LOTS OF POLICIES THAT NO LONGER
SERVE THE NEEDY OR CLAIMANTS AND
OUR STAFF. ARE AMAZING I'VE SEEN
YOU I STAFF. YOUKNOW WORK WITH
EXTENSION OF ONE OF THE VENDORS
IN OUR B. C. P. TO HELP US. SIFT
THROUGH THE DATA AND FIGURE OUT
YOU KNOW WHERE WE WENT RIGHT
WHERE WE WENT WRONG. AND BASED
ON THAT WE CHANGE OUR FIVE ARE
FIVE DOCTORS BOTH INTERNALLY AND
WITH THOMSON REUTERS WHICH IS
ANOTHER VENDOR- IN OUR BCP. YOU
KNOW IN MOVING FORWARD WE'RE
GOING TO BE USING THE NEW FRAUD
UNIT. THAT WAS CREATED
INTERNALLY AT EDT- THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATION- TO CONTINUALLY
REVIEW THE FRAUD FILTERS AND
ADJUST AS NECESSARY. AND USING
THIS TEAM YOU KNOW WHAT TOM SOME
WRITERS WILL BE ABLE TO PAY THAT
OUR FILTERS- YOU KNOW.
IMMEDIATELY AND ONE THING I JUST
WANT TO REITERATE AND I'LL WRAP
UP MY COMMENTS- IS YOU KNOW I
SAID THIS LAST WEEK AT THE
HEARINGI THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO SAY AGAIN. I THINK THAT WE
ARE UNDER ESTIMATING WHAT
HAPPENED THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
AND THE IDENTITY STEPS THAT WENT
ON AND THAT CONTINUES QUITE
FRANKLY TO GO ON. YOU KNOW
ALMOST EVERYONE THAT I KNOW WHY
THERE HAD SOME SORT OF SCAM SENT
TO THEM. EDT RELATED OR NOT. YOU
KNOW OR KNEW SOMEONE THAT DID
AND I THINK THAT SAYING THAT THE
FRAUD IS OVER. YOU KNOW NOW THAT
WE NO LONGER HAVE HULA- IS
DANGEROUS- YOU KNOW AND TO THE
ALLEY OF THIS POINT YOU KNOW.
THAT I'M DATA DRIVEN DECISIONS
YOU KNOW WE DIDN'T HAVE TIME TO
DO THIS BEFORE THE HEARINGS BUT-
YEAH WE'D BE HAPPY TO MEET WITH
THE L. A. O. TO REVIEW THE DATA
THAT THEY USED TO COME UP WITH
THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS. ON
BECAUSE WE CAN COMPARE IT TO THE
DATA THAT WE HAVE BECAUSE AS I
THINK YOU'RE ALL AWARE. YOU KNOW
WE'VE SEEN OF THE TICKET- TO.
DISABILITY INSURANCE PROGRAM.
AND SOME OF THE CONTRACTS THAT
ARE BEFORE YOU TODAY IN THE B.
P. CENTER I DO MEAN FOR A- ARE
PREFERRED. US WITH THAT DATA.
OPERA THE AUDITORS RECOMMENDED.
OKAY I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS ID ME
SITUATION AS WELL AS YOU'D LIKE
YES PLEASE SURE SO CURRENTLY ARE
MEETING WITH SOME OTHER STATES
TO SEE WHAT THEY ARE DOING BASED
ON THE FRONT THAT THEY HAVE SEEN
WORKING WITH ID NEED. AND JUST
LAST WEEK- AS AS- CHAD MENTIONED
YOU KNOW- WE ARE WORKING WITH ID
NEED TO EXPLORE OTHER WAYS TO
VERIFY IDENTITY WITHOUT USING
FACIAL RECOGNITION AND ONE OF
THE WAYS IS LAST WEEK THE- I. D.
NY. ENTERED INTO A CONTRACT WITH
THE IRS THAT ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS
EITHER UPLOAD A SELFIE AND
DELETE IT OR TO GO THROUGH A
TRUSTED REFEREE WHICH IS A LIVE
PERSON- WE'RE LOOKING INTO THAT
STILL AGAIN TALKING TO OTHER
STATES TO FIGURE OUT- WHAT THEY
ARE DOING TALKING TO OUR VENDORS
SUCH TO SEE THEM. SORT OF FRAUD
TO SEE IF THEY WOULD ADDRESS THE
TYPE OF FRAUD THAT THEY ARE
SEEING BUT- ABSENT ANY- YOU KNOW
ANYTHING AGREED JUST- WE SEE NO
REASON WHY WE CAN'T FOLLOW WHAT. THE IRS IS DOING. BOB IS THERE
ARE OBVIOUSLY THERE'S CERTAIN
ELEMENTS AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND
ALL THIS TECHNOLOGY. BUT THERE
ARE CERTAIN ELEMENTS THAT ID ME
ID ME- OF THAT ADD USES AND IT'S
A VERIFICATION PROCESS. SO ARE
WE WHAT ARE WE SACRIFICING. IF
WE DON'T USE ID ME- IN YOU KNOW
SOME MIGHT CONSIDER IT A
DOWNGRADE TO- TO DO TONIGHT DO
EVERYTHING- THEN THERE'S FACIAL
RECOGNITION SO. WHERE IS THE
RIGHT USAGE OF THESE ELEMENTS.
THAT THAT THAT IS A GOOD
QUESTION AND ONE AND IN WHICH
YOU KNOW AGAIN WE ARE ASKING AND
TALKING TO OTHER STATES AS WELL
AS OUR- YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
VENDORS THAT WE HAVE- EXCLUDING
ID ME OTHER VENDORS AS WELL. I
THINK THAT- AND I CAN ARE CHAU
IT IS MUCH MORE TECHNICALLY
SAVVY THAN I AM ON THAT BUT-
GETTING RID OF THE SELFIE OR THE
TRUSTED RIGHT FOR ME REFEREE AS
I UNDERSTAND IT- WOULD JUST BE
BASICALLY STRAIGHT UP IDENTITY
THEFT SO YOU KNOW YOU CAN GO TO
THE DARK WEB IN BY MY
INFORMATION FOR SIX DOLLARS AND
SIXTY TWO CENTS AS I'M SURE I AM
NOT THE ONLY ONE WHOSE
INFORMATION IS. IN ON THE DARK
WEB PAGE- AND ONCE YOU HAVE THAT
INFORMATION- YOU KNOW YOU CAN
PRETTY MUCH DO ANYTHING YOU WANT
WITH THAT- YOU KNOW AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THAT WE HAVE
SEEN IS YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE THE
FBI THAT THE SCAMMERS THEIR DATE
THEY HAVE HAD ALL THE U. Y.
SYSTEMS ACROSS THE COUNTRY RIGHT
AND THEY'RE VERY SOPHISTICATED
WE DON'T KNOW HOW OR WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO. NEXT ANDI
DID MENTION THIS ALSO NEXT WEEK
THAT THE LAST WEEK I'M SORRY
THAT THE F. B. I. PUT OUT A
MEDIA ADVISORY JUST LAST WEEK AS
I MENTIONED SO AFTER C ENDED SO
TO THE L. A. O.'S POINT ABOUT
THE PRIDE OF BEING LESS- NOW I
YOU KNOW THIS IS AFTER PRO ENDED
AT ONE STAGE ABOUT SCAMMERS
EXPLOITING JOB BOARDS. AND
SOCIAL MEDIA SITES TO
IMPERSONATE LEGIT BUSINESSES AND
CLAIMANTS IN ORDER TO GET YOU Y.
SO AT EIGHT AYE IT WOULD BE AN
UNDERSTATEMENT TO SAY THAT YOU
WOULD BE AMAZED TO SEE WHAT WE
ARE PROVIDING AS FAR AS WHAT'S
ON THE DARK WEB IN THE CHATTER
IN THE ATTEMPT- I'M GOVERNMENT
BENEFITS FRAUD RIGHT NOW- BUT
I'D I'D PROBABLY TALK TOO MUCH
BUT I CAN LET THE CIO- MAYBE
DISCUSS SOME OF THE NUANCES OF
THE TECHNOLOGY- IF THAT DOESN'T
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION- YES IF YOU
HAVE. IF YOU HAVE SOME.
UNANSWERED THAT COULD CONTRIBUTE
TO THAT. YES GOOD MORNING- READ
A GUY ET SO WHAT YOU NEED IT WAS
AS IF WE DOWNGRADE TO ELIMINATE
THE FACIAL RECOGNITION SERVICE
IS OUR ABILITY TO PROVE THE
IDENTITY WE USED ID ME AS AN
IDENTITY PROOFING TOOL
POTENTIALLY STOLEN IDENTITIES
USE BY ORGAN ORGANIZED CRIMINALS
WILL NOT BE DISCOVERED DURING
THE SCREENING PROCESS BECAUSE I
NEED ME WILL ONLY BE CHECKING IF
THE PERSON SPACE SUBMITTING THE
IDENTIFICATION. PROOF MATCHES
THE GOVERNMENT IDENTIFICATION
PAPERWORK NOT IF THIS PERSON HAS
TRIED MANY TIMES TO BEFORE USING
OTHER IDENTITIES WHAT HAD
HAPPENED I THAT I DIDN'T EACH UP
FOUND IS THAT ONE PERSON COULD
BE USING THE SAME PHOTO AND THE
SAME DRIVERS LICENSE WITH
DIFFERENT NAMES AND THAT'S HOW
THEY WERE ABLE TO CATCH THAT YOU
KNOW THIS ONE PERSON WHAT IT
SUBMITTED FIVE TEN OR MULTIPLE-
IDENTITIES DEBRA. FILE-
UNEMPLOYMENT. SO THE DAY THAT
HAVE BEEN. WITH WITH USING ID ME
- YOU ALL FEEL COMFORTABLE A TO
CONTINUE TO USE IT EXCITING
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE QUESTION
IS THAT THE PROBLEMS THAT ARE
CREATED BOM BOM BY ID ME YOU
FEEL THAT. THOSE ARE NOT- SO
SERIOUS THAT WE SHOULD CONTINUE
TO USE IT ME. SENATE OUR
IDENTITY VARIOUS- WITH IDEALLY I
WOULDN'T WITH EDT- I WOULD SAY
THAT WE TAKE THAT VERY
SERIOUSLY- WHICH IS WHY WE ARE
TALKING TO OTHER STATES AS WELL
AS THE ID YOU KNOW AS WELL AS
THE ID ME ABOUT PUTTING IN PLACE
BUT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
WHICH TAKES OUT THE FACIAL
RECOGNITION PIECE OF IT IT'S
ALSO MY UNDERSTANDING THAT- ID
NY HAS IMPLEMENTED- A PROCESS BY
WHICH WHEN YOU WHEN YOU DO
UPLOAD A SELFIE BECAUSE THAT IS
PROBABLY THE ROUTE THAT MOST
PEOPLE WOULD GO BECAUSE IT'S
QUICKER TO UPLOAD A SELFIE AND
THEN YOU CAN DELETE IT AFTER.
YOU KNOW THAT IF THERE IS AN
ISSUE WITH THAT SELFIE THAT
LET'S SAY YOU MATCH WITH
SOMEONE- FROM ANOTHER STATE THAT
A LIVE PERSON WILL COME ON TO
THAT WILL APPEAR ON YOUR SCREEN-
AND COME ON TO THE SCREEN TO
WALK YOU THROUGH THE PROCESS SO
THERE IS NO UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT THAT IS PART
OF- WHAT THEY ARE DOING I
BELIEVE FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND AGAIN. THAT IS
THE DIRECTION THAT WE ARE HEADED
IN WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE MAKING THE RIGHT
DECISION YOU DON'T BASED ON ALSO
WHAT OTHER STATES ARE DOING BUT
YOU KNOW AS I MENTIONED LAST
WEEK WE DON'T NECESSARILY SEE AN
ISSUE WITH US FOLLOWING- THE
PROCESS THAT THE IRS IS- THAT IS
NOW- IMPLEMENTED WITH ID ME.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY DIRECT- ANY
OTHER THING MEMBERS SENATOR
NEWMAN. THANK YOU ENSURE. TIME
SHOW. I YEAH WE STARTED USING ID
ME TO SOLVE A PARTICULAR PROBLEM
IN THE PROBLEM RELATED THE
PANDEMIC IN THE AND THE
INABILITY DURING THE PANDEMIC'S
FROM PEOPLE TO PRESENT
THEMSELVES PERSONALLY RIGHT
PHYSICALLY. AND I GUESS MY
QUESTION REDUCED IS TO WHAT
EXTENT- LOOKING FORWARD TO IT
ARE WE PRESUPPOSING THAT ID ME
WILL HAVE A PROMINENT ROLE IN
MEDICINE AND SO AS COALBED
SUBSIDES- AS WE CAN RETURN TO
SOMETHING MORE LIKE NORMAL LIFE
WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE BALANCE
WHERE DOES IT ME FIT INTO OR OR
OR OTHER TOOLS LIKE IT. FIT INTO
SOMETHING LIKE A RETURN TO
NORMALCY WHICH ALLOWS PEOPLE
ACTUALLY PHYSICALLY VISIT EIGHTY
OFFICES. THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION- SENATOR AND YOU KNOW
ASK AS A SENATOR DRAWS SO
MENTION AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
HEARING THE WORLD IS NOT GOING
TO BE THE SAME. AGAIN I DON'T
THINK- BUT- THE PANDEMIC HAS
REALLY OPENED UP OUR EYES I
THINK TO SOME OF THE-
TRANSGRESSIONS AND MISGIVINGS OF
THE WORLD BUT- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT. WE ARE WE WILL HAVE AN
IDENTITY VERIFICATION SYSTEM- WE
ARE AND YOU WILL SEE IN THE MAY
REVISION. OUR PROPOSAL- FOR A
NEW I. T. PROJECT- A NEW IT
SYSTEMS PROBABLY LITTLE BIT MORE
THAN A PROJECT- THE BENEFITS
MODERNIZATION SYSTEM. AND IT
WILL BE IDENTITY- VERIFICATION
WITHIN THAT- THE BSM PROJECTS SO
WE ANTICIPATE USING IDENTITY
VERIFICATION WHETHER OR NOT. YOU
KNOW HOW THAT'S GONNA WORK I
MEAN IS IT IS YOU KNOW PROBABLY
A COUPLE OF YEARS A WAY FOR US
TO FIGURE THAT OUT BUT THE NEW
SYSTEM. BUT WE DO ANTICIPATE
IDENTITY VERIFICATION SYSTEM
YES. ANSWERS TO FOLLOW UP
SEVENTY TWO IS THE DIAZ
ANTICIPATED MOBILE MOST ARE ALL
OF YOUR DENTURE VERIFICATION
WILL TAKE PLACE. ONLINE OR
THROUGH AUTOMATED PROCESSES
ISSUE OR- DO WILL WE GO BACK TO
SOMETHING. HYBRID OR SOMETHING
LIKE LIKE I HAVE EVERY DAY EVERY
TIME I GO TO THE AIRPORT WE HAVE
TO TAKE MY MASK OFF AS I GO
THROUGH NORTH THX. WE ARE
EXPLORING WAYS TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT IN OUR OFFICES AYE I THINK
ACTUALLY IT TEAM IS MEETING.
TOMORROW MORNING TO TALK ABOUT
THAT SO IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
ARE EXPLORING WE- AS I
UNDERSTAND IT. AND I ONLY CAME
TO EDT DURING THE PANDEMIC BUT-
AS I UNDERSTAND IT I'M I'M I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE WERE DOING
THAT IN THE OFFICES BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
EXPLORE FOR PEOPLE THAT MAY NOT
HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY. THAT BRINGS
YOU DON'T WANT TO CALL AND YOU
KNOW AND THERE MAY BE ARGUMETS
FOR DELIBERATELY- INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF TRANSACTIONS ARE DONE
IN PERSON WOULD SAY THAT. TO THE
EXTENT YOU DO. THAT YOU REDUCE
THE LIKELY IT OF ALL FRONT. AB
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR ANY
OTHER COMMENTS CENTER GROVE I'M
THINKING CHAIR I ASK ONLY TO IN
WE GOT INTO THIS IDEA WHICH I
WASN'T AWARE OF- SO THE TWO
QUESTIONS THAT I'D IKE TO START
WITH IS THAT- MY UNDERSTANDING
IN THE EDM INSTRUCTED TO EDT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE IS
ROUGHLY- BASED ON THE AGENDA AT
SEVEN THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
NINETY TWO BACK LIKELY CASES. OF
PAYMENTS- THAT ARE ROUGHLY
SIXTEEN WEEKS OUTPERFORMANCE-
NOT PAID AT OR DELAYED I THINK
THAT NUMBER IS DOWN TO AROUND
SIXTY EIGHT HUNDRED NOW AS OF
TODAY IS THAT STILL AN ADEQUATE
NUMBER OF DELAYED PAYMENTS FOR
PEOPLE THAT HAVE APPLIED FOR
BENEFITS THAT ARE OUT- FOUR
MINUTES. SIXTEEN WEEKS. I
BELIEVE SO WHAT I'M GOING TO
DEFER TO ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES TO
RESPOND SPECIFICALLY TO THAT
QUESTION. HI GOOD MORNING THIS
YEAR WITH EDM UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE FRENCH DEPUTY
DIRECTOR- I DO BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS- THERE'S A CUT. TWO
DIFFERENT KIND OF COHORTS OR OR
AVENUES OF DETERMINATION
WORKLOAD THAT WE HAVE GOING ON
WE HAVE OUR- OUR CURRENT EFFORT
THAT WE HAVE AS FAR AS
PROSPECTIVE DETERMINATIONS THAT
WE PRESUMED- AS OF JANUARY OF
LAST YEAR. AND THAT INCLUDES-
PRIORITIZING- THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
CONDITIONAL PAYMENTS I'M AND SO
THOSE ARE THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
WE HAVE PRIORITISED TO ENSURE
THAT THE- RECEIVE TIMELY
ADJUDICATION OR OR AS QUICK AS
AND AT THE EDUCATION AS WE CAN.
TO CONDUCT DETERMINATION
INTERVIEWS THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
WOULD PRIORITIZE THAT AE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR CONDITIONAL
PAYMENTS THESE ARE TYPICALLY
ELIGIBILITY ISSUES WHERE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE EITHER I'M
SEPARATED WHERE THEY INDICATED
THAT THEY VOLUNTARILY QUIT OR
THEY WERE TERMINATED FROM THEIR
EMPLOYMENT. OR INDIVIDUALS THAT
WE'VE IDENTIFIED THAT DID NOT
REPORT WAGE INFORMATION DURING
THE TIME IN WHICH THE PANDEMIC
THEY HAVE THE COURAGE AND THEY
WERE CERTIFYING AND DID NOT
PROVIDE OR DISCLOSE THAT WAGE
INFORMATION WHEN THEY WERE
CERTIFYING. THEIR BI WEEKLY
CERTIFICATION THE WAITING TIME
FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT- ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR CONDITIONAL
PAYMENTS IT'S SEVEN TO SIXTEEN
WEEKS IT IS A RANGE BECAUSE WE
ARE PRIORITIZING THAT GROUP- AND
I BELIEVE THE ANSWER THE
QUESTION SPECIFIC TO. IT DEAD
THANK YOU MA'AM. I HAVE A DOCK
HERE THAT SAYS THAT- TOTAL
NUMBER OF- UNEMPLOYMENT OR SKEWS
ME THE ONES THAT WERE TO
IMPLEMENT DEVELOP APARTMENT. OF
EMPLOYEE. EMPLOYEES IS FIFTEEN
THOUSAND FOREIGN TWENTY ONE-
PROVIDING ALL THOSE POSITIONS
ARE FILLED AND IN THAT FIFTY I'M
SORRY IT'S REALLY SMALL FIFTY
NINE TWENTY CATEGORY WHICH IS.
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAMS
WHICH THESE BACKLOGS WOULD BE
ADDRESSED IN OUR CLAIMS TO BE
FILED AND- THERE'S FIVE THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE
EMPLOYEES- IN THAT. AREA IS THAT
TRUE. IS THE DOCUMENT I HAVE
TRUE. SENATOR NANCY VARIOUS WITH
EDT I I'M NOT SURE THAT WE COULD
ANSWER THAT SPECIFIC QUESTION
BUT- IF YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT YOU
KNOW THE VACANCY RATE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT IS THAT NO I MEDICINE
THANK YOU MYSTERIES FOR
DIRECTORS FOR DOING THAT- AND
RESPONDING I'M IT'S SO BASED ON
THE INFORMATION I HAVE AN
EMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM
FIVE THOUSAND SEVEN OR SIXTY
FIVE EMPLOYEES EXISTED IN THE
PROCESSING OF BENEFITS AND
CLAIMS. THAT SO IN THERE'S OTHER
EACH THAT'S ONLY THIRTY OR WORK
FORCE BUT IT'S IN THIS AREA BUT
THEY'RE STILL SIXTY EIGHT
HUNDRED CLAIMS THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN- PROCESSOR SEVEN THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED NINETY TWO BUT IT'S
THE INORMATION I HAVE IS A
COUPLE OF WEEKS OLD. IF AND ALL
THE BEST DEAL WITH THOSE PHONE
CALLS I DON'T KNOW ONE
LEGISLATOR THAT DOES NOT DEAL
WITH PHONE CALLS IN THEIR OFFICE
ABOUT PROCESS SENIOR WAITING OR
DELAYED UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. I
KNOW THAT YOU GUYS HAVE STEPPED
IT UP. A 1000% I KNOW THAT. WITH
WHAT YOU TOOK ON DURING THE
PANDEMIC WITH- FRIED
ADMINISTERING BENEFITS. GETTING
CASE WORK DONE. IT WAS
EXTRAORDINARY WHAT YOU HAVE
OVERCOME. AND SO I IT I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT. AND GIVING
US AN INDIVIDUAL IN OUR OFFICES
SO THAT WE COULD WORK DIRECTLY
WITH YOU TO SOLVE CLAIMS FOR
CONSTITUENTS WAS VERY HELPFUL AS
WELL. BUT I HAVEN'T MY CONCERN
IS THAT. I GUESS MY SOLUTION OR
I HAVE IS IF YOU TOOK THESEFIVE
THOUSAND SEVEN HER SIXTY FIVE
PEOPLE. THAT YOU HAVE A NEW SET
ASIDE ONE DAY JUST ONE DAY. YOU
COULD PROBABLY ELIMINATE THOSE
THAT ENTIRE BACKLOG OF CASES FOR
THAT AND FOR THOSE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE BEEN WAITING UP TO FOUR
MONTHS FOR THEIR BENEFITS OR
DETERMINE THEM INELIGIBLE. SO
THAT THEY DIDN'T GET BENEFITS
SOMEWHERE ON THE WAITING LIST
AND FRANKLY WE'RE CALLING OUR
OFFICE TO COMPLAIN ABOUT YOUR
DEPARTMENT. LATER NEEDS MEETING
VARIOUS WITH EDT- FIRST AND
FOREMOST I I'D I WANT TO AGAIN
THANK THE STAFF- IN ALL OF YOUR
OFFICES FOR THE- HELP. QUITE
FRANKLY THAT THEY HAVE GIVEN TO
EDT- THEY'VE HELPED YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AND WE WERE HAPPY
TO- YOU KNOW PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
IN YOUR OFFICES- THAT THAT IS
YOU KNOW WE WILL WE- ARE HAPPY
TO DO THAT TRUST ME BECAUSE- WE
WANT TO HELP YOU AS MUCH AS YOU
ARE HELPING US- AS FAR AS- I
THINK I UNDERSTAND. YOUR LINE OF
QUESTIONING- THE ISSUE WITH THE
FIVE THOUSAND SEVEN. HUNDRED ODD
STAFF THAT ARE IN YOU WHY IS
THERE NOT ALL AT THE SAME. LEVEL
OF- THE WORK THAT THEY CAN DO SO
THERE ARE THERE ARE DIFFERENT
CLASSIFICATIONS. AND CERTAIN
CLASSIFICATIONS CAN DO CERTAIN
WORK AND CERTAIN CLASSIFICATIONS
CAN'T- ALSO NOT ALL OF THE
ISSUES ARE- YOU AYE RELATED SOME
OF THEM ARE ACTUALLY I. T.
RELATED INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
RELATED- AND SO. I DO UNDERSTAND
WHERE YOU'RE GOING WITH THAT- I
DON'T THINK THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT- EVERY PERSON CAN
WORK ON. YOU KNOW ONE CASE AND
WE WOULD BE DONE WHAT DOES THAT
THAT BACKLOG AND IT IS A IT'S A-
CONTINUAL. YOU KNOW BACKLOG
THERE'S ALWAYS- SOME PEOPLE.
THAT ARE BEHIND ON TWENTY ONE
DAYS. YES I AM THAT AND I AREA.
THAT YOUR RESPONSE AND I
APPRECIATE YOU GIVING ME THAT I
HAD MY SECOND QUESTION THAT I
PLANNED ON ASKING TODAY IS- WITH
THE DISABILITY INSURANCE CLAIMS
THERE'S ROUGHLY- THERE'S FRAUD
GOING ON AND THERE'S AS WELL
IT'S NOT AS LARGE AS THE U. I.
FRAUD IT'S THEIR- BUT- THERE'RE
SOME LEGITIMATE DISABILITY
CLAIMS THAT HAVE BEEN FROZEN
AGAIN- YOU AYE CLAIMS ARE 1100%
FUNDED BY THE EMPLOYER
DISABILITY CLAIMS ARE ONE. ARE
OFFENDED BY THE EMPLOYEE. CAN
PROCESSES ARE WITH STANDARD
OPERATING PROCEDURE IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE DISABILITY.
CLAIMS AND CLAIMS FOR DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS ARE BEING PROCESSED
IN A TIMELY MANNER. SURE NAY I
NEED TO VARIOUS WITH EDT- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE REDIRECTED- STAFF-
FROM OTHER BRANCHES IN EDT MUCH
LIKE WE DID WITH YOU I. TO HELP
WITH THE- BACKLOG IN D. I. IT
ZERO POINT SENATOR- AND THANK
YOU FOR ACKNOWLEDGING- WE'VE
LEARNED OUR LESSONS AND- THE
FRAUD IS NOT NEARLY. AS LARGE AS
IT WAS IN THE U. I PROGRAM DRAW
THE PANDEMIC WE CAUGHT IT VERY
EARLY THANKS TO- YOU KNOW GOOD
STAFFING AND A PROCESS SEESTHAT
WE HAVE IN PLACE BUT WE HAVE RE
DIRECTED STAFF AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT- AND I THIS
WAS. REPORTED I BELIEVE LAST
WEEK ON- DONE BY WEEKLY
LEGISLATIVE CALL THAT THE NUMBER
OF CALLS ARE GOING DOWN THE
NUMBER OF- MEDICAL PROVIDERS AND
CLAIMANTS THAT- ARE GETTING
THROUGH ARE INCREASING- BUT- TO
YOUR POINT. MOST OF THIS WAS
FRAUD TO SO THERE IS A LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
NOT VERIFIED THEIR IDENTITY- AND
WE BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE THEY
ARE FRAUDULENT BASED ON
HISTORICAL. NUMBERS AND DATA
THAT WE'VE SEEN. IS THERE ANY
YOU KNOW HAVE TO ANSWER QUESTION
NOW BECAUSE I KNOW THE CHAIRS
AND A VERY- TIGHT TIME
CONSTRAINT BUT IS THERE A
DOCUMENT THAT YOU COULD PROVIDE
MY OFFICE THAT WOULD GIVE ME THE
PERCENTAGE OF APPLICANT FRAUD.
FOR APPLICATIONS THE PERCENTAGE
OF- FRAUDULENT CLAIMS THAT WERE
PAID I MEAN I JUST LIKE TO SEE
NUMBERS AND PERCENT IF YOU COULD
PROVIDE THAT TO ME OFFLINE I
WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE THAT- TO
MY OFFICE. AND THOSE ARE THE TWO
QUESTIONS THAT I WANTED TO ASK
AND MAKE SURE GO TO ANSWER TO
BUT NOW THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED
THIS ID MEETING. I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS IT WAS
DETERMINED EARLIER STATED
EARLIER THAT THEIR- EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
AND- ALL OF THAT WEEK- FIVE
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES- TO BE WELL
VERSED STAFF TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
CARE THE DIVERSE POPULATION THAT
WE HAVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND IS IT MADE
KNOWN- CLEARLY- TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS- THE ENGLISH IS NOT
THEIR PRIMARY LANGUAGE BUT IS IT
MADE KNOWN TO THOSE OTHER FIVE
LANGUAGES THAT THEY ARE BEING
IDENTIFIED BY FACIAL RECOGNITION
IN ORDER TO OBTAIN BENEFITS FROM
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. DID THEY CLEARLY
UNDERSTAND THAT AND IF SO WHAT'S
THE PROCESS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT- COULD YOU
ASK THAT AGAIN I'M- SO THERE'S
FIVE LANGUAGES THAT WE FOCUS ON
TO MAKE SURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE LANGUAGE IN DIVERSE
POPULATION. HAS THE ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE WITH STATE AGENCIES
SPECIFICALLY YOURS. IS IT MADE
CLEAR TO THESE INDIVIDUALS
SPECIFICALLY THOSE IN THE FIVE
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES. M. THAT
WHEN THEY UPLOAD THEIR SELFIE
THEY ARE THEY CLEARLY UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU ARE USING FACIAL
RECOGNITION TO IDENTIFY WHO THEY
ARE. YES YES THANK YOU NANCY
VARIOUS WITH EDS I DEEM ME ALSO-
OPERATE IN I BELIEVE SEVEN OR
EIGHT OTHER LANGUAGES POSSIBLY
EVEN MORE MADE THE CHAU MATE MAY
HAVE A OF MORE- NUMBER SH BUT
STILL YES THEY THEY CAN THEY-
CAN- VERIFY THEIR IDENTITY IN
OTHER LANGUAGES AND OF COURSE WE
ALSO HAVE- OTHER LANGUAGES
AVAILABLE FOR THE APPLICATION
PROCESS. THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S
NOT MY QUESTION I'M ASKING YOU
IF- SO LET'S PICK A LANGUAGE-
GIVE ME A LANGUAGE WHAT'S ONE OF
THE FIVE LANGUAGES SPANISH. SURE
OKAY SO DOES THIS THIS
INDIVIDUAL WHO- HAS LIMITED
ENGLISH OR ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE AND SPEAKS PRIMARILY
SPANISH DOES THAT INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS APPLYING FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS WHEN THEY FILL OUT THE
APPLICATION AND THEY UPLOAD
THEIR SELFIE BECAUSE THEY TAKE A
PICTURE THAT'S HOW YOU IDENTIFY
THEM IS THAT. THAT INDIVIDUAL.
DOES THAT INDIVIDUAL CLEARLY
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU ARE
IDENTIFYING THEM. THROUGH FACIAL
RECOGNITION OR DO THEY THINK
THEY'RE JUST UPLOADING A SELFIE
SO YOU COULD SAY OH THAT'S EASY
OR WHATEVER. DO THEY CLEARLY
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE USING
THAT PHOTO FOR FACIAL
RECOGNITION THE APPLICANT. AND
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION I'M NOT
SURE IF THE CIA CHAU KNOWS THE
ANSWER TO THAT- I I'M NOT SURE.
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN GOOD
MORNING IT'S JUST READ ABOUT THE
BEAT SO- ID ME HAS SEVEN
ADDITIONAL ACT LANGUAGES IN
ADDITION TO ENGLISH AND SPANISH-
LIKE ABOUT LOVE THAT TWO FORMS
OF CHINESE. AND ALL THOSE AND
THEIR INSTRUCTION MATCHES FOR
THOSE LANGUAGES INSTRUCTION MAC
MATCHES THE SAME AS THE ENGLISH
AND SPANISH SO- WHATEVER TO
INSTRUCTIONS ARE IN ENGLISH IT'S
THE SAME THING AS- SEVEN
LANGUAGES. BUT THEY ALSO HAVE
ADDITIONAL- PORT FOR YOUR
TRUSTED REFEREED TO HAVE MORE
LANGUAGES THAT COULD PROVIDE
THAT THE SAME SAME INSPECTION.
IS SO YOU'RE NOT ANSWERING MY
QUESTION IF I AM A TO GAULLIST
SPEAKING INDIVIDUAL IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND I FILL OUT A
APPLICATION FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BECAUSE I HAVE BEEN
DEEMED NONESSENTIAL BY THE
RESPONSE OR- NOT ESSENTIAL AS A
WORKER. AND I APPLY FOR BENEFITS
AND I SPEAK TO GAULA. AND I TAKE
A PICTURE OF MYSELF BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THE APPLICATION
INTERCALL INSTRUCTS ME TO DO TO
SEND TO YOU OR SOMEONE ON YOUR
STAFF. DO I HAVE A CLEAR
TO I READ A COMMENT THIS SAYS
THIS PHOTO WILL BE USED FOR
FACIAL ID OR FACIAL RECOGNITION.
DO I CLEARLY UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT'S A STANDARD OPERATING
PROCEDURE. BY THE EDT. FOR THEIR
CONDO. FELLOW- ARE THAT FENDER
THE WHEN THEY AFTER THE PHOTO
DON'T COME TO AYE ET. IT'S THE
PROCEDURE THAT RIGHT AND ASK AND
THE AT THE OUT TWENTY TO PREPARE
CLAIM ACT NOW. WHEN THEY GET
INTO AYE ME- SO. FOR ANY. WHY
THEY GET IN EATING THE ONLY.
ENGLISH AND SPANISH AT THIS TIME
SELL BUT WE DON'T DO THAT THAT
THAT THAT THE UPLOAD OF THE
PICTURE IS NOT IN THE EDT
WEBSITE IT'S IN B. B. ID ME
WEBSITE SO ANY TERMS AND
CONDITIONS. OF ID NEED IT'S
PRESENTED WITH THE POTENTIAL
CLAIM THAT WHEN THEY DO THEY'RE
THEY'RE VERIFYING YOUR IDENTITY
IS IN THE ID ME WHAT'S WEBSITE.
AND INSTRUCTIONS HE'S SPLITTING
HAIRS WHEN AND THAT'S I'M SORRY
BUT YOU'RE SPLITTING HAIRS. SO
YOU HAVE A CONTRACTOR THE
STANCES OF HIS ONE MORE ONE MORE
TIME AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON AND
MAYBE WE COULD HAVE A- SECURE
LINE WINNING HERE'S- OKAY I
APOLOGIZE FOR SAYING IT GOES TO
THE EIGHTY D. BDD EMPLOYEES A
CONTRACTOR. THAT CONTRACTOR
PROVIDES BENEFITS OR OR
APPLICATION PROCESSES OR
WHATEVER. EVEN IF THAT'S
INCORRECT. I'M TRYING TO GET TO
THE IS. WE SOMEBODY WHO SPEAKS
TO GOLF OR A OF THOSE EITHER SO
LINK. AND THEY TAKE A SELFIE AS
AN APPLICATION PROCESS IN ORDER
TO OBTAIN BENEFITS BECAUSE THEY
ARE NO LONGER ELIGIBLE TO
FURTHER NO LONGER WORKING. DOES
THAT INDIVIDUAL CLEARLY
UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN THEY SUBMIT
THAT PHOTO TO THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR OR THE CONTRACTOR.
FOR EDIE D. THEY ARE GOING TO
USE THAT FOR FACIAL RECOGNITION
AGAINST SOME LARGER MORE
EXPANSIVE DATABASE. SENATOR NEED
THE VERY SPEEDY I THINK I SO. IT
HAS BEEN AWHILE SINCE I HAVE
GONE THROUGH I. DV BUT THERE IS
A BOX THAT YOU CHECK- THAT SAYS
THAT YOU ACKNOWLEDGE YOU KNOW
THAT I. D. ME CAN USE YOUR
INFORMATION AND YOU KNOW EXCEPT
ARE UP FOR THE PURPOSES OF
WHITE- YOU'RE GOING TO ID NEED
FOR. AND SO I THINK YOUR
QUESTION IS THAT ALSO IN OTHER
LANGUAGES TO PEOPLE UNDERSTAND-
IN OTHER LANGUAGES THAT THAT IS
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS THAT YOUR
QUESTION. IS YES AND THAT'S IT
AND THEN I HAVE TO JUMP IN THE
ANSWER YES. THAT'S THE AND
THAT'S HOW. YOU ALWAYS ANSWER
STAND OKAY. YES YES WE GOT IT
GOING. I SUCKS SO IT THAT MIGHT
BE IN IS I DO KNOW I GOING TO
ASSUME. THAT WHEN THEY TRANSLATE
THE WEBSITE IT IS TRANSLATED
INTO THE OTHER LANGUAGES AND
THAT IS STILL- AN OPTION TO
CHECK THE BOX YES OKAY MY LAST
WE'RE GONNA. RUN THIS IS S
THESE CONTRACTS FOR THESE THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATORS ARE
CONTRACTORS THAT EDIE YOU ADD
USES. IS THERE A- IS THERE A
SUBJECT TO CANCELLATION NOTICE
CAN BE CANCELED- IMMEDIATELY
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS- OR IS THERE
A PENALTY FOR CANCELLATION ON AN
EARLY CANCELLATION NOTICE. I
WILL DEFER TO THIS CHAU ON THAT
. YES SPEAK WITHOUT THE- OF THE
IDB CONTRACT WE DO HAVE A
PREPAID- UP OF FOUR FORTY I DO
NEED BUT WE CAN CANCEL THE
SERVICE- WITHIN A CERTAIN LIMIT
OF TIME I AFFECT LET THEM KNOW
THAT THAT WE'RE CANCELLING THE
CONTRACT. WITHOUT PENALTY.
CORRECT BUT WE WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO RECOVER THE ONES THAT WE
ALREADY PREPAID THANK YOU MA'AM
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THANK YOU
DIRECTOR WILL MOVE ON NOW TO
ISSUE SEVEN. AND THE ISSUE SEVEN
IS WORKFORCE EDUCATION. TIME FOR
A SHORT SUMMARY OF THE PROPOSALS
OUTLINED IN THE AGENDA- SOMEONE
FROM EDT. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR- HI MEGAN THE ADDRESS WITH
THE EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL I
BELIEVE I'M GOING TO BE SPEAKING
FIRST AND THEN- MY COLLEAGUE
FROM EDT WILL ALSO. SOME
INFORMATION- FIRST OFF THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITYTO WRITE A
BRIEF SUMMARY OF THE TWO
INITIATIVES FOR THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL- BRIEFLY THE
FIRST INITIATIVE WHICH IS OUR
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE ADVANCEMENT
INITIATIVE WHICH IS REQUESTING
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS. TO
SUPPORT- JOB ENTRY CAREER
ADVANCEMENT TOP FOR ENTRY LEVEL
ANOTHER WORKERS IN CHAIR HEALTH
CARE AND HUMAN SERVICES SETTINGS
INCLUDING SOCIAL WORK. AND THIS
FUNDING WILL GO DIRECTLY TO THE
EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE TRAINING
AND THEREBY CREATING CAREER
PATHWAYS THE FUNDING WILL ALSO
GO TO- ORGANIZED LABOR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. NONPROFITS
TRADE ASSOCIATIONS ALSO TO
PROVIDE TRAINING TO THE WORKERS
MULTIPLE FIRE SETTINGS- TRAINING
PROVIDERS THAT DO USE THIS
FUNDING TO UPSKILL EXISTING
EMPLOYERS WILL BE REQUIRED TO
DEMONSTRATE I WAGE INCREASES
AFTER TRAINING COMPLETION IN
ORDER TO RECEIVE FUNDING- UNLIKE
OTHER CORE ETP SERVICES SUCH AS
MANUFACTURING AND CONSTRUCTION
CETERA. BUT CARE AND YOU SERVICE
INDUSTRY PROVIDERS ARE NOT
NORMALLY ELIGIBLE FOR YOU TO BE
FUNDING HOWEVER THROUGH THIS
INITIATIVE ARE THEY WILL BE ABLE
TO APPLY FOR THE FUNDS AND BUILD
SKILLS. FOR THEIR WORK FORCE TO
SUPPORT CAREER ADVANCEMENT AND
MORE HIGHLY SKILLED AND ARE
COMPENSATED ROLES SO THAT IS THE
FIRST INITIATIVE- THE SECOND
INITIATIVE IS OUR WORKFORCE
LITERACY INITIATIVE. THIS IS
REQUESTING TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR EACH REPEAT TO
EXPAND WORKFORCE LITERACY
TRAINING AND CONTEXTUALIZED
ENGLISH DIGITAL SKILLS AND
TECHNICAL SKILLS TRAINING FOR
INCUMBENT AND YOU'LL HIRE
WORKERS AS WELL AS FOR THE
UNEMPLOYED INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT. THIS
WILL ENABLE EMPLOYERS TO BUILD
SKILLED WORKFORCES AND INCREASE
EMPLOYEE RETENTION PROVIDING
PATHWAYS I HAD TO- ATHLETES TO
HIGHER WAGES AND BETTER JOBS FOR
IMMIGRANTS REFUGEES. AND OTHER
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENCY-
INDIVIDUALS THIS FUNDING- WILL
ENABLE PARTICIPANTS ARE
PARTICIPATING EMPLOYERS- AND
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS ORGANIZED. LABOR UNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
AGAIN. STRAIGHTEST THE BILL
SKILLED WORK FORCES AND IN AND-
AND PROVIDE POWER TO HIGHER WAGE
FOR THOSE IMMIGRANTS REFUGEES
ARM AND- A LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT INDIVIDUALS. OF THE
ETP WILL UTILIZE EXISTING NEW
PARTNERSHIPS EXISTING AND NEW
PARTNERSHIPS EXCUSE ME. BY THE
AND CAN WITH THESE. THE
PARTNERSHIP'S WILL INCLUDE THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES-
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMS ADULT AND I CAME TO ALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS- AS WELL AS NON
PROFITS AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARDS THAT HAVE A
REFUGEE ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS-
JERRY THAT. THANK YOU AND THAT'S
A BRIEF OVERVIEW THOSE TWO AND-
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE THE
FOLLOWING NEED TO BE COLLEAGUES
AS WELL- IN ORDER TO HAVE THEM
HEALTH AND ANSWERING QUESTIONS
THEY ARE RED CHOPPIER. COURTNEY
QUITE AND DIANA THOREZ AND MARIO
MANDZUKIC- HOWEVER BEFORE WE GET
TO QUESTIONS I BELIEVE MY PEER
OVER ACT EDT HAVE YEAR ROMERO.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR WORKFORCE
SERVICES WILL BE PROVIDING SOME
INFORMATION REGARDING EDIE'S.
INITIATIVES PARDEE MANAGER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE COMPANY
IN THE NEXT THREE ITEMS
OFFICIALS SEVEN ON THE FIRST ONE
BEING DISPLACED OIL AND GAS
CORPORATE PRIVATE FUN. THIS IS A
FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR A PILOT TO SUPPORT
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF THE OIL AND
GAS WORKERS THAT ARE DISPLACED-
THIS PROPOSAL. ESTIMATES
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
SECONDS TO COMPLEMENT STATES
EXISTING UNEMPLOYMENT SERVICES
TO MITIGATE THE IMPACT ON
WORKERS ARE DISPLACED IN THIS
INDUSTRY. THE THIS PILOT THE
BEST MY WILL COMPLEMENT- THE
STATE'S X. WORK. INNOVATION
OPPORTUNITY ACT THE STOCK
WORKABLE. WHICH IS INTENDED TO
STOP WORKER ARE JUST PROBABLY
THIS FINAL BE DEDICATED TO THESE
WORKERS. ARMIES WORKERS WILL
HAVE TAXES OKAY- TRANSITIONAL
JOBS. RECOUNTS FROM EMPLOYMENT
AND SERVICE AND HELP THEM TO
PREPARE FOR- NEW CAREERS- ALSO
THE STATE'S RESOURCES MAGAZINE
THIS FIND UNIQUE THAT IT WOULD
ALSO HELP THEM WITH THEIR BIKES
STYLE ISN'T ACTUALLY HELP THEM
WITH THEIR LIVING EXPENSES SUCH
AS HOUSING. GROCERIES UTILITIES
CHILD CARE- AND ALSO WILL AND WE
INTEND FULLY CLAMOR. ON WITH A
WHOLE OF PARTNER IN THIS THOSE
DEPARTMENTS WITH INTERNALLY
STATE OF SADDAM TO RAINY I CALL
. AS THEY DIRECTOR OF THE CALL
WORKERS ALL ON BOARD STATE- OIL
CAP TRADING BE A PART- PROGRAM
THAT WOULD THE PROGRAM AS
PROVIDING WORKERS IN. IN HIM
GIVE THEM. INTO A NEW INDUSTRY
IN THE. YOUR PROGRAM SO WE WILL
WORK VERY CLOSE. WITH OUR
PARTNERS TO DO THE- AND WE WILL
USE THIS. I WILL USE THIS PILOT
TO COLLECT ON THE- OF THIS
POPULATION AND- ALERT FROM THE
PROGRAM SHARE WITH REPORT BACK.
ON THE NEXT ITEM I WILL BE IN
JUST AS A SLOWER WILL BE SO
ANTICIPATE WHAT THIS FUN ABLE TO
SERVE ABOUT THREE FIVE WORK
STRATISTICS WORK. THE NEXT ITEM
I'LL BE IS INTEGRATED INTO AND-
YOU MUST LANGUAGE. THIS REQUEST
IS FOR ONE THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTED. AND THIS IS THE BEST
WILL. ABOUT T. INTEGRATOR
COMMENT. FOR ENGLISHMAN
HIGHLIGHTS ARAMBULA EXPANDING
PRODUCTS BE ON THE STATE THIS
PRO WILL. CONTEXTUAL ENGLISH
LANGUAGES. OKAY TRAINING FOR IN
DEMAND OCCUPATIONS. THIS THIS
ARM WITH THIS- THIS MODEL IS
BASED ON. PILOTS THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE ONE WAY AND THAT HAVE HAD-
EVIDENCE OF THE OTHER STATES-
PRIVATE AN INCH SHORT THIS MODEL
BROUGHT ACCESS TO OCCUPATION
SKILLS FOR THIS POP. AND AS WE
KNOW THIS ARE IN SLANG LEARNERS
. ARE IMMIGRANTS WORKERS. ARE
THE ONES THAT WERE FIRST ENACTED
BY LAST FINANCIAL CRISIS IN OUR
LITTLE ONE STRUGGLING TO COME
OUT THIS PROGRAM WILL HELP THEM
WITH THAT- THE GOAL HERE IS ONE.
COMBINED CONTEXTUALLY LEARNING
OCCUPATIONAL TRAINING AND DEMAND
JOBS TO GET THEM ON A PATH TO
SKILLED JOBS. AND I ALSO ADDED
THAT THIS PROGRAM WILL. ENTAIL
UNDERVALUATION COMPONENT. AND
WHICH WILL SUPPORT. ONE ASSEMBLY
WITH THE PROGRESS AND SUCCESSES
OF THESE PROGRAMS ALSO ADDRESS
ON TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE NEEDS
AND LET US ALL KNOW HOW WE CAN
BETTER FASTER. THIS TIME WITH
ANYTHING BECOMING SCALE AND BE
MORE IMPACTFUL. FOR THE INTENDED
COMMUNITY. AND BOB ARM AND THIS
IS GOING BACK THE A. T. WE HAD
TO SERVING OUR PLEASE SIXTEEN
HUNDRED ARTISTS- LAST ITEM
COVERING BE A TARGET EMERGES
MEDICAL SERVICE CORPS. THIS
REQUEST IS A TOTAL SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS. THIS
INVESTMENT IS PART OF THE CARE
ECONOMY PACKAGE ARAMBULA MAKES
THIS PROGRAM UNIQUE IN THAT IT
FOCUSES ON- THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TECHNICIANS. IT WILL
WORK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEMS- AND
THEY'RE CONTRACTED TO MERGE THE
MEDICAL PROVIDERS AND WHAT'S
UNIQUE ABOUT THIS PROGRAM THAT
IT WILL TARGET USING THOSE USE
MOST ANY. AND WE HAVE A MODEL
THAT WE ARE BASED IN THIS
PROGRAM ON IT TOMORROW I'M A
MODEL THAT WAS- CREATE A IN THE
ALAMY AREA. THEY HAD A LOT OF
SIX BECAUSE THEY HAVE. KONKRETEN
SUPPOSED APPROACH. TO THAT-
DEVELOP NOT ONLY DEBATE RECRUIT
TRAIN AND HELP THEM GET JOBS BUT
THEY INCLUDE. ARMS MENTORING
THINGS WITH MY TRAUMA- IT IS
VERY AFFECT AND ARMED WITH STATE
USED WHAT'S MOST IN NEED- SO
WILL BE LOOKING TO REPLICATE
THAT MARK. ACROSS STATE WITH
THAT PROGRAM ANTICIPATE TO SIR
ABOUT. EIGHTEEN HUNDRED PARTISAN
MARKETS THAT WILL CONCLUDE MY
PRE SUMMER- WELCOME WELCOME
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MR
ROBERT- THE A. O. LIKE TO CALM.
GOOD AFTERNOON CELLO ONLY
BRIEFLY- WITH RESPECT TO THE FOR
I- OF THIS. GROUP GRANTS- OR
HELP IN AN- SOCIAL SECTORS ARE
PART OF THEIR THE CARAVAN A
PACKAGE I MENTIONED- EARLIER- I
WILL BE WERE A BROADER. I ON THE
CARE COMING BUT DON'T OUT THAT
ET GRANTS HAVE HAVE I THINK OF
SAN AND ALLOW. SEVERAL BUDGETS-
MORE THAN DOUBLING- THERE
THERE'S FOR LONG TRADITIONAL
MOUNT AND WE PUT OUT THAT WHAT
IS IT YOU'RE GOING TO. ENSURE
THAT EIGHTY EIGHTY P. HAS A
CAPACITY TO ADMINISTER THE
GRANTS- EVIDENTIAL REVIEW THE-
QUALIFICATIONS ABOUT- ONGOING
REQUIREMENTS FOR EMPLOYERS WHO
WHO DO RECEIVE ATP GRANT
POLITICS- BUT NO SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS JUST HIGHLIGHTS. THANKS THANK YOU FOR MUCH-
WITH FINANCE LIKE TO COMMON. I
UP IN THE MODIFY NO ADDITIONAL
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU HAVE AN
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU-
I DO HAVE ACTUALLY A FEW
QUESTIONS WANT FOR DEEP OF FINE.
CAN YOU WHY THE TRAINING
PROPOSALS THAT ARE BEING
REQUESTED ARE UNDER THE EDT AS
OPPOSED TO- THE LABOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY. I FEDERAL
JOB IN THE FARMER TO FINANCE
THANK YOU CHAIR- SO I THINK
THERE'S BEEN TWO PARTS OF THIS
ONE FIRST IS THE ATP WHICH IS.
ITSELF A TRAINING ANY THAT
OPERATES BUDGETARY EARLY
UNDERNEATH. INCLEMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT- BUT IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE WOULD SORT
OF WE HAVE FULL CONFIDENCE THAT
EIGHTY THEIR PROPERTY
IMPLEMENTATION ENTITY. THE EMT
AND OTHER PROGRAMS BECAUSE OF
EDIE'S WORKS ARE WORKFORCE
SERVICES BRANCH THAT CURRENTLY
MINISTERS. BROWN SIX HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDING EVERY YEAR HAS A
DEMONSTRATED CAPACITY TO PROCURE
FUNDS AND- EVALUATE- AS WELL AS
CONDUCT TITLE ONE OVERSIGHT OF
WE- SO WE HAVE NO CONCERNS ABOUT
THEIR ABILITY TO IMPLEMENT THESE
. GET UP YEAH I WASN'T
QUESTIONING THAT I WAS
QUESTIONING ASKING SINCE WE HAD
ALL OF THESE PROPOSALS. FROM THE
LABOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY AND FRANKLY I THINK SOME
OF THEM ARE DUPLICATES SO I
DON'T UNDERSTAND. WHY HAVE A
DUPLICATE FONG- PROGRAM UNDER ET
DE OR EIGHTY P. WE JUST WENT
THROUGH A WHOLE PRESENTATION OF
THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM THE- HEALTH
AND SOCIAL WORK. THE OF FUND FOR
OIL AND GAS WORKERS- THE
INTEGRATED EDUCATION OUR
TRAINING ALL OF THESE WERE JUST
WE JUST WENT THROUGH THESE AND
THE- LABOR ON WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. WHAT WHAT IS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THESE
PROGRAMS. I CHAIR- PETRA TOP AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SORT OF I
THINK YOU MAY BE REFERRING TO
THE OVERVIEW THAT THE LABOR
AGENCY GAVE BEFOREHAND WHICH
INCLUDED THESE BUT ARE NOT BEING
ADMINISTERED BY THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY IS
AGENCY DOES NOT IMPLEMENT
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD FALL TO THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE E. D. I
WOULD DEFER TO MY LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
COLLEAGUES IF THEY HAVE
ANYTHING. LIKE THAT. WHO'S GONNA
ANSWER THAT WELL IF I MAY JUST
ADD- IF YOU RECALL EARLIER. THIS
NAY GIVEN OVERVIEW OF THE LABOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGING
INVESTMENTS WHICH TO CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD- AS
PATRICK STATED. OUR OVERUSE SHE
COVERED SOME OF THE. INVESTMENT
STATE HEALTH. AND WE FOR THE
SEASON FALL WITH A- THAT
FRAMEWORK SHE PROVIDED AND THEY
ARE EACH DISTINCT. YEAH ARMED IF
WE COULD PERHAPS FOLLOW UP AND
PROVIDE FURTHER CLARIFICATION OF
THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN EACH OF
THIS INVESTMENTS BUT THEY ARE
WHEN FOR EXAMPLE THAT WOMEN
TRAINING PANEL COVERED ONE
REGARDING THE EMIGRATE WORKFORCE
THAT WAS REALLY FOCUSED ON
WORKERS INCUMBENT WORKERS
WORKERS THAT ARE. ACTUALLY
EMPLOYED ALREADY UPGRADE
GOVERNMENT SAW- THE ONE I
DESCRIBED IS MORE BROAD IT'S TO
EXPAND. EVERY SPECIFIC- PROGRAM-
THAT WOULD. I EXPAND ON A MOM OF
DEGREE THAT WOULD TRADITIONALLY
A BEEN AND TRAINING TO DO THAT
AND SPECIFIC TRAINING AND THAT
WOULD BE BROADER TO THE PUBLIC
MIND THOSE THAT ARE PUBLIC.
UNDERPLAY SAID THAT I JUST GIVE
BAD AND EXAMPLE TOOLS. THE
DISTINCTION OF THE COMMISSION BY. YEAH AND THIS IS ABBY WITH THE
EACH I FOLLOW UP ON HOW THE
REMAIN. COMMENTS ON AS I DID
DESCRIBE EARLY. THESE ARE THREE
AND AROUND HOW. AROUND CLIMATE-
AROUND IMMIGRANT INTO WHICH ON
IN WHICH EACH OF THE- IN TAKING
P. THE WORK FOR DEVELOP BOARD ON
WILL ADMINISTER. IMPENDING-
SPECIFIC PROBE ALUM AND ARE JUST
TO- COORDINATE TO REFERRAL TO
COP EACH OTHER- IS JUST PART OF
THE INCREASING THE OF.
COORDINATION TO GET PEOPLE INTO
GOOD AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN.
PLEASE LET ME KNOW IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS. OKAY SO THE WITH THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE DISCUSSED
EARLIER WHEN THOSE UNDER THE
LABOR WORK FORCE DEVELOPMENT.
UNDER THE LARGER UMBRELLA BUT
THE DIRECTED MINISTRATION OF THE
PROGRAM'S GOES TO ANY OF THESE
WORK FOR SERVICES BRANCH THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL AND
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
. OKAY THIS WILL SOUND DIFFERENT
THE OIL WORKERS- THE TERMINOLOGY
THAT'S USED HERE IS REALLY
DIFFERENT SOCKS USE ME FOR IF I
GOT THESE CONFUSED BUT THIS
DESCRIBES IT AS DISPLACED BROWN
DISSIPATED- ONCE WORD SAYS
ACTUALLY DISPLACED. THE OTHER
WORDS ARE ANTICIPATED
DISPLACEMENT- AND THOSE ARE
REALLY DIFFERENT FROM THE WAY
THAT WE HEARD EARLIER BY MISTER
RANEY IS THE PROCESS OF OKAY AS
THERE IS OPPORTUNITY TO CAP THE
OIL WELLS THAT THERE WILL BE A
TRANSITION FOR THOSE AND WORKERS
OF BRUCE'S YOU KNOW THEY'RE
DISPLACED AND SO LET'S GIVE HIM
SOME MONEY AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS
NEXT- DOES THE- HIGH ROW
TRAINING PARTNERSHIP DO THOSE
ELEMENTS APPLY TO ALL OF THESE
AS WELL. HAVE YOUR DO YOU WANT
TO ADDRESS THE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS. SURE YES- SELECTED
THE ONE THAT MISTER RANEY WAS
DESCRIBING EARLIER WAS VERY
SPECIFIC TO A PILOT FOR OIL
CAFFEINE AND WHICH WE WILL BE
SEEKING ACTUALLY PLACE PEOPLE
INTO THOSE POSITIONS- ARM THE
FINE THAT I DESCRIBE AS
DISPLACED WORKER FIND IS A FUND
CREATED TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
WORKERS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
DISPLACED FROM AN INDUSTRY AND
THAT IN THE FUTURE WE ANTICIPATE
THE TREND TO CONTINUE UNTIL WE
CONTINUE OUR ONGOING THE SPACE
JUST RIGHT INDUSTRY AND THIS
FUND WILL BE CREATED TO HELP
THOSE WORKERS. AND THAT CAP AND
TRADE WILL BE OPTION FOR MANY OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SERVE
BUT ALSO OUR FUNDING WILL ACT
FINE OTHERS- GRANTS THAT WILL
SUPPORT PROGRAMS THAT WOULD HELP
THESE WORKERS FIND NEW CAREERS.
IN OTHER SECTORS AND INDUSTRIES
. OKAY REQUEST WELL IT IS BASED
APPEAR APPEAR TO BE DISK I MEAN
I DON'T UNDER WHY THEY AND DO.
DEPARTMENTS BRUCE'S THERE IN ONE
PLACE YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S ALL
GOING TO COMPREHENSIVELY PROVIDE
FOR THOSE WORKERS AND YOU KNOW I
JUST DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT
WE'RE ALREADY DECIDING THAT THEY
WILL BE DISPLACED WHEN OUR WHEN
OUR GOAL IS SAID TO BE THEY WILL
NOT BE DISPLACED THEY WILL BE
TRANSITIONED- AND PROVIDED FOR
THE TRAINING OF THEY NEED WHICH
APPEARS TO BE VERY LITTLE- TO GO
INTO THESE NEW INTO THESE NEW
SECTORS INTO THESE NEW JOBS SO.
THAT PART MAKES ME YOU KNOW
UNCOMFORTABLE TO DECLARE THAT
THERE WILL BE DISPLACED WORKERS
WE ARE HAVE WE ARE THINKING
ABOUT THE FUTURE JOBS AS A PLACE
FOR THOSE WORKERS TO GO INTO NOT
AS THEY'RE GOING TO BE LEFT OUT
THERE AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE THEM YOU KNOW SOME SOME
MONEY SO THAT'S MY QUESTION
THERE ON THE ATP ON THE-
TARGETED TRAINING FOR EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TECHNICIANS I READ THE
MODEL THAT WAS BEING USED AND
WAS A LITTLE CONCERNED THAT THE
MODEL HAS THERE'S A TRAINING
STIPEND OF A THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MONTH- SO THAT PARTICIPANTS CAN
FOCUS ON TRAINING. WITHOUT PART
TIME OR FULL TIME EMPLOYMENT. I
KNOW THAT THAT'S EXACTLY THE
KIND OF MODEL WE WANT TO USE
BECAUSE A THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MONTH IS NOT GOING TO PAY THE
BILLS. EVERY EXPECTED TO DO THE
TRAINING WITHOUT- BEING ABLE TO
WORK SO JUST TO COMMENT ON THAT
I DON'T NEED A RESPONSE IS NOT A
QUESTION- MEMBERS QUESTIONS. YES
SENATOR NEWMAN. RETURNED AND FOR
PUTTING MYSTERY MERYL OR
SOMEBODY LIKE QUESTION ON. THE
ATP COMPONENT RIGHT SO NINE
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS
OBVIOUSLY. SIMPLY REGIONALLY BIG
SOME OF MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THE TRAINING CAN BE DONE EITHER
IN HOUSE. OR BY A THIRD PARTY
AND STRIKE BACK MIGHT MAKE
QUESTIONS ARE. DO WE CURRENTLY
HAVE- TO VISION CAPACITY IN OR
THERE ARE ARE THERE. EXISTING
TRAINING PROVIDERS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE FOR A PROGRAM LIKE
THIS AND I GUESS AS PART OF THAT
WHAT WHAT WHAT'S THE SERVICE
STANDARD FOR QUICKER FOR
PARTICIPATION. OF COURSE
CERTIFICATION TO DO THAT. I CAN
ANSWER QUESTION FOR THE RECORD
THIS IS DIANA TORSION THE PLAN
TRAINING PANEL CURRENTLY JUST TO
CLARIFY A WITH REGARDS TO ANY
HOUSE THE TRAINING IS ACTUALLY
PROVIDED BY EITHER THE EMPLOYER
THEMSELVES BY THEIR IN HOUSE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS. OR THEY
CAN APPROACH YOUR THIRD PARTY
TRAINING ENDORS WE ALSO
CONTRACTOR ACTUALLY WITHOUT A
POINT WHERE CONTRACTORS WHO ARE
TRAINING AGENCIES OR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. SO IT'S NOT E. G. P.
THE PROVIDES THE TRAINING I'M
NOT SURE OF THAT I WAS ABLE TO
CLARIFY HIS DATE I MEAN THAT WAS
CLEAR BUT SERVICE TO WHAT'S
WHAT'S- WHAT'S THE STANDARD FOR
PARTICIPATION. BY YOU KNOW BY
WAY OF QUALIFICATION VACATION
FOR A THIRD PARTY PROVIDER AND
ARE THERE SITUATION NUMBER RIGHT
NOW. TO MEET THE DEMAND THAT
THIS WILL CREATE. EXCELLENT WHAT
. SHOW FOR THE THIRD PARTY- WE
DO HAVE TRAINING H. SIR. SUCH AS
THE BURKE- THE- SECOND AS WELL
FOR COMMITTEE IS OBVIOUS WE HAVE
. THE A RATIONS THAT ARE
NECESSARY FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TRAINER'S. CREATURE THAT'S RIGHT
I GUESS- THE PROVISION RIGHT
HERE ALLOWS FOR EXTENDED PERIOD
FOR A CONFERENCE SO THIS IS A
FIVE YEAR CYCLE IS A IS THAT
CORRECT. AND AGAIN I GUESS I'D
LOVE TO LEARN MORE WE DON'T DO
IT NOW ABOUT THROUGH THE G. P.
MODEL JUST YOU KNOW BE MORE
GENERALLY- AND THE COMMUNITY OF
TRAINERS- AND FULLY QUALIFIED
PARTICIPANTS- BECAUSE IT SEEMS
THE OTHERS ARE FAIRLY TECHNICAL
AREAS SO THAT- YOU KNOW MY
CONCERN IS THAT. EITHER WERE NOT
READY TO DO THIS QUICKLY- OR IT
WILL TAKE LONG ENOUGH. TO FIND
TRAINERS FOR BY GESS THE
CONGRESS IS THAT WE WILL HAVE.
SURGERY TO SEE THAT WE WON'T
HAVE THE HIGHEST QUALITY
TRAINING SO- I GUESS IT'S NOT
REALLY A QUESTION BUT AGAIN
ALLOW REACH OUT AT LIKE LEARN
MORE ABOUT THIS. I JUST WANT TO
COUPLE RELATED FOLLOW- IS ETP.
ARE REQUIRING JOB AND WAGE
COMMITMENTS UP FRONT SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT THESE. JOBS
THAT THEIR- TRAINEES ARE GOING
TO WILL BE GOOD JOBS AND- WHAT
INFORMATION IS IT DOES ETP
REQUIRE CONTRACTORS TO SUBMIT.
AND IS NOT AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC. YES I CAN ANSWER THE
FIRST PART OF YOUR QUESTION WITH
REGARD TO THE JOBS UP FRONT YES
EGP ALWAYS REQUIRES THE JOBS UP
FRONT AND UP AS WELL AS WE ARE
ACTUALLY VERY POSITIONS WITH OUR
NEW SYSTEMS. CHIU REQUIRE AND
ASKED FOR THE CURRENT WAGES OF
THOSE- TRAINING PARTICIPANTS AS
WELL AS THE WAGES AT THE END OF
THEIR NINETY DAY RETENTION
PERIOD OR A SPECIFIC RETENTION
PERIOD BASED ON THE TYPE OF
OCCUPATION. AND IS THAT
INFORMATION- THE- THAT
CONTRACTORS ARE THEY REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT THAT AND IS IT PUBLIC. I
CAN ANSWER THAT QUESTION MARK
ABOUT SLICK FROM EGP AS PART OF
OUR APPLICATION DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS THE CONTRACTORS ARE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE WAGE
INFORMATION- ONE OF YOUR
PATIENTS ARE BEING TRAINED AND
THEIR TRAINING CLASS- THAT ALL
GETS PUT INTO A PROPOSAL THAT
GOES INTO- IN FRONT OF OUR PANEL
AND WE PUBLISH. THOSE PROPOSALS
ONLINE- WE WITHHOLD CERTAIN
INFORMATION THAT'S PROPRIETARY
TO THE COMPANIES- THEN ONCE THE
CONTRACT IS EXECUTED WHERE
TRACKING ON AN INDIVIDUAL
TRAINEE LEVEL- WE'RE WE'RE
GETTING- YOU KNOW DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION THINGS LIKE THAT-
FOR THAT ALL OF THAT IS IN OUR
NEW- A NEW KILEY FOR SYSTEM
BASED ON SALES FORCE WHICH ALL
PROTECTED AND- ENCRYPTED. ALSO
THE- BASICALLY PRO PRIVATE THE
PRIVATE INFORMATION IS NOT
SHARED WITH ANYONE THAT CAN'T BE
SHARED. I'M SORRY I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT. IT IF THIS IS A
PUBLIC CONTRACT WHAT INFORMATION
IS BEING WITHHELD. SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS IT'S- BASICALLY
INDIVIDUAL IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS IF THEY'RE COLLECTED
WHICH WE DO COLLECTED ENROLLMENT
FOR. ATTENTION VERIFICATION
PURPOSES- JUST BASIC DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION ABOUT THE TRAINEES
THEIR NAMES THINGS LIKE THAT IF
EVER WE'RE SHARING DATA WHERE WE
HAVE TO SCRUB THAT TYPE OF
INFORMATION SO THAT IT'S NOT
SHARED- THEN IN AGGREGATE WE DO
REPORTED YEARLY- IN OUR ANNUAL
REPORT WE PROVIDE A REPORT OF
HOW WE DID ESSENTIALLY DURING
THE LAST YEAR ACROSS ALL OF OUR
PROJECTS AND ALL OF OUR
CONTRACTS AND- WE DO A
PRESENTATION FOR A PENALTY WHICH
OF COURSE- YOU'RE ALL WELCOME TO
COME WE'RE ABOUT TO DO ONE- IN A
MONTH OR TWO- JUST TO GIVE YOU
ONE- ONE SIMPLE POINT. ON
AVERAGE AS YOU'VE HEARD- OUR
DEPUTY DIRECTOR I MAKE IT SURE
IS STATE. ON AVERAGE WE TRAIN
ABOUT EIGHTY THOUSAND TRAINEES
PER YEAR- AND OUR AVERAGE WAGE
ACROSS OUR ENTIRE PROGRAM. ENDS
UP BEING OVER THIRTY DOLLARS AN
HOUR SO THESE ARE GOOD QUALITY
OF GOOD QUALITY TRAINING THAT'S
RESULTING IN HIGHER WAGES. OKAY
THANK YOU CENTER GROVE PLEASE
THANK YOU MR GET RIGHT STRAIGHT
INTO THE QUESTION OKAY THANK YOU
I DO BELIEVE THAT THESE
QUESTIONS WILL BE DIRECTED TO
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR RESPONDING
IN ADVANCE SO THE INFORMATION I
HAVE ON THE AGENDA SAYS THAT-
THE DISPLACING OIL PULLING GAS
WORKERS ON THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO
ESTABLISH AND PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
FOR OIL AND GAS WORKERS. FACING
AN ANTICIPATED DISPLACEMENT DO
YOU REALLY THINK THEY WOULD IT
WAS AN ANTICIPATED DISPLACEMENT
. PALMER THE WAY IN THE CURRENT
TREND WITH THIS SUGGESTS THAT
THERE WILL BE DISPLACEMENT
SETBACK IN ABOUT INDUSTRY THE
STOCK WAS ADVANCED UNDER
CONSTANT OKAY M. THE SECOND
QUESTION I HAVE IS THAT THESE
WORKERS FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND OF
THEM ROUGHLY MAKE A HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR. DID YOU. DO YOU THINK THAT
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS ADEQUATELY
ADDRESSES THEIR WAGE LOSS WITH
THE LACK OF PERMITS AND
EVERYTHING BEING ISSUES AND JOB
AT PEOPLE BEING DISPLACED NOW.
TODAY WITHOUT RIGS GOING UP DO
YOU REALLY THINK THAT FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND FOR THIS.
UNANTICIPATED DISPLACEMENT. IN
YOUR ORDER GOVERNOR'S WORDS AND
IS ADEQUATE FOR THESE WORKERS.
IT'S INTENDED TO BE A PART OF
THE ARM AND WE HOPE TO LEARN
FROM THE LEVEL OF NEED. FROM
THIS POPULATION IN THIS INDUSTRY
AND AS WE GET ACQUIRED THAT
INFORMATION WEWILL REPORT BACK
AND WILL CERTAINLY BRING STATE
WILSHIRE THE MINISTRATION AND
YOURSELVES OKAY OKAY APPRECIATE
I MEAN I STILL HAVE OTHER
QUESTIONS MISS MADAM CHAIR. AND
SO JUST SO YOU KNOW. I FEEL LIKE
AGAINST FREELY FOR MINE FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND OIL FIELD WORKER
CONSTITUENTS. THEY WOULD RATHER
HAVE THEIR HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND THEIR
BENEFITS. INSTEAD OF GOING TO
WHATEVER FOOD LINE YOU EXPECT
THEM TO GO TO FOR HOUSING
GROCERIES AND CHILD CARE. WHICH
YOU MENTIONED. AND SO IN A IT'S
- HARD FOR ME TO UNDERSTAND THE
HOW AND ANTICIPATED DISPLACEMENT
THAT YOU ADDRESS OR THE
ADMINISTRATION DRESSES BECAUSE
YOU'RE PURPOSELY TRYING TO SHUT
DOWN THE INDUSTRY AND I STILL
CANNOT GET AN ANSWER FROM ANYONE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION REGARDING
WORKERS WHICH WE'RE DISCUSSING
TODAY OR HOW WE WILL CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE. AT THE NECESSARY OIL
THAT IS NEEDED FOR CALIFORNIANS
AND THEN EACH ONE OF OUR
DISTRICTS NOT TO MENTION MY
CULINARY GROUP ARE I REALLY
MASKING YOU TO ASK YOUR DIRECT
QUESTION IAN LINERS OUT OF LOS
NOT JUST MAKE COMMENTS ASK A
DIRECT QUESTION SO THAT THEY
COULD BE ANSWERED. WHEN ROUGHLY
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND OIL FIELD
WORKERS ARE DISPLACED NOT
ANTICIPATE NOT AN ANTICIPATED
BUT ANTICIPATED DISPLACED. WHERE
WILL THE ADMINISTRATION. NUMBER
ONE PUT THEM. LIKE THE CHAIRS
QUESTIONS THERE WILL BE SOME
THAT WILL TRANSITION INTO
CAPPING WELLS BUT IN SOME INTO
CONSTRUCTION AT IN NUMBER TWO-
WHERE WILL THIS IS SOMEBODY'S A
TELL ME WHERE THIS YEAR THIS OIL
IS GONNA COME FROM. I'M SORRY
CENTER GROUP THAT IS NOT THE
ISSUE BEFORE US HERE THE ISSUE
BEFORE US ARE THESE SPECIFIC
TRAINING PROGRAMS AND ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT THOSE SO THAT WE
CAN DECIDE ON THE BUDGET ITEM SO
IF THESE TRAINING PROGRAMS HERE
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION OF WITH
THESE TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT
YOU'RE ASKING DEFENDER
IRRELEVANT. IF WE DON'T HAVE THE
OIL TO TAKE CARE OF THE ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION BARRELS OF
OIL THE CALIFORNIA STATE FAIR I
NEED A SPECIFIC QUESTION OR
PLEASE MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
QUESTION HOW WILL WE PROVIDE ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION BARRELS OF
OIL WITH PEOPLE THAT DON'T WORK
IN THE INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
FIGURE TRANSITIONING. OUT OF
THOSE JOBS INTO EITHER FOOD
LINES OR OTHER JOBS. HELLO DO
THAT THAT'S NOT A QUESTION
BEFORE THAT IS RELEVANT TO THIS
ISSUE BEFORE US. SO WE MOVE ON
CENTER COURT AS HE DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. HE DISAPPOINTED
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE-
THE INDUSTRY. REGARDLESS OF THIS
COMMITTEE'S EFFORTS ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER IS HAS BEEN DECLINING
AT ABOUT SIXTY FIVE PERCENT-
ANNUALLY AS I UNDERSTAND THE
MATERIALS HERE SO THE QUESTION
BECOMES- WHAT WE DOING. TO HELP
THOSE FOLKS OUT- WELL THAT'S
HAPPENING. REGARDLESS OF WHAT
SIDE OF THAT ISSUE YOU'RE ON. IN
TERMS OF. FOSSIL FUELS. FOUR OR
WHATEVER IN A TOTALLY RESPECT
THE CONCERN OF. OF SOMEBODY IN
THE SENATE WHO REPRESENTS SO
MANY OF THOSE WORKERS- HAS THAT
LEGISLATORS. BUT I THINK REALLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE IS A
SAFETY NET. FOR WHAT'S
HAPPENING. WHILE IT'S HAPPENING.
PLEASE CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG-
BUT I JUST WANTED TO. JUST
CLARIFY MY ATTITUDE ABOUT THIS
IN THANK YOU AND. AGAIN I
RESPECT ALL OF HER COMMENTS.
COURSE THANK YOU OKAY- WE BONDS
TO. C. READ ON TO IS A- WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF A THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF FOR ME DD WE MOVE
ON TO THE OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ISSUE EIGHT ENHANCED
ENFORCEMENT OF COMPLIANCE- AND
WHO WILL BE PRESENTING FROM D.
I. R. I GET AFTERNOON. I'M TERRY
JANET CAME TO CAPPY DIRECTOR
FARID DR. SIR A GOOD AFTERNOON
MOM TURNED TWENTY MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT OUR BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL ON ENHANCED ENFORCEMENT
COMPLIANCE WHICH WILL SUPPORT BY
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS WORK ENFORCING OUR
STATE LABOR CODE TO PROTECT THE
ECONOMIC SECURITY AND HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF CALIFORNIA WORKERS. AS
MENTIONED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THE DEPARTMENT REQUEST
TEN POINT FOUR MILLION IN FIFTY
THREE POINT FIVE POSITIONS IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. TEN POINT ONE MILLION AND
FIFTY THREE POINT FIVE POSITIONS
IN TWENTY. FOUR NINE TWENTY
MILLION FIFTY TWO POINT FIVE
POSITIONS IN TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE AND TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION
AND THIRTEEN POSITIONS IN TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX AND I'M GOING.
TO TELL THE PROVISIONS OF
RECENTLY CHAPTER LEGISLATION.
AND THE INTEREST OF TIME I WILL
VERY QUICKLY TOUCH ON THE RECENT
LEGISLATION MUST PROPOSAL COVERS
THAT IS AB SEVEN OH ONE.
RELATING TO WAREHOUSE
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS AND QUOTAS.
I CANNOT PROVIDE COMPLIANCE WITH
MEAL AND REST PERIODS ARE
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
WISE AB TEN TWENTY THREE. PUSH
FOR SCRIBES HOW CERTIFIED
PAYROLL RECORDS SHOULD BE
SUBMITTED TO THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE AND ADDS A
MONETARY PENATY FOR CONTRACTORS
OR SUBCONTRACTORS THAT FAILED TO
SUBMIT. SB SIXTY TWO WHICH
PROHIBITS PAYMENT OF PIECE RATE
IN THE GARMENT INDUSTRY EXCEPT
AS AN INCENTIVE BONUS AMONG
OTHER PROVISIONS SB SIX OR SIX
WHICH GIVES SCHOLARSHIP THE
AUTHORITY. TO ISSUE ENTERPRISE
WIDE HEALTH AND SAFETY CITATIONS
AND LASTLY SB SEVENTY SEVEN.
WHICH REQUIRES DIRECT
CONTRACTORS. TO PRIVATE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS TO BE
JOINTLY LIABLE FOR THE PENALTIES
AND LIQUIDATED DAMAGES OF
SUBCONTRACTORS IF CERTAIN
CONDITIONS ARE MET. SO WITH THAT. I AM HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS- YOU VERY. FOR THE L.
ALE ARE HAVING TO COME. HELLO
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE OUT WE HAVE SPECIFIC
CONCERN WITH- PROPOSAL. THANK
YOU AND OUR FINANCE. I'M PATRICK
COMING DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
HAPPEN TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THE FIRM. BEFORE MY COLLEAGUES
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS I JUST WANT
TO MENTION THAT WITH REGARDS TO
SB SIXTY TWO WHICH IS A PART OF
THIS- THIS ISSUE- THERE WAS A-
THERE WAS A DRAFTING ERROR THAT
WAS MADE NOW SEEKING TO CORRECT
IT. SO THAT THERE WILL BE NO
AMBIGUITIES IN THE LAW- WELL NOW
WE OPEN THE DISCUSSION TOOK
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. YES SECRETARY THANK
YOU MANAGER. I HAVE THE- PRESSEL
BROADER ISSUE ON- F. T. FOR.
REALLY THE NUMBER OF FOLKS SAID
THAT MAY BE NEEDED- TO GET THIS
. THE OVERALL BODY OF WORK
AROUND ENFORCEMENT COMPLIANCE-
TOTALLY CAUGHT UP WITH ON ON AN
EVEN KEEL GOING FORWARD SO FIRST
OF ALL I'M SUPPORTIVE OF THESE.
REQUESTS AS I READ THEM I EIGHT
I CAME INTO THE SUPPORT OF THEM
AND I UNDERSTAND- VERY
PARTICULARLY ESPECIALLY. BY
HAVING. A CHAIRED FOR THE LABOR
COMMITTEE SENATE LABOR
COMMITTEE. IN AND SEEN OF ALL OF
THIS WORK COME THROUGH ON THE
POLICY SIDE- WHY YOU KNOW
AUGMENTATION IS NEEDED. BECAUSE
THE LARGER ISSUES SEEMS TO ME
AND I WANT TO SAY THAT I BASIS A
LOT ON. ADVOCACY IN MY OWN
DISTRICT- ON THE FACT THAT A
MILE DISTRICT THE COUNTY STOOD
UP WITH. A VERY ROBUST- OFFICE
BELIEBERS ENFORCEMENT TWO TWO IN
A SENSE. BUT TRY TO AUGMENT THE
ACTIVITIES OF THE DEPARTMENT-
HIS REPUTATION- YOU KNOW IN IN
IN MY OWN COUNTY AMONGST MY OWN-
ADVOCATES THERE IS VERY STRONG
IN TERMS OF. CAPABILITY BUT NOT
IN TERMS OF CAPACITY IN IN I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO HEAR FROM-
ANYONE WHO'S WHO'S WILLING TO
ADDRESS SAID IF IT'S MORE
COMFORTABLE FOR THE L. A. O. TO
ADDRESS AT EIGHT. I JUST THINK
THAT. WHO WOULD SUPPORT FOR US
TO HERE IS WHETHER OR NOT. THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD BE OFF BASE
AND CONSIDERING A SIGNIFICANT-
AUGMENTATION OF F. T. E. ACROSS
THE BOARD. WHEN I SIT CROSS
BORDER MEANING AND COMPLIANCE-
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN TOLD IS AS
MUCH AS AS THREE TIMES A NUMBER
OF STAFF WOULD NOT BE EXCESSIVE
WHEN THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND IS-
PROVIDE YOUR FEEDBACK ON IS. HOW
MUCH OF THAT CAN BE DONE WITH
EXISTING FUNDED VACANT
POSITIONS- OR OR WHETHER OR NOT
THAT'S AN ISSUE WE'VE HEARD. YOU
KNOW WITH SOME OTHER DEPARTMENTS
HAVE COME BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
THAT- THEY'RE TRYING TO FILL
POSITIONS SO IT'S NOT DOLLARS
THAT ARE NEEDED BUT IT'S- IT'S-
RECRUITMENT RETENTION THAT'S
NEEDED- COULD COULD SOMEBODY
SPEAK TO JUST WHAT. THE
SITUATION IS CURRENTLY IN TERMS
OF THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN.
FILL POSITIONS CAPACITY. AND- IN
BACKLOG. HI SENATOR DEANNA THING
DEPARTMENT I'M SORRY IF WE COULD
IF WE HAVE A REALLY SHORT ANSWER
OTHERWISE I'VE JUST BEEN
INFORMED CENTER CORTESE THAT WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE A FOLLOW UP
OVERSIGHT HEARING UP TO COVER
THIS BECAUSE I ALSO HAVE A LOT
OF QUESTIONS ON THE PHONE SO- IF
THERE'S SOME SOMETHING QUICK YOU
MIGHT WANT TO ANSWER OTHERWISE
SAW WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
HEARING TO COVER MORE OF THIS.
THAT WOULD BE FINE THEY DEFERRED
THE CHAIR ON THAT- AND- THANKS
TO THE FOLKS PRESENTING DON'T
MIND THAT AT ALL SO THAT'S FINE
WITH ME THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
I'M I'M CHECKING A VERY QUICK
ANSWER JUST AND RESPONSIVE.
THAT'S OKAY OKAY. SO IT JUST TO
SAY BY. I IT IS OUR DEPART.
PRIORITY TO ENSURE THAT WE FORM
. TO ENFORCE THE STATE LAW CODE
. AND TO THE SIDE QUESTION ABOUT
OUR- AGENCIES AT THE TOP PRIZE.
TEST HARD TO BAKER. WHICH
CURRENT ARE VACANCY RATES AROUND
25% WITH EIGHT HUNDRED AND-
FIFTY VACANCIES AND JUST TO NOTE
SOME OF THE PROGRESS THAT WE'VE
MADE IN THOSE VACANCIES OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS. TWENTY
NINETEEN. WE MADE TWENTY
APPOINTMENTS IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
APPOINTMENTS AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
APPOINTMENTS WHICH IS A TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED AND 50% INCREASE
FROM THE REVIOUS YEAR AND SO
JUST TO SAY THAT IT IS A
PRIORITY TO SIMPLE OF THE ARMY
AND DATE TO FILL EXISTING
VACANCIES. WE PUT IN A LOT OF
STRATEGIES IN PLACE WHICH- IN
THE FUTURE CONVERSATION HAPPY TO
DELVE MORE INTO AND WILL
CONTINUE BUILDING ON THAT
PROGRESS THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
I'VE FOR SURE AND I. SHE THE
CENTER NEWMAN WE ALL AGREE THAT
THIS ISSUE OF COMPLIANCE IS
REALLY CRITICAL UP AND DOWN THE
STATE. NO MATTER WHERE WE ARE SO
I APPRECIATE YOUR RAISING THAT
QUESTION AND WE WILL ADDRESS
THAT IN ANOTHER HEARING. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT- ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS ARE NEWMAN- WE MOVE ON
NOW TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH- TO
THE DEPARTMENT DUSTER RELATIONS
FROM. YOUR COMMENTS PRESENTATION
WE HAVE OUR FINAL ITEM FOR THE
DAY. IT INCLUDES MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS AND TO RELATED TO
THE STATE RETIREMENT-
LIABILITIES. WE HAVE-
REPRESENTATIVES FROM DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO PRESENT. AFTERNOON
ASSETS HOSPICE BERMAN FINANCE. I
WILL KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF- AND
THEN I'LL HAND OFF TO HER
COLLEAGUES TO DISCUSS.
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM. SO CALPERS
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES EIGHT
POINT FOUR MILLION. FOUR POINT
SEVEN BILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
THE STATUTORILY REQUIRED. ANNUAL
STATE CONTRIBUTION TO CALPERS
FOR THE STATE PENSION COSTS OF
THIS AMOUNT INCLUDES SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX MILLION
GENERAL FUND. THE STATE
UNIVERSITY RETIREMENT COSTS.
BUDGET ALSO REFLECTS THREE POINT
NINE BILLION IN CONSTITUTIONALLY
REQUIRED PROPOSITIONS YOU READ
EVERY PAYMENT FUNDING. THIS
INCLUDES THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION TO FURTHER REDUCE THE
STATE'S CALIFORNIA. SHOCK
UNFUNDED LIABILITY AS WELL AS
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE MILLION
TO THE GENERAL FUND PORTION OF
THE STATE EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTIONS
TO OTHER. POST EMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS. ALSO KNOWN AS- SO IT'S
A VERY HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW AND
OVER TWO RIGHT WIND. FOR AND
WILL BE A BILL. ALONG WITH THE
FOR QUITE AFTER HIS. HELLO RYAN
ONE BUT NO. THE STATE BUT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN THREE
POINTS BILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN STATE CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THE- TO THE COW STAR SYSTEM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM. THIS REFLECTS
A STATIC- STATE CONTRIBUTION
RATE THAT HAS NOT INCREASED
SINCE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO THIS
IS DUE TO THE FACT THAT GIVE THE
GREAT INVEST VETERANS YOU KNOW
THE LAST FEW YEARS COUNCIL IS
NOW ON TRACK TO ACHIEVE. FULLY
FUNDED STATUS BY TWENTY TWENTY
FOURTH WERE NOT FULLY FUNDED
STATUS BUT TO A LIMITED ON AT
UNFUNDED ACTUARIAL OBLIGATION BY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
AND ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT STRUCTURES YOUR
PROPOSITION TWO DEBT REPAYMENT
FUNDING WHICH SPEED UP THAT
PROCESS AND LEAD TO A FASTER
ELIMINATION STATE. CONTRIBUTION
RATE SO AS A RESULT THE STATE
INCOME STATES HAVE ELECTED TO
LEAVE THE STATE CONTRIBUTION AT
THE SAME AT WHICH IS RESULTING
IN A THREE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TREATMENT
ACOSTA IS THE. TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY. HAVING TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY ON THE- FOR.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH- OF THE
CA. ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
NO OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR MAKING
THE PRESENTATION- DEPARTMENT OF-
OF FINANCE WE NOW MOVE ON TO
ANYONE WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT REGARDING ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS THREE FIVE THREE ONE TWO
EIGHT THREE. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS- COMMITTEE
CHAIRS MANSA TO TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY TODAY I'M GOING TO ASK
THAT EVERYONE- PLEASE GIVE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
ARE AND WHERE YOU STAND ON THAT
ISSUE- NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
OF THE WITNESSES HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. GO AHEAD. AND I'M
CHAIRMAN OKAY IS IT ON WHAT. THE
TOWN MANAGER YES OUR CHRISTMAS
CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE
DO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ON THE REPAYMENT TO THE
U. I TRUST FUND DEFICIT- YES
THAT'S WHAT I WANTED TO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE AND FOR BEING
SO PATIENT- MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT AND
WOULD YOU PLEASE LET US KNOW HOW
MANY INDIVIDUALS ARE WAITING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT ON TODAY'S CALL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU A LINE NUMBER. AND ONE
MOMENT AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE DO
HAVE CURRENTLY. NINETEEN AND ARE
COMMON TO Q. AND THAT NUMBER IS
RISING. TWENTY ONE AT THIS TIME
. OKAY AGAIN I JUST WANT TO
REMIND EVERYONE TO THE STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION-
WHAT ISSUE IN YOUR POSITION ON
IT PLEASE SO THAT WE CAN GIVE
EVERYBODY THE OPPORTUNITY. TO BE
HEARD YOU WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE EVEN MORE
DETAIL BE TESTIMONY COULD
SUBMITTED IN WRITING SO THANK
YOU ALL MODERATOR PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU AND- NINE ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON AT
THIRTEEN CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER ON THE BOOKS CARE
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU TODAY
MY NAME IS CUT YOUR KEYS AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IF YOU EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE PROPOSED TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT TO SUPPORT
IMMIGRANT COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS
OUTLINED IN THE GOVERNMENT'S
PROPOSED BUDGET. IN ADDITION TO
THAT AS A MEMBER OF THE SAFETY
NET FOR ALL COALITION WE CALL ON
THE LEGISLATORS TO MAKE WORKERS
EXCLUDED FROM UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE A PRIORITY THIS YEAR
BUT PUTTING AN EXCLUDE WORKERS
PROGRAM THROUGH THEIR LABOR AS
WELL AS THEIR- SUPPORT IN PAYING
STATE AND LOCAL TAXES THE
WORKERS HAVE HELPED YOU
CALIFORNIA UP VOTE DURING. ONE
THE MOST DEVASTATING THAT THANK
AND EVEN RECENT HISTORY WE URGE
YOU TO HONOR THEIR THEIR AND
UNDER THEIR BY CREATING AN EXTRA
WORKERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR I'M VERY MUCH PLEASE. KEEP
IT TO YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION THE
ISSUE AND YOUR POSITION. ON IT
THANK YOU NEXT MODERATOR. FIND
SO YEAR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD.
BY TWENTY SEVEN YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO
LINE TWENTY FIVE LINE TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE-
ANYTHING THEY COULD HAVE STAMINA
CONNECTOR WITH THE RESTAURANT
OPPORTUNITIES CENTER- I'M IN
OAKLAND- HERE TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT YOU TWEETED WORKERS OF
THE PROGRAM- DOCKING WORKERS ARE
CRITICAL PARTY CONTINUES TO MAKE
THE STATE RUN. AND RUN FOR ALL
THE TIME BUT YOU DURING THE
PANDEMIC THEY NEED TO BEGIN WITH
SUPPORT AND RESPECT THAT THEY
DESERVE THE SUPPORT IS LONG
OVERDUE CAN GO A LONG WAY TO
TRANSFORM LIVES BY PLEASE URGE
THE COMMUNITY PUT THEIR SUPPORT
BEHIND STILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT PLEASE. ONE SO ZERO IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHEN I
THOUGHT ME NUMBER THERE BUT SET
UP GUARD YOUR WOMAN CAN GO BIT
ABOUT HOW BUT I LOVE BUILDING.
GET INTO HELLO HELLO I'M AN
EXCEL MCCARTY. I WILL A MODEL BY
DEVELOPMENT HE GOT ON CUT THAT
WERE I'M GOING TO ABOUT THE WE
DON'T IT'S A LITTLE BIT AT THE
BILL AND WILL NOT BE ON THE THAT
IF THEY ARE. A MOMENT ON IT
COULD NOT FOUND HELLO GENDER
DOCTOR OKAY DEMONSTRATED THIRTY
I LOVE THE YOU KNOW THAT THE
ONLY. HAVE A WHOLE LOT OF THE
DOESN'T IT GALA COULD NOT BE.
ONE STOP THREE THING BELL IN
THAT THAT AWFUL AGENT COASTAL
FORGET IT YEAH MUNIZ. WHICH IS
SUPER DIZZY BY SEALING GLASS YES
NEXT PLEASE. NINE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ORDER ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR ETP IN JOBS MY
COMMENTS ARE RELATED TO THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL IN THE
PROPOSED INCREASES AS OUTLINED
UNDER ISSUE SEVEN ON PAGE THIRTY
FOR THE AGENDA. OKAY EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL THE PREEMINENT
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM IN
THE STATE THE QUALITY
ADMINISTRATION TRADITIONAL
HUNDRED TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE PROGRAM. OUR POSITION IS
THAT MORE FLEXIBILITY IS
REQUIRED FOR THE NEW MONEY WE
ADVOCATE AT LEAST FIFTY OF A
HUNDRED TEN MILLION. THE OPEN
AND AVAILABLE TO ANY INDUSTRY OR
SECTOR CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE FOR
ETP THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
MODERATOR. NINE FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS FINALLY
MILAN WHAT THE COMMON NOT
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES CENTER
AND I AND RESIDENT IN WORKER
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING TO URGE
LEGISLATORS TO MAKE WORKERS
EXCLUDED FROM UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE A PRIORITY THIS YEAR.
ON A STATE DINNER FOR ALL THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR MUCH NEXT PLAY
. NINE FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR TOM SHE HE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LANDSCAPE CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION THE CALLING IT
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE ON PAGE THIRTEEN OF
YOUR AGENDA YEAH APPOINTMENT
INSURANCE FUND ISSUE. WE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO PAY
DOWN THAT DEFICIT BY ONE BILLION
THIS YEAR AN ADDITIONAL TWO
BILLION NEXT YEAR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU FOR CALLING
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
NEXT MODERATOR. NINE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DADDY GRANDMA HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE WFNZ COUNCIL IF
YOU HAVE YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED INVESTMENT
IN HIGH ROAD TRAINING PARTNER
STAFF ESPECIALLY IN FUNDING FOR
HEALTH CARE JOBS ADDITIONALLY
YOU HAVE THE W. WOULD LIKE TO
START STRONG SUPPORT. BUT IF I
DID INCREASE TO BE I. R.
COMPLIMENT CRITICAL WORKER
PROTECTION LAWS PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE INCLUDING SB SIX
AFFECTED EIGHTY SEVEN OH ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR- BREVITY. NEXT
MODERATOR. BLIND FAITH SIX YOUR
LINE OF THE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT WAS A ABOUT
THE AS YET YOU CALIFORNIA- THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY JUST
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF HE
GOVERNOR'S HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE%
PROPOSALS PARTICULARLY ONE SHORE
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLAR- INVESTMENT IN THE
HEALTHCARE H. R. T. P. FUNDING.
AS WELL AS SUPPORT FOR THE
NINETY MILLION OR EGP HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
ADDITIONALLY I WANT TO JUST CALL
OUT THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL. IN
SUPPORT FOR THE PUBLIC AFTER
WORK. AND ALSO- WE ARE SUPPORT
OF- NUMBER EIGHT TO ADDRESS THAT
- ADDITION. RETALIATION NEEDS
AND C. W. O. P. WORKOUT REACH
AND FINALLY SUPPORT FOR THE
SAFETY NET FOR ALL PROPOSAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR CALLING NEXT MODERATOR. NINE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS EDDIE GONZALEZ OUT WITH
WAREHOUSE WORKERS RESOURCE
CENTER. AND- GENE TO LEGISLATORS
TO MAKE WORKERS SCHOOL FROM ONE
EMPLOYMENT INSURANCE A PRIORITY
. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE
PROPOSAL OUTLINED IN ISSUE FIVE
THE THREE BILLION DOLLAR BAIL
OUT TO THE U. I FIND AND ARE
SUBMITTED LETTER EXPLAINS ALL
THE DETAILS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR CALLING MODERATOR NEXT. NINE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JOSH DUGGAR ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA ON
ISSUE TOO CHIAPAS AND THE
CALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT COALITION
APPRECIATE HELPING HUMAN
SERVICES WORKFORCE INVESTMENT WE
JUST ALSO EARNED YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF OUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX BILLION ONE TIME
PUBLIC HEALTH EQUITY IN REDDING
ADOPTION IT INITIATIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR CALLING NEXT
. MIND YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON REX W.
HÌNH ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
CALLING POINT ITEM BY THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET THREE
BILLION UP THE LIGHTS ON THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
NINE FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS ROBERT
WHICH REMAIN HAPPY CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S THREE BILLION
PROPOSAL TO HELP REDUCE ON
COMING- YOU LIKE TAX INCREASES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. NINE FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ON MY NAME IS
KATHY FONG I'M CALLING FROM
POWER SWITCH ACTION CALLING AT
THE PORT OF THREE ITEMS THE
CLEAN. ENOUGH FOR ALL COULD
WORKERS OFTEN TELL YOU CAN COME
IT AFTER UNIT AT TWENTY ONE
MILLION AND FUNDING HELP WITH
WHAT WHICH- SEE WHAT AT ONE HIGH
MILLION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT NINE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS A
PLEASE GO AHEAD I'M SORRY-
BEFORE YOU SPEAK MODERATOR HOW
MANY DO WE HAVE IN Q. AT THIS
TIME WE DO HAVE TWENTY STILL IN
QUEUE. OKAY I'M REALLY GONNA
HAVE TO ASK EVERYONE JUST YOUR
NAME. ORGANIZATION AND ISSUE YES
OR NO WE HAVE TO LEAVE HERE FOR
THE PROTOCOL THAT CLEANING ALL
WE HAVE TO LEAVE THIS ROOM SO.
WE'RE GOING TO CUT IT OFF AT THE
CURRENT NUMBER NO MORE. THANK
YOU. MY GUARDIAN MADAMS AFTER
MADAM CHAIR NARAL MEMBERS
SNAPPED TO CARLESS WITH THAT
STATIC LEGAL SERVICES IN SUPPORT
OF ISSUE EIGHT PARTICULARLY
ENFORCEMENT- SB. SIXTY TWO
BECOME A WORKER PROTECTION ACT
THANK YOU. WE'LL JUST YEAH. BOB
ONE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD- GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS RYAN ELAINE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED THREE
BILLION TO HELP YOU OUT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
pOF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FEDERATION OF LABOR WE ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS BY
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
WE ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT
PENDING OF PIR AND SUPPORT FOR
EXPANDED FUNDING FOR ANTI
RETALIATION. AND WORKER OUTREACH
PROGRAMS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. NINE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
BRIAN LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION IN SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
THREE BILLION DOLLARS TO REDUCE
THE U. I. TRANSPLANT ABSENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE
. NINE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
KATIE HANSON WITH A CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
AND THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
THREE BILLION TO HELP OFFSET YOU
I KINDA THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
CALLING NEXT PLEASE. NINE FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS LORD GETTING ON
THE UP THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION CALL AT THE PORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED THREE
BILLION TOWARD THE YOU GOING TO
SOLVENCY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. PINE SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CONNOR
MEDINA ON BEHALF OF ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSED THREE
BILLION FOR THE- I THOUGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO JENNIFER
MALLEY WITH A CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WERE CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE JUNE THE
GOVERNOR'S INVESTMENT IN A
TURKEY ARE YOU H. R. TV IN OTHER
PROGRAMS THE ETP FOR THE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE
FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON THEN
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE SHOULD
BRADY COLLINS WITH THE KOREATOWN
IMMIGRANT WORKERS ALLIANCE HE
WAS ALSO A MEMBER OF THE STATE
LIKE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
WORKER POWER CALLING IT SUPPORT.
AGENT SPECIFICALLY INCREASED
FUNDING FOR THE RETALIATION
COMPLAINT DESTINATION UNIT AND
CALIFORNIA WORKOUT WHICH PROGRAM
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE
. NINE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
KONG FENG DIRECTOR OF TRANSISTOR
TO SAN FRANCISCO AND MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
LOOK POWER CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM EIGHT FINE THE STATE'S ANTI
RETALIATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ANASTASIA CALL RIGHT AND- I WORK
WITH WORK FACE AND WE ARE A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WORKER POWER AS
WELL AND WE'RE CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF LINE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT- AND IN PARTICULAR AND
THAT WE'VE GOT YOUR BACK FROM
THE RETALIATION COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATION UNIT AND THAT THE
WHAT PROGRAMS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT PLEASE. ONE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M ALEX BERLINER
DIRECTOR BUT SEVEN CALIFORNIA
COAST OCCUPATIONAL THINKING AND
OF THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
POLITICAL POWER WE'RE ALSO
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF EIGHT TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR STATE AND
COUNTY SHOULD COST. AND PACIFIC
TO FIND THE STATE ARE UNIT CAN I
SEE WHAT AT A HUNDRED DOLLARS
THANK YOU. THANK NEXT PLEASE.
NINE SIXTY FOUR LINE IS A PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OKAY I'M THE BAY AND
IT'S HER WITH THE SUBJECT SERVER
CALLING TO- URGE LEDGE TO
WORKERS A- FROM SIMPLE INSURANCE
PRIOR THIS YEAR WE HOPE YOU WORK
FOR A TO BUILD AN ECONOMY THAT
PROTECTS ALL HEALTH WORKERS
THANK. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
NINE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON AUDIBLE CHAIR A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THOUGHT MOSTLY
QUALITY ASSOCIATED WITH YOUR
MIND APPOINTMENT COLOR COME ON
NUMBER THE CALIFORNIA. GLOBAL
THAT THE ALLOCATE SHOULD AN
OFFICIAL FIFTY MILLION A YEAR.
THE TOTAL IS TWENTY FIVE MILLION
PER YEAR OVER THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS BUT THE PROBLEM COULD
EXPAND THE TWENTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
. NINE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS JOKING AND- I'M AN ORGANIZER
WITH DECREE COUNT IN THE GRANT
WORKERS ALLIANCE. I'M CALLING
YOU AND- REPORT ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT- YOUR CURRENT INCOME
SUBCOMMITTEE TO ON TO THE STATE
AND I WOULD. PLAN AYE
RETALIATION OF TEXTURE AND TO-
TRIPLE THE IN THE SO THAT WE CAN
ADD. RESPOND TO SUPPORT
HEALTHCARE WORKERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU NECK PLEASE. SPLINES
YOUR LINE IS A PLEASE GO.
FINANCIAL MY NAME IS T.
EXCELLENCE WITH THE UC A LABOR
WERE ALSO MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WORKERS. CALL TO
SUPPORT NUMBER EIGHT PROJECT-
EDITION FUNDING FOR THE RETURN
CAN INVESTED NEXT WHICH A BACK
OF NEARLY TWO THOUSAND CASES OF
DEATH NEEDED STAFF AS WELL AS
FIFTY WHAT PROGRAMS THAT WERE WE
THANK SO MUCH THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR CALLING NEXT PLEASE.
MINDS THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
A- HELLO MY NAME IS TO. AND THE
EXTENT DIRECTOR OF THE QUEEN CAR
WASH WORKERS MEMBER OF THE OF
CAL CALL FOR POWER. CALLING
TRYING THE COMMITTEE TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR THE STATE ENTIRELY.
IMPOSTER NATIONALLY WE ARE YOU
TO A RETALIATION COMES.
INVESTIGATE UNIT AT TWENTY ONE
MILLION AND A CALIFORNIA WORKER
OUR PROGRAM YOU WANT. ONE
HUNDRED MILLION AND SUPPORT FOR
THE SAFETY NET FOR ALL COUPLES
WILL BE YOU. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING CEMEX PLEASE. MY SEVENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN PUT UP
MEMBER MY NAME IS JOHNNY NOW ON
THE UP OF THE- LAUNCH AND WHERE
YOU'RE- I. L. W. AND OF COURSE
THERE SIXTY TWO NINETY PORT. TO
PORT A ORDERS ALLOCATE OF ONE
HUNDRED TEN MILLION QUAKER MORE
TRAINING CENTER INCOME BECAUSE-
WE RESPECT ASK WHERE SUPPORT
THANK. THANK YOU FOR CALLING
NEXT PLEASE. AND WE'VE REACHED
THE LAST MINE THAT'S ABLE TO BE
IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME. NINE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MONEY IS MARIA AND
I HERE ON HOW OF THE ROOF
OPPORTUNITY CENTERS OF THE GAME
AND WITH. FIGURE FOR CLOSURE OF
YOUR DEMAND YOU SUPPORT. FOR
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET- ON THE
QUICKNESS RUNNING LOCKING WORKER
THANK YOU FOR MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THANK. I'M SORRY. ONE
MORE. OKAY MODERATE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR
WORK- AND HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SENATORS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. JUST WANT TO COMMEND
YOU ON RIGHT AFTER IT COULD
HEARING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SENATOR- AND I WANT TO
THANK. ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET FISCAL
COMMITTEE REVIEW COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO
US WE WANT INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU
EVERYONE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING
SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE IS ADJOURNED
THANK YOU.